online yet. Test. It just logged
in. So, thank you so much.
Test. Test. This is a caption
test.
I'm Neil, and as my capacity of
the president of the -- I would
like to
welcome you to a live stream
reading of
Frankenstein, as part of our
larger
Franken
reads program, we would like to
thank
the global community of nearly
700Franken reads partners,
including universities, public
libraries, schools,
and museums in 45 countries who
will be
participating during Franken
read,
October 24 through 31 bangs , by
planning public readings,
symposia and more.
We would like to thanks
Elizabeth Dolen for first
suggesting the idea fev
Franken
reads.
-- for their outstanding work on
the project. For special thanks
are due to the
library of congress for live
streaming
and organizing this reading and
for so crotchetyly hosting us in
this grand
historic space, the site of so
much brilliant research.
And finally, we'd like to thank
the national endowment for the
humanities, which made the whole
event possible through a
chairman's grant.
With that, I'll turn things over
to Mark, who has been a strong
pillar of
support throughout the project.
>> Thank you. I'll be as quick
as possible with my remarks, as
you'll be hearing my voice as
much today.
I would like to congratulate
Amanda, Neil, Stephanie, and
everyone involved
with this remarkable project. It
was done in the recognition that
the 200th anniversary of the
book is an
extraordinary reason to
celebrate the
vie brancy of the novel.
We're proud to support the
humanities whenever possible.
I read the book in high school,
and my
first deep dive with it came in
a graduate seminar with Neil,
where we
read the novel alongside works
like the
Matrix, and
things like that in the novel,
victor Frankenstein has a dream
about his future bride,
embracing her.
He soon realizes that with a
kiss, she
became vivid with the hue of
death, a
shroud envel lopping her form,
with
grave worms crawling in the
folds of
her flannel. If this train is
reversed, as it is in the story,
with the dead coming back to
life, it's a metaphor for what
the team has accomplished with
their own embrace of the novel's
power.
Frankenstein never died, and the
book remains one of the most
read in the world.
When I think about what this
project
has succeeded in doing with 600
partners in 49 countries, I
can't help but imagine the ways
that the novel is coming alive
again in a manner that it
has never had before.
I imagine voices speaking in
unison
with shelly's passions coming to
life, and occasionally, I would
like to think
a unity, a harmony.
But to the power of the words
themselves, the strange,
beautiful deepening mastery that
they hold when we speak them
aloud to each other.
I think it's no exaggeration to
say that this novel has never
been quite so human as it has
through the course of
the project, and how it has
today. Never did we expect it to
transform
into the monster that it has.
From the esteemed library of
congress herself, Carla.
>> Welcome to the library of
congress
and to Franken reads, part of
our
week-long celebration of the
200th
anniversary of Mary Sh
elley's Frankenstein this
all-day reading is being held in
the magnificent
reading room of the library's
Thomas
Jefferson
building.
>> Franken sign, volume one,
letter one. To Ms.
Seville, England, St.
PaidPetersberg, December
You will rejoice to hear that no
disaster has accompanied the
commencement of an enterprise
which you have regarded with
such evil forebodings.task is to
assure my dear sister of my
welfare and increasing
confidence in the success of my
undertaking.as I walk in the
streets of Petersburgh, I feel a
cold northern breeze play upon
my cheeks, which braces my
nerves and fills me with
delight.the regions towards
which I am advancing, gives me a
foretaste of those icy climes.
promise, my daydreams become
more fervent and vivid.
pole is the seat of frost and
desolation; it ever presents
itself to my imagination as the
region of beauty and delight.
ever visible, its broad disk
just skirting the horizon and
diffusing a perpetual splendour.
I will put some trust in
preceding navigators there snow
and frost are banished; and,
sailing over a calm sea, we may
be wafted to a land surpassing
in wonders and in beauty every
region hitherto discovered on
the habitable globe.
without example, as the
phenomena of the heavenly bodies
undoubtedly are in those
undiscovered solitudes.
which attracts the needle and
may regulate a thousand
celestial observations that
require only this voyage to
render their seeming
eccentricities consistent for
ever.
with the sight of a part of the
world never before visited, and
may tread a land never before
imprinted by the foot of man.
sufficient to conquer all fear
of danger
or death and
to induce me to commence this
laborious voyage with the joy a
child feels when he embarks in a
little boat, with his
holiday mates, on an expedition
of discovery up his native
river.
be false, you cannot contest the
inestimable benefit
which I shall confer on
all mankind, to the last
generation, by discovering a
passage near the pole to those
countries, to reach which at
present so many months are
requisite; or by ascertaining
the secret of the
magnet, which,
if at all possible, can only be
effected by an undertaking such
as mine.
agitation with which I began my
letter, and I feel my heart glow
with an
enthusiasm which
elevates me to heaven, for
steady purpose,a point on which
the soul may fix its
intellectual eye.dream of my
early years.
Thomas's library.
the various voyages which have
been made in the prospect of
arriving at the North Pacific
Ocean through the seas which
surround the pole.the voyages
made for purposes of discovery
composed the whole of our good
Uncle Thomas's library.These
volumes were my study day and
night, and my familiarity with
them
increased that regret
learning that my fatherâ ™s
dying
injunction had forbidden
my uncle to allow me to embark
in a seafaring life.the first
time, those poets whose
effusions
entranced my soul and lifted it
to heaven.lived in a paradise of
my own creation; I imagined that
I also might obtain a niche in
the temple where the names of
Homer and Shakespeare are
consecrated.
and how heavily I bore the
disappointment.
fortune of my
cousin, and my thoughts were
turned into the channel of their
earlier bent.
on my present undertaking.
which I dedicated myself to this
great enterprise.
several expeditions to the North
Sea; I voluntarily endured cold,
famine, thirst, and want of
sleep; I often worked harder
than the common sailors
during
the day and devoted my nights to
the study of mathematics, the
theory of
medicine, and those branches of
physical science from which a
naval adventurer might derive
the greatest practical
advantage.
under-mate in a Greenland
whaler, and acquitted myself to
admiration.
my captain offered me the second
dignity in the vessel and
entreated me to remain
with the greatest earnestness,
so valuable did he consider my
services.
deserve to accomplish some great
purpose?
and luxury, but I preferred
glory to
every
enticement that wealth placed in
my path.
but my hopes fluctuate,
and my spirits are often
depressed.
and difficult voyage, the
emergencies of which will demand
all my fortitude:  I am required
not only to raise the spirits of
others, but sometimes to sustain
my own, when theirs are failing.
sledges; the motion is pleasant,
and, in my opinion, far more
agreeable than that of an
English stagecoach.
you are wrapped in furs, a dress
which I have already adopted,
for there is a great difference
between walking the deck and
remaining seated motionless for
hours, when no exercise prevents
the blood from actually freezing
in your veins.
the post-road between
St. Petersburgh and Archangel.
fortnight or three weeks; and my
intention is to
hire a ship there, which can
easily be done by paying the
insurance for the owner, and to
engage as many
sailors as I think necessary
among those who are accustomed
to the whale-fishing.
of June; and when shall I
return?
answer this question?
perhaps years, will pass before
you and I may meet.
you, and save me, that I may
again and again testify my
gratitude for all your love and
kindness.
encompassed as I am by frost and
snow!
in collecting my
sailors; those whom I have
already engaged appear to be men
on whom I can depend and are
certainly possessed of dauntless
courage.
yet been able to satisfy,
and the absence of the object of
which I now feel as a most
severe evil, I have no friend,
Margaret:  When I am glowing
with the enthusiasm of success,
there will be none to
participate my joy; if I am
assailed by disappointment, no
one will endeavour to sustain me
in dejection.
paper, it is true; but that is a
poor medium for the
communication of feeling.
who could sympathise with me,
whose eyes would reply to mine.
sister, but I bitterly feel the
want of a friend.
courageous, possessed of a
cultivated as well as of a
capacious mind, whose tastes are
like my own, to approve or
amend my plans.
for the first fourteen years of
my life
I ran wild on a common and read
nothing but our Uncle Thomas'
books of voyages.
the celebrated poets of our own
country; but it was only when it
had ceased to be
in my power to derive its most
important benefits from such a
conviction that I perceived the
necessity of becoming acquainted
with more languages than that of
my native country.
more illiterate than many
schoolboys of fifteen.
that my daydreams are more
extended and magnificent, but
they want keeping; and I greatly
need a friend who would have
sense enough not to despise me
as romantic, and affection
enough for me to endeavour to
regulate my mind.
shall certainly find no friend
on the
wide ocean, nor even here in
Archangel, among merchants and
seamen.
dross of human nature, beat even
in these rugged bosoms.
of wonderful courage and
enterprise; he is madly desirous
of glory, or rather, to word my
phrase more characteristically,
of advancement in his
profession.
of national and professional
prejudices,
unsoftened by cultivation,
retains some of the noblest
endowments of humanity.
board a whale vessel; finding
that he was unemployed in this
city, I easily
engaged him to assist in my
enterprise.
disposition and is remarkable in
the ship for his gentleness and
the mildness of his discipline.
well-known integrity and
dauntless courage, made me very
desirous to engage him.
best years spent under your
gentle and feminine fosterage,
has so refined the groundwork of
my character that I cannot
overcome an intense distaste to
the usual brutality
exercised on
He saw his mistress once before
the destined ceremony; but she
was bathed in tears, and
throwing herself at his feet,
entreated him to spare her,
confessing at the same time that
she loved another, but that he
was poor, and that her father
would never consent to the
union.
suppliant, and on being informed
of the name of her lover,
instantly abandoned his pursuit.
money, on which he had designed
to pass the remainder of his
life; but he bestowed the whole
on his rival, together with the
remains
of his prize-money to purchase
stock, and then himself
solicited the young woman's
father to consent to her
marriage with her lover.
thinking himself bound in honour
to my
friend, who, when he found the
father inexorable, quitted his
country, nor returned until he
heard that his former mistress
was married according to her
inclinations.” you will exclaim.
uneducated:  He is as silent as
a Turk,
and a kind of ignorant
carelessness attends him, which,
while it renders his conduct the
more astonishing, detracts from
The interest.the interest and
sympathy which otherwise he
would command.
labour, to arrive at once at the
summit But this discovery was so
great and overwhelming that all
the steps by which I had been
progressively led to it were
obliterated, and I beheld only
the result.
but the spring promises well,
and it is considered as a
remarkably early season, so that
perhaps I may sail sooner than I
expected.sufficiently to confide
in my prudence and
considerateness whenever the
safety of others is committed to
my care.
on the near prospect of my
undertaking.
a conception of the trembling
sensation, half pleasurable and
half fearful, with which I am
preparing to depart.
“the land of mist
and snow,” but I shall kill no
albatross; therefore do not be
A LARMed by my
Shall I meet you again, after
having traversed immense seas,
and returned by the most
southern cape of Africa or
America?cannot bear to look on
the reverse of the picture.
by every opportunity:  I may
receive your letters on some
occasions when I need them most
to support my spirits.
never hear from me again.
Walton
To Mrs. Saville, England.
haste to say that I am safe—and
well advanced on my voyage.
merchantman now on its homeward
voyage from Archangel; more
fortunate than I, who may not
see
my native land, perhaps, for
many years.
purpose, nor do the floating
sheets of ice that continually
pass us, indicating
the dangers of the region
towards which
we are advancing, appear to
dismay them.
latitude; but it is the height
of summer, and although not so
warm as in
England, the southern gales,
which blow
us speedily towards those shores
which I so ardently desire to
attain, breathe a
degree of renovating warmth
which I had not expected.
that would make a figure in a
letter.
springing of a leak are
accidents which experienced
navigators scarcely remember
to record, and I shall be well
content
if nothing worse happen to us
during our voyage.
well as yours, I will not
rashly encounter danger.
us that I cannot forbear
recording it, although it is
very probable that you will see
me before these papers can come
into your possession.
by ice, which closed in the ship
on all sides, scarcely leaving
her the sea-room in which she
floated.especially as we were
compassed round by a very thick
fog.change would take place in
the atmosphere and weather.
away, and we beheld, stretched
out in
every direction, vast and
irregular plains of ice, which
seemed to have no end.
mind began to grow watchful with
anxious
thoughts, when a strange sight
suddenly attracted our attention
and diverted our solicitude from
our own situation.
fixed on a sledge and drawn by
dogs,
pass on towards the north, at
the distance of half a mile; a
being
which had the shape of a man,
but apparently of gigantic
stature, sat in the sledge and
guided the dogs.
traveller with our telescopes
until he was lost among the
distant inequalities of the ice.
miles from any land; but
this apparition seemed to denote
that it was not, in reality, so
distant as we had supposed.
impossible to follow his track,
which we had observed with the
greatest attention.
we heard the ground sea, and
before night the ice broke and
freed our ship.
morning, fearing to encounter in
the
dark those large loose
masses which float about after
the breaking up of the ice.
was light, I went upon deck and
found all the sailors busy on
one side of the vessel,
apparently talking to someone in
the sea.had seen before, which
had drifted towards us in the
night on a large fragment of
ice.was a human being within it
whom the sailors were persuading
to enter the vessel.
seemed to be, a savage
inhabitant of some undiscovered
island, but a European.
said, “Here is our captain, and
he will not allow you to perish
on the open sea.
On perceiving me, the stranger
addressed me in English,
although with a foreign accent.
said he, “will you have the
kindness to inform me whither
you are bound?
You may conceive my astonishment
on hearing such a question
addressed to me from a man on
the brink of destruction
and to whom I should have
supposed that my vessel would
have been a resource which he
would not have exchanged for the
most precious wealth the earth
can afford.
voyage of discovery towards the
northern pole.
and consented to come on board.
thus capitulated for his safety,
your surprise would have been
boundless.
body dreadfully emaciated by
fatigue and suffering.cabin, but
as soon as he had quitted the
fresh air he fainted.
deck and restored him to
animation by rubbing him with
brandy and forcing him to
swallow a small quantity.
wrapped him up in blankets and
placed him near the chimney of
the kitchen stove.
little soup, which restored him
wonderfully.he was able to
speak, and I often feared that
his sufferings had deprived him
of understanding.
I removed him to my own cabin
and attended on him as much as
my duty would permit.
creature:  His eyes have
generally an expression of
wildness, and even
madness, but there are moments
when, if anyone performs an act
of kindness towards him or does
him any the most trifling
service, his whole countenance
is
lighted up, as it were, with a
beam of
benevolence and sweetness that I
never saw equalled.
despairing, and sometimes he
gnashes his teeth, as if
impatient of the weight of woes
that oppresses him.
had great trouble to keep off
the men, who wished to ask him a
thousand
questions; but I would not allow
him to be tormented by their
idle curiosity, in a state of
body and mind whose restoration
evidently depended upon entire
repose.
he had come so far upon the ice
in so strange a vehicle.
aspect of the deepest gloom, and
he replied, “To seek one who
fled from me.
“And did the man whom you
pursued travel in the same
fashion?
“Then I fancy we have seen him,
for the day before we picked you
up we saw some dogs drawing a
sledge, with a man in it,
across the ice.
This aroused the stranger's
attention,
and he asked a multitude of
questions concerning the route
which the daemon, as he called
him, had pursued.
he said, “I have, doubtless,
excited
your curiosity, as well as that
of these good people; but you
are too considerate to make
inquiries.
“Certainly; it would indeed be
very impertinent and inhuman in
me to trouble you with any
inquisitiveness of mine.
“And yet you rescued me from a
strange and perilous situation;
you have benevolently restored
me to life.
Soon after this he inquired if I
thought that the breaking up of
the ice had destroyed the other
sledge.
any degree of certainty, for the
ice had
not broken until near midnight,
and the
traveller might have arrived at
a place of safety before that
time; but of this I could not
judge.
life animated the decaying frame
of the stranger.
be upon deck to watch for the
sledge which had before
appeared; but I have persuaded
him to remain in the cabin, for
he is far too weak to sustain
the rawness of the atmosphere.
watch for him and give him
instant notice if any new object
should appear in sight.this
strange occurrence up to the
present day.
health but is very silent and
appears uneasy when anyone
except myself enters his cabin.
gentle that the sailors are all
interested in him, although they
have had very little
communication with him.
a brother, and his
constant and deep grief fills me
with sympathy and compassion.his
better days, being even now in
wreck so attractive and amiable.
Margaret, that I should find no
friend on the wide ocean; yet I
have found a man who, before his
spirit had been broken by
misery, I should have been happy
to have possessed as the brother
of my heart.
concerning the stranger at
intervals, should I have any
fresh incidents to record.
pity to an astonishing degree.
destroyed by misery without
feeling the most poignant grief?
his mind is so cultivated, and
when he speaks, although his
words are culled with the
choicest art, yet they flow with
rapidity and unparalleled
eloquence.
his illness and is continually
on the deck, apparently watching
for the sledge that preceded his
own.utterly occupied by his own
misery but that he interests
himself deeply in the projects
of others.
mine, which I have communicated
to him
without
disguise.
Nor have I believed it
impossible to find a true
friend. I agree with you, and
believing that
friendship is not only
desirable, but a
possessable acquisition. To
judge respecting friendship.
You have hope in the world
before you, and have no cause
for despair. But I? I have lost
everything, and cannot begin
life anew.
As he said this, his countenance
become expressive of grief.
Broken in spirit as he is, no
one can feel more deeply than he
does the beauties of nature.
can feel more deeply than he
sight afforded by these
wonderful regions seem still to
have the power of
elevating his soul from earth.
may suffer misery and be
overwhelmed by disappointments,
yet when he has retired into
himself, he will be like a
celestial spirit that has a halo
around him, within whose circle
no grief or folly ventures.
express concerning this divine
wanderer?
Yet, if you will, smile at the
warmth
of my expression, while I find
every day new causes for
repeating them.
may easily perceive, Captain
Walton, that I have suffered
great and unparalleled
misfortunes.memory of these
evils should die with me, but
you have won me to alter my
determination.once did; and I
ardently hope that the
gratification of your wishes may
not be a serpent to sting you,
as mine has been.
disasters will be useful
To you.
Yell yet if you are inclined,
listen to my tale.
Internal evidence of the truth
of the events of which it is
composed.
You may easily concede that I
was much gratified by the
awkward communication,
yet I could not concur that he
should renew his grief.
the promised narrative, partly
from curiosity and partly from a
strong desire to ameliorate his
fate if it were I wait but for
one event, and then I shall
repose in peace.
he, perceiving that I wished to
interrupt him; “but you are
mistaken, my friend, if thus you
will allow me to name you;
nothing can alter my destiny;
listen to my history, and you
will perceive how irrevocably it
is determined.
”his narrative the next day when
I should be at leisure.
when I am not imperatively
occupied by my duties, to
record, as nearly as possible in
his own words, what he has
related during the day.
you the greatest pleasure; but
to me,
who know him, and who hear it
from his own lips—with what
interest and sympathy shall I
read it in some future day!
my family is one of the most
distinguished of that republic.
counsellors and syndics, and my
father had filled several public
situations He was respected by
all who knew him for his
integrity and indefatigable
attention to public business.
occupied by the affairs of his
country;
a variety of circumstances had
prevented his marrying early,
nor was it until the decline of
life that he became a husband
and the father of a family.
illustrate his character, I
cannot refrain from relating
them.
merchant who, from a Fe
flourishing state, fell, through
numerous mischances, into
poverty.
of a proud and unbending
disposition and could not bear
to live in poverty and oblivion
in the same country where he had
formerly been distinguished for
his rank and magnificence.
the most honourable manner, he
retreated
with his daughter to the town of
Lucerne, where he lived unknown
and in wretchedness.
truest friendship and was deeply
grieved by his retreat in these
unfortunate circumstances.
which led his friend to a
conduct so little worthy of the
affection that united them.him
out, with the hope of persuading
him to begin the world again
through his credit and
assistance.
to conceal himself, and it was
ten months before my father
discovered his abode.
hastened to the house, which was
situated in a mean street near
the Reuss.
despair alone welcomed him.
of money from the wreck of his
fortunes,
but it was sufficient to provide
him with sustenance for some
months, and in the meantime he
hoped to procure some
respectable employment in a
merchant's house.
in inaction; his grief only
became more deep and rankling
when he had leisure
for reflection, and at length it
took so fast hold of his mind
that at the end of three months
he lay on a bed of sickness,
incapable of any exertion.
greatest tenderness, but she saw
with despair that their little
fund was rapidly decreasing and
that there was no other prospect
of support.of an uncommon mould,
and her courage rose to support
her in her adversity.
straw and by various means
contrived to
earn a pittance scarcely
sufficient to support life.
more entirely occupied in
attending him; her means of
subsistence decreased; and in
the tenth month her
father died in her arms, leaving
her an orphan and a beggar.knelt
by Beaufort's coffin weeping
bitterly, when my father entered
the chamber.
poor girl, who committed herself
to his care; and after the
interment of his friend he
conducted her to Geneva and
placed her under the protection
of a relation.
between the ages of my parents,
but this
circumstance seemed to unite
them only closer in bonds of
devoted affection.
father's upright mind which
rendered it necessary that he
should Perhaps during former
years he had suffered from the
late-discovered unworthiness of
one beloved and so was disposed
to set a greater value on tried
worth.worship in his attachment
to my mother, differing wholly
from the doting fondness of age,
for it was inspired by reverence
for her virtues and a desire to
be the means of, in some degree,
recompensing her for the sorrows
she had endured, but which gave
inexpressible grace to his
behaviour to her.
her wishes and her convenience.
exotic is sheltered by the
gardener, from every rougher
wind and to surround her with
all that could tend to excite
pleasurable emotion in her soft
and benevolent mind.of her
hitherto constant spirit, had
been shaken by what she had gone
through.previous to their
marriage my father had gradually
relinquished all his public
functions; and immediately after
their
union they sought the pleasant
climate of Italy, and the change
of scene and interest attendant
on a tour through that land of
wonders, as a restorative for
her weakened frame.
Naples, and as an infant Fe
accompanied them in their
rambles.other, they seemed to
draw inexhaustible
stores of
affection from a very mine of
love to bestow them upon me.
father's smile of benevolent
pleasure while regarding me are
my first recollections.
no one could submit more
gracefully to constraint.
Her person was the image of her
mind. Her hazel eyes, although
as lively as a bird's, possessed
an attractive softness.
Her figure was light and airy,
and
though capable of enduring great
fatigue, she appeared the most
fragile
creature in
the world.
I never saw so
much grace.
I was more calm and
philosophical than
my companion, yet me temper was
not so yielding.
My application was of longer
endurance, but it was not so
severe. I delighted in
investigating the facts relative
to the actual world. She busied
herself in following the
aerial creations of the
The world was to me a secret
which I desired to divine.
My brothers were considerably
younger than myself. But I had a
friend.
Henry was the son of a merchant
of Geneva, an intimate friend of
my father. He was a boy of
singular talent and fancy. I
remember when he was 9 years
old, he
wrote a fairy tail, which was
the
delight and amazement of all of
his companions. When I was very
young, I remember that
we used to act plays composed by
him out of these favorite books.
The principle characters were
Orlando,
Robin hood,
Amades, and St. George. Our
studies were never forced.
And by some means we always had
an end placed in view which
excited us in the prosecution of
them. It was by this method, and
not by emulation that we were
urged to application.
Elizabeth was not incited to
apply herself to drawing that
her companions
might not outstrip her, but
through her desire of pleasing
her aunt by the reputation of
some favorite scene done by her
own hand.  We learned Latin and
English that we
might read the writings in those
languages. We loved application,
and our
amusements would have been the
labors of other children.
Perhaps we did not learn
languages so quickly as those
who are disciplined by the
ordinary methods, but what we
learned was impressed more
deeply on our memories.  In this
description, I include Henry,
for he was constantly with us.He
went to school with me and
generally passed the afternoon
at our house.
For being an only child and
destitute of our companions at
home -- that he should find
associates at our house, and
we were never completely happy
when he
was
absent.
I feel pleasure when recounting
my
childhood.
For when I would account to
myself for
the birth of my passion, I find
it arise like a mountain river
from a noble and
almost forgotten sources. But
swelling, it became the torrent,
which in its course, has swept
away all of my hopes and joys.
Natural philosophy is the genius
that
has regulated my fate. I desire
to state those facts.
When I was 13 years of age, we
all
went on a party of pleasure.
In this house, I chanced to find
a
volume of the works of  of
Cornelius Agripa. The wonderful
facts he would relate
changed the feeling
I opened it with apathy; the
theory which he attempts to
demonstrate and the wonderful
facts which he relates soon
changed this feeling into
enthusiasm.mind, and bounding
with joy, I communicated my
discovery to my father.
title page of my book and said,
“Ah!
upon this; it is sad trash.
If, instead of this remark, my
father had taken the pains to
explain to me that the
principles of Agrippa had been
entirely exploded and that a
modern system of science had
been introduced which possessed
much greater powers than
the ancient, because the powers
of the
latter were chimerical, while
those of the former were real
and practical, under such
circumstances I should certainly
have thrown Agrippa aside and
have contented my imagination,
warmed as it was, by returning
with greater ardour to my former
studies.
my ideas would never have
received the fatal impulse that
led to my ruin.
taken of my volume by no means
assured me that he was
acquainted with its contents,
and I continued to read with the
greatest avidity.
to procure the whole works of
this author, and afterwards of
Paracelsus and Albertus Magnus.
these writers with delight; they
appeared to me treasures known
to few besides myself.
these secret stores of knowledge
my
father, yet his indefinite
sincere of my favorite always
withheld me.
I disclosed my discoveries to
Elizabeth, therefore, under a
promise of
strict
secrecy.
It may appear strange that a
discipline
of Albetus Magnus should arise.
I entered where the greatest
diligence
into the search of the
philosopher's stone and the
elixir of life.
But the latter obtained my most
undivided attention. Wealth was
an inferior object.
But what glory would attend the
Wealth was an inferior object,
but what glory would attend the
discovery if I could banish
disease from the human frame and
render man invulnerable to any
but a violent death!promise
liberally accorded by my
favourite authors, the
fulfilment of which I most
eagerly sought; and if my
incantations were always
unsuccessful, I
attributed the failure rather to
my own inexperience and mistake
than to a want of skill or
fidelity in my instructors.
exploded systems,
mingling, like an unadept, a
thousand contradictory theories
and floundering desperately in a
very slough of multifarious
knowledge, guided by an ardent
imagination and childish
reasoning, till an accident
again
changed the current of my ideas.
had retired to our house near
Belrive, when we witnessed a
most violent and terrible
thunderstorm.
of Jura, and the thunder burst
at once I remained, while the
storm lasted, watching its
progress with curiosity and
delight.beheld a stream of fire
issue from an old and beautiful
oak which stood about twenty
yards from our house; and so
soon as the dazzling light
vanished, the oak had
disappeared, and nothing
remained but a blasted stump.
found the tree shattered in a
singular manner.
Before this I was not
unacquainted with the more
obvious laws of electricity.
research in natural philosophy
was with us, and excited by this
catastrophe, he entered on the
explanation of a theory which he
had formed on the subject of
electricity and galvanism, which
was at once new and astonishing
to me.
had retired to our house near
Belrive, when we witnessed a
most violent and terrible
thunderstorm.of Jura, and the
thunder burst at once I
remained, while the storm
lasted, watching its progress
with curiosity and delight.
beheld a stream of fire issue
from an old and beautiful oak
which stood about
twenty
yards from our house; and so
soon as the dazzling light
vanished, the oak had
disappeared, and nothing
remained but a blasted stump.
found the tree shattered in a
singular manner.
entirely reduced to thin ribbons
of wood.
research in natural philosophy
was with us, and excited by this
catastrophe, he entered on the
explanation of a theory which he
had formed on the subject of
electricity and galvanism, which
was at once new and astonishing
to me.
He made a kite with a wire and
string,
which drew down that fluid from
the clouds.
This last stroke completed the
overthrow of Cornelius Agrippa,
Albertus Magnus, and Paracelsus,
the lords of my imagination; but
by some fatality the overthrow
of these men disinclined me to
pursue my accustomed studies.
inclined to commence the study
of any modern system. And this
disinclination was influenced
by the following circumstance:
My father expressed a wish that
I should attend a
course of lectures upon natural
philosophy, to which I
cheerfully
consented. The lecture, being
therefore one of the
last, was entirely
incomprehensible to me.
The professor discoursed with
the
greatest fluency of potassium,
Boran, and terms to which I
could have fixed no idea. And I
became disgusted with the
science
of natural
philosophy. My occupations at
this age were principally the
mathematics.
And most of the branchs of study
are pertaining to that science.
I was busily employed in
learning
languages. Latin was already
familiar to me, and I
began to read some of the
easiest Greek authors without
the help of a lexicon. I also
perfectly understood English and
German.
This is the list of my
accomplishments at the age of
17.
And you may conceive that my
hours were
fully employed in acquireg and
maintaining a knowledge of this
various literature.
Another task also devolved upon
me when I
became the instructor of my
brothers.
William, the youngest of our
family, was yet an infant, and
the most
beautiful little fellow in
the world.
Such was the domestic circle
from which
the care and pain seemed forever
vanished.
My father directed our studies,
and my
mother partook of our
enjoyments.
Neither of us possessed the
slightest
preeminence over the other.  The
voices of command was never
heard amongst us.
But mutual affection
gaged us all to comply with and
obey the
slightest desire of
each other.
>> When I attained the sage of
17, my
parents resolved that I should
become
Geneva, but my father thought it
necessary for the completion of
my education that I should be
made acquainted with other
customs than those of my native
country.
early date, but before the day
resolved upon could arrive, the
first misfortune
of my life
occurred—an omen, as it were, of
my future misery.
her illness was severe, and she
was in the greatest danger.
quickly recovered.
During her confinement many
arguments had been urged to
persuade my mother to refrain
from attending upon her.
entreaties, but when she heard
that the life of her favourite
was menaced, she could no longer
control her anxiety.
attentions triumphed over the
malignity
of the distemper—Elizabeth was
saved, but the consequences of
this imprudence were fatal to
her preserver.her fever was
accompanied by the most alarming
symptoms, and the looks of her
medical attendants
prognosticated the worst event.
and benignity of this best of
women did not desert her.
hopes of future happiness were
placed on the prospect of your
union.
Elizabeth, my love, you must
supply my place to my younger
children.
you; and, happy and beloved as I
have been, is it not hard to
quit you all?
me; I will endeavour to resign
myself cheerfully to death and
will indulge a
hope of
meeting you in another world.
”
countenance expressed affection
even in death.those whose
dearest ties are rent by
that most irreparable
evil, the void that presents
itself to the soul, and the
despair that is exhibited on the
countenance.persuade itself that
she whom we saw every day and
whose very existence appeared a
part of our own can have
departed for
ever—that the brightness of a
beloved eye can have been
extinguished and the sound of a
voice so familiar and dear to
the ear can be hushed, never
more to be heard.
first days; but when the lapse
of time proves the reality of
the evil, then the actual
bitterness of grief commences.
hand rent away some dear
connection?
which all have felt, and must
feel?
grief is rather an indulgence
than a necessity; and the smile
that plays upon
the lips, although it may be
deemed a
sacrilege, is not banished.
still duties which we ought to
perform; we must continue our
course
with the rest and learn to think
ourselves fortunate whilst one
remains whom the spoiler has not
seized.
which had been deferred by these
events, was now again determined
upon.
leave the repose, akin to death,
of the house of mourning and to
rush into the thick of life.
those that remained to me, and
above all, I desired to see my
sweet Elizabeth in some degree
consoled.
to act the comforter to us all.
its duties with courage and
zeal.
whom she had been taught to call
her uncle and cousins.
time, when she recalled
She forgot even her own regret
in her endeavours to make us
forget.
father to permit him to
accompany me and to become my
fellow student, but in vain.and
saw idleness and ruin in the
aspirations and ambition of his
son.
being debarred from a liberal
education.
read in his kindling eye and in
his animated glance a restrained
but firm resolve not to be
chained to the
miserable details of commerce.
each other nor persuade
ourselves to say the word
“Farewell!” It was said, and we
retired under the pretence of
seeking repose, each fancying
that the other was deceived; but
when at morning's dawn I
descended to the carriage which
was to convey me
away, they were
all there—my father again to
bless me, Clerval to press my
hand once more, my Elizabeth to
renew her entreaties that I
would write often and to bestow
the last feminine attentions on
her playmate and friend.to
convey me away and indulged in
the most melancholy reflections.
by amiable companions,
continually engaged in
endeavouring to bestow mutual
pleasure—I was now alone.
must form my own friends and be
my own protector.
remarkably secluded and
domestic, and this had given me
invincible repugnance to new
countenances.
Clerval; these were “old
familiar faces,” but I believed
myself totally unfitted for the
company of strangers.my journey;
but as I proceeded, my spirits
and hopes
rose.
it hard to remain during my
youth cooped up in one place and
had longed to enter the world
and take my station among other
human beings.
it would, indeed, have been
folly to repent.
these and many other reflections
during my journey to Ingolstadt,
which was long and fatiguing.
I alighted and was conducted to
my solitary apartment to spend
the evening as I pleased.of
introduction and paid a visit to
some of the principal
professors.the Angel of
Destruction, which asserted
omnipotent sway over me from the
moment I turned my reluctant
steps from my father's door—led
me first to M. Krempe, professor
of natural philosophy.
imbued in the secrets of his
science.
concerning my progress in the
different branches of science
appertaining to natural
philosophy.contempt, mentioned
the names of my
time in studying such nonsense?
”
instant that you have wasted on
those books is utterly and
entirely lost.exploded systems
and useless names.
lived, where no one was kind
enough to inform you that these
fancies which you have so
greedily imbibed are a thousand
years old and as I little
expected, in this enlightened
and scientific age, to find a
disciple of Albertus Magnus and
Paracelsus.
So saying, he stepped aside and
wrote down a list of several
books treating of
natural philosophy which he
desired me to procure, and
dismissed me after mentioning
that in the beginning of the
following week he intended to
commence a
course of lectures upon natural
philosophy in its general
relations, and that M.
Waldman,
a fellow professor, would
lecture upon chemistry the
alternate days that he omitted.
have said that I had long
considered those authors useless
whom the professor
reprobated; but I
returned not at all the more
inclined to recur to these
studies in any shape.
Krempe was a little squat man
with a gruff voice and a
repulsive countenance;
the teacher, therefore, did not
prepossess me in favour of his
pursuits.
connected a strain, perhaps, I
have given an account of the
conclusions I
had come to concerning them in
my early years.
the results promised by the
modern professors of natural
science.
accounted for by my extreme
youth and my want of a guide on
such matters, I had retrod the
steps of knowledge along the
paths of time and exchanged the
discoveries of recent inquirers
for the dreams of forgotten
alchemists.
of modern natural philosophy.
of the science sought Fe
immortality and power; such Fe
views, although futile, The
ambition of the inquirer seemed
to limit itself to the
annihilation of those visions on
which my interest in science was
chiefly founded.boundless
grandeur for realities of little
worth.first two or three days of
my residence at Ingolstadt,
which were chiefly spent in
becoming acquainted with the
localities and the principal
residents in my new abode.
thought of the information which
M. Krempe had given me
concerning the lectures.and hear
that little conceited fellow
deliver sentences out of a
pulpit, I recollected what he
had said of M.
Waldman, whom I had never
seen, as he had hitherto been
out of town.idleness, I went
into the lecturing room, which
M. Waldman entered shortly
after.
age, but with an aspect
expressive of the greatest
benevolence; a few grey hairs
covered his temples, but those
His person was short but
remarkably erect and his voice
the sweetest I had ever heard.
recapitulation of the history of
chemistry and the various
improvements made by different
men of learning, pronouncing
with fervour the names of the
most distinguished discoverers.
present state of the science and
explained many of its elementary
terms.
experiments, he concluded with a
panegyric upon modern chemistry,
the terms of which I shall
“The ancient teachers of this
science,” said he, “promised
impossibilities and performed
nothing.
little; they know that metals
cannot be transmuted and that
the elixir of life is a chimera
but these philosophers,
whose hands seem only made to
dabble in dirt, and their eyes
to pore over the microscope or
crucible, have indeed performed
miracles.
nature and show how she works in
her hiding-places.
discovered how the blood
circulates, and the nature of
the air we breathe.
unlimited powers; they can
command the thunders of heaven,
mimic the earthquake, and even
mock the invisible world with
its own shadows.Such were the
professor's words—rather let me
say such the words of the
fate—enounced to destroy me.
grappling with a palpable enemy;
one by
one the various keys were
touched which formed the
mechanism of my being; chord
after chord was sounded, and
soon my mind was filled with one
thought, one conception, one
purpose.
soul of Frankenstein—more, far
more, will I achieve; treading
in the steps already marked, I
will pioneer a new way, explore
unknown powers, and unfold to
the world the deepest mysteries
of creation.
insurrection and turmoil; I felt
that order would thence arise,
but I had no power to produce
it.There only remained a
resolution to return to my
ancient studies and to devote
myself to a science for which I
believed myself to possess a
natural talent.mild and
attractive than in public, for
there was a certain dignity in
his mien during his lecture
which in his own house was
replaced by the greatest
affability and kindness.account
of my former pursuits as I had
given to his fellow professor.
narration concerning my studies
and smiled at the names of
Cornelius Agrippa and
Paracelsus, but without the
contempt that M. Krempe had
exhibited.
indefatigable zeal modern
philosophers were indebted for
most of the foundations of their
knowledge.to give new names and
arrange in connected
classifications the facts which
they in a great degree had been
the instruments of bringing to
light.
erroneously directed, scarcely
ever fail in ultimately turning
to the solid advantage of
mankind.” I listened to his
statement, which was delivered
without any presumption or
affectation, and then added that
his lecture had removed my
prejudices against modern
chemists; I expressed myself in
measured terms, with the
modesty and deference due from a
youth
to his instructor, without
letting escape any of the
enthusiasm which stimulated my
intended labours.
Chemistry is that branch of
natural philosophy in which the
greatest improvements have been
and may be made; it is on that
account that I have made it my
peculiar study; but at the same
time, I have not neglected the
A man would make but a very
sorry chemist if he attended to
that department of human
knowledge alone.of science and
not merely a petty
experimentalist, I
should advise you to apply to
every branch of natural
philosophy, including
mathematics.He then took me into
his laboratory and explained to
me the uses of his various
machines, instructing me as to
what I ought to procure and
promising me the
use of his own when I should
have advanced far enough in the
science not to derange their
mechanism.
I had requested, and I took my
leave.
me; it decided my future
destiny.
particularly chemistry, in the
most comprehensive sense of the
term, became nearly my sole
occupation.of genius and
discrimination, which modern
inquirers have written on these
subjects.
cultivated the acquaintance of
the men of science of the
university, and I found even in
M. Krempe a great deal of sound
sense and real information,
combined, it is true,
with a repulsive physiognomy and
manners, but not on that account
the less valuable. Waldman I
found a true friend.
by dogmatism, and his
instructions were given with an
air of frankness and good nature
that banished every idea of
pedantry.
inclined me more to that branch
of philosophy than the love for
the science itself.
The more fully I entered into
science, the more I pursued it
for its own sake.
That application now became so
aridenned and eager that the
stars often disappeared in the
light of morning. As I applied
so closely, and maybe
easily conceived that I improved
My ardour was indeed the
astonishment of the students,
and my proficiency that of the
masters.
sly smile, how Cornelius Agrippa
went on, whilst M.
Waldman expressed the most
heartfelt exultation in my
progress.
which I paid no visit to Geneva,
but was engaged, heart and soul,
in the pursuit of some
discoveries which I hoped to
make.
them can conceive of the
enticements of science.
others have gone before you, and
there is nothing more to know;
but in a scientific pursuit
there is continual food for
discovery and wonder.
which closely pursues one study
must
infallibly arrive at great
proficiency in that study; and
I, who continually sought the
attainment of one object of
pursuit and was solely wrapped
Fe up in this, improved so
rapidly that at the end of two
years I made some discoveries in
the improvement of some chemical
instruments, which procured me
great esteem and admiration at
the university.
had become as well acquainted
with the theory and practice of
natural philosophy as depended
on the lessons of
any of the professors at
Ingolstadt, my
residence there being no longer
conducive to my improvements, I
thought of returning to my
friends and my native town, when
an incident happened that
protracted my stay.
peculiarly attracted my
attention was the structure of
the human frame, and, indeed,
any animal endued with life.
principle of life proceed?
has ever been considered as a
mystery; yet with how many
things are we upon the
brink of becoming acquainted, if
cowardice or carelessness did
not restrain our inquiries.
mind and determined thenceforth
to apply myself more
particularly to those branches
of natural philosophy which
relate to physiology.
supernatural enthusiasm, my
application
to this study would have been
irksome and almost intolerable.
first have recourse to death.
anatomy, but this was not
sufficient; I must also observe
the natural decay and corruption
of the human body.
taken the greatest precautions
that my mind should be impressed
with no supernatural horrors.at
a tale of superstition or to
have feared the apparition of a
spirit.
and a churchyard was to me
merely the receptacle of bodies
deprived of life,
which, from being the seat of
beauty and strength, had become
food for the worm.
cause and progress of this decay
and forced to spend days and
nights in vaults and
charnel-houses.
object the most insupportable to
the
delicacy of the human feelings.
degraded and wasted; I beheld
the
corruption of death succeed to
the blooming cheek of life; I
saw how the worm inherited the
wonders
of the eye and brain.
the minutiae of causation, as
exemplified in the change from
life to death, and death to
life,
until from the midst of this
darkness a sudden light broke in
upon me—a light so brilliant and
wondrous, yet so simple, that
while I became dizzy with the
immensity of the prospect which
it illustrated, I was surprised
that among so many men of
genius who had directed their
inquiries towards the same
science, that I alone should be
reserved to discover so
astonishing a secret.
shine in the heavens than that
which I now affirm is true.
it, yet the stages of the
discovery were distinct and
probable.
labour and fatigue, I succeeded
in discovering the cause of
generation and
life; nay, more, I became myself
capable of
bestowing animation upon
lifeless matter.
experienced on this discovery
soon gave place to delight and
rapture.labour, to arrive at
once at the summit of my desires
was the most gratifying
consummation of my toils.
overwhelming that all the steps
by which
I had been progressively led to
it were obliterated, and I
beheld only the result.
the wisest men since the
creation of the world was now
within my grasp.
opened upon me at once:  The
information I had obtained was
of a nature rather to direct my
endeavours so soon as I should
point
them towards the object of my
search than to exhibit that
object already accomplished.
been buried with the dead and
found a
passage to life, aided only by
one glimmering and seemingly
ineffectual light.
and hope which your eyes
express, my friend, that you
expect to be informed of the
secret with which I am
acquainted; that cannot be;
listen patiently until the end
of my story, and you will easily
perceive why I am reserved upon
that subject.
ardent as I then was, to your
destruction and infallible
misery.
at least by my example, how
dangerous is
the acquirement of knowledge and
how much happier that man is who
believes his native town to be
the world, than he
who aspires to become greater
than his nature will allow.
placed within my hands, I
hesitated a long time concerning
the manner in which I should
employ it.
bestowing animation, yet to
prepare a
frame for the
reception of it, with all its
intricacies of fibres, muscles,
and
veins, still remained a work of
inconceivable difficulty and
labour.
attempt the creation of a
being like myself, or one of
simpler organization; but my
imagination was too much exalted
by my first success to permit me
to doubt of my ability to give
life to an animal as complex and
wonderful as man.command hardly
appeared adequate to so arduous
an undertaking, but I doubted
not that I should ultimately
succeed.
reverses; my operations might be
incessantly baffled, and at last
my work
be imperfect, yet when I
considered the improvement which
every day takes
place in science and mechanics,
I was encouraged to hope my
present attempts would at least
lay the foundations of future
success.
magnitude and complexity of my
plan as any argument of its
impracticability.the creation of
a human being.
great hindrance to my speed, I
resolved,
contrary to my first intention,
to make the being of a gigantic
stature, that is to say,
about eight feet
in height, and proportionably
After having formed this
determination and having spent
some months in successfully
collecting and arranging my
materials, I began.
feelings which bore me onwards,
like a
hurricane, in the first
enthusiasm of success.
bounds, which I should first
break through, and pour a
torrent of light into our dark
world.
creator and source; many happy
and excellent natures would owe
their being to me.
his child so completely as I
should deserve theirs.
that if I could bestow animation
upon lifeless matter, I might in
process of time renew
life where death had apparently
devoted the body to corruption.
while I pursued my undertaking
with unremitting ardour.
my person had become emaciated
with confinement.
certainty, I failed; yet still I
clung to the hope which the next
day or the next hour might
realise.
possessed was the hope to which
I had dedicated myself; and the
moon gazed on my midnight
labours, while, with
unrelaxed
and breathless eagerness, I
pursued nature to her
hiding-places.
secret toil as I dabbled among
the unhallowed damps of the
grave or tortured the living
animal to animate the lifeless
clay?
with the remembrance; but then a
resistless and almost frantic
impulse
urged me
forward; I seemed to have lost
all soul or sensation but for
this one pursuit.
that only made me feel with
renewed
acuteness so soon
as, the unnatural stimulus
ceasing to operate, I had
returned to my old habits.
and disturbed, with profane
fingers, the
tremendous secrets of the human
frame.
at the top of the house, and
separated from all the other
apartments by a gallery and
staircase, I
kept my workshop of
filthy creation; my eyeballs
were starting from their sockets
in attending
The dissecting room and the
slaughter-house furnished many
of my materials; and often did
my human nature turn with
loathing from my occupation,
whilst, still urged on by an
eagerness which perpetually
increased, I brought my work
near to a conclusion.
was thus engaged, heart and
soul, in one pursuit.
did the fields bestow a
more plentiful harvest or the
vines yield a more luxuriant
vintage, but my eyes were
insensible to the charms of
nature.
neglect the scenes around me
caused me
also to forget those
friends who were so many miles
absent, and whom I had not seen
for so long a time.
I well remembered the words of
my father:  “I know that while
you are
pleased with
yourself you will think of us
with affection, and we shall
hear regularly from you.
any interruption in your
correspondence as a proof that
your other duties are
equally neglected.
I knew well therefore what would
be my father's feelings, but I
could not tear my thoughts from
my employment, loathsome in
itself, but which had taken an
irresistible hold of my
imagination.
all that related to my feelings
of affection until the great
object, which swallowed up every
habit of my nature, should be
completed.
unjust if he ascribed my neglect
to vice or faultiness on my
part, but I am now convinced
that he was justified in
conceiving that I should not be
altogether free from blame.
ought always to preserve a calm
and peaceful mind and never to
allow passion
or a transitory desire to
disturb his tranquillity.
of knowledge is an exception to
this rule.
yourself has a tendency to
weaken your affections and to
destroy your taste for
those simple pleasures in which
no alloy can possibly mix, then
that study is
certainly unlawful, that is to
say, not befitting the human
mind.
observed; if no man allowed any
pursuit
whatsoever to interfere with the
tranquillity of his domestic
affections, Greece had not been
enslaved, Caesar would have
spared his country, America
would have been discovered more
gradually, and the
empires of
But I forget that I am
moralizing in the most
interesting part of my tale, and
your looks remind me to proceed.
letters and only took notice of
my silence by inquiring into my
occupations more particularly
than before.during my labours;
but I did not watch
the blossom
or the expanding leaves—sights
which before always yielded me
supreme delight—so deeply was I
engrossed in my occupation.
before my work drew near to a
close, and now every day showed
me more plainly how
well I had succeeded.
anxiety, and I appeared rather
like one doomed by slavery to
toil in the mines,
or any other unwholesome trade
than an artist occupied by his
favourite employment.
fever, and I became nervous
to a most painful degree; the
fall of a leaf startled me, and
I shunned my
fellow creatures as if I had
been guilty of a crime.
perceived that I had become; the
energy of my purpose alone
sustained me:  My
labours would soon end, and I
believed that exercise and
amusement would then drive away
incipient disease; and I
promised myself both of these
when my creation should be
complete.
that I beheld the accomplishment
of my toils.
agony, I collected the
instruments of life around me,
that I might infuse a
It was already one in the
morning; the rain pattered
dismally against the
panes, and
my candle was nearly burnt out,
when, by the glimmer of the
half-extinguished
light, I saw the dull yellow eye
of the
creature open; it breathed hard,
and a convulsive motion agitated
its limbs.
at this catastrophe, or how
delineate the wretch whom with
such infinite pains and care I
had endeavoured to form?
and I had selected his features
as beautiful.
the work of muscles and arteries
beneath; his hair was of a
lustrous black, and flowing; his
teeth
of a pearly whiteness; but
these luxuriances only formed a
more horrid contrast with his
watery eyes,
that seemed almost of the same
colour as the dun-white
sockets in which they were set,
his shrivelled complexion and
straight black lips.
are not so changeable as the
feelings of human nature.
for the sole purpose of infusing
life into an inanimate body.
of rest and health.
far exceeded moderation; but now
that I had finished, the beauty
of the dream
vanished, and breathless horror
and disgust filled my heart.
being I had created, I rushed
out of the
room and
continued a long time traversing
my bed-chamber, unable to
compose my mind to sleep.
the tumult I had before endured,
and I threw myself on the bed in
my clothes, endeavouring to seek
a few moments of forgetfulness.
but I was disturbed by the
wildest dreams.
of health, walking in the
streets of Ingolstadt.
her, but as I imprinted
the first kiss on her lips, they
became
livid with the hue of death; her
features appeared to change, and
I thought that I held the corpse
of
my dead mother in my arms; a
shroud
enveloped her form, and I saw
the grave-worms crawling in the
folds of the flannel.
cold dew covered my
forehead, my teeth chattered,
and every
limb became convulsed; when, by
the dim and yellow light of the
moon, as it forced its way
through
the window
shutters, I beheld the
wretch—the miserable monster
whom I had created.
bed; and his eyes, if eyes they
may be called, were fixed on me.
some inarticulate sounds, while
a grin wrinkled his cheeks.
hear; one hand was stretched
out, seemingly to detain me, but
I escaped and rushed downstairs.
belonging to the house which I
inhabited, where I remained
during the rest of the night,
walking up and down
in the greatest agitation,
listening attentively, catching
and fearing each
sound as if it were to announce
the approach of the demoniacal
corpse to which I had so
miserably given life.
No mortal could support the
horror of that countenance.
was ugly then, but when those
muscles
and joints were rendered capable
of
motion, it became a thing such
as even Dante could not have
conceived.
hardly that I felt the
palpitation of every artery; at
others, I nearly sank
to the
ground through languor and
Mingled with this horror, I felt
the bitterness of
disappointment; dreams
that had been my food and
pleasant rest
for so long a space were now
become a hell to me; and the
change was so rapid, the
overthrow so complete!
dawned and discovered to
my sleepless and aching eyes the
church of Ingolstadt, its white
steeple and clock, which
indicated the sixth hour.
the court, which had that night
been my asylum, and I issued
into the streets, pacing them
with quick steps, as if I sought
to avoid the wretch whom I
feared every turning of the
street would present to my view.
which I inhabited, but
felt impelled to hurry on,
although
drenched by the rain which
poured from a black and
comfortless sky.
some time, endeavouring by
bodily
exercise to ease the load that
weighed upon my mind.
clear conception of where I was
or what I was doing.
sickness of fear, and I hurried
on with
irregular steps, not daring to
look Like one who, on a lonely
road, Doth walk in fear and
dread, And, having once turned
round, walks on, And turns no
more his head; Because he knows
a
frightful fiend Doth close
behind him tread.
length opposite to the inn at
which the
various diligences and carriages
usually stopped.
remained some minutes with my
eyes fixed on a coach that was
coming towards me
from the other end of the
street.
was the Swiss diligence; it
stopped just where I was
standing, and on the door being
opened, I perceived Henry
Clerval, who, on seeing me,
instantly sprung out.
“how glad I am to see you!
at the very moment of my
alighting!Nothing could equal my
delight on seeing Clerval; his
presence brought back to my
thoughts my father, Elizabeth,
and all those scenes of home so
dear to my recollection.
forgot my horror and misfortune;
I felt
suddenly, and for the first time
during many months, calm and
serene joy.
in the most cordial manner, and
we walked towards my college.
about our mutual friends and his
own good fortune in being
permitted to come to Ingolstadt.
great was the
difficulty to persuade my father
that all necessary knowledge was
not comprised in the noble art
of book-keeping; and, indeed, I
believe I left him incredulous
to the last, for his constant
answer to my unwearied
entreaties was the same as that
of the Dutch schoolmaster in The
Vicar of Wakefield:  ‘I have ten
thousand florins a year without
Greek, I eat heartily without
Greek.
overcame his dislike of
learning, and he has permitted
me to undertake a voyage of
discovery to the land of
knowledge.
“It gives me the greatest
delight to see you; but tell me
how you left my father,
brothers, and Elizabeth.
”
little uneasy that they hear
from you so seldom.
a little upon their account
myself.
he, stopping short and gazing
full in my
face, “I did
not before remark how very ill
you appear; so thin and pale;
you look as if you had been
watching for several nights.
“You have guessed right; I have
lately been so deeply engaged in
one occupation that I have not
allowed
myself sufficient rest, as you
see; but I hope, I sincerely
hope, that all these
employments are now at an end
and that I am at length free.”
endure to think of, and far less
to allude to, the occurrences of
the preceding
I walked with a quick pace, and
we soon arrived at my college.
me shiver, that the creature
whom I had left in my apartment
might still be there, alive and
walking about.
feared still more that Henry
should see him.
few minutes at the
bottom of the stairs, I darted
up towards my own room.
door before I recollected
myself.
children are accustomed to do
when they
expect a spectre to
stand in waiting for them on the
other side; but nothing
appeared.
was empty, and my bedroom was
also freed from its hideous
guest.
good fortune could have befallen
me, but when I became assured
that my enemy had
indeed
fled, I clapped my hands for joy
and ran down to Clerval.
the servant presently brought
breakfast; but I was unable to
contain myself.
I felt my flesh tingle with
excess of sensitiveness, and
my pulse beat rapidly.
instant in the same
place; I jumped over the chairs,
clapped my hands, and laughed
aloud.
spirits to joy on his arrival,
but when he observed me more
attentively, he saw a wildness
in my eyes for which he could
not account, and my loud,
unrestrained, heartless laughter
frightened and astonished him.
God's sake, is the matter?
“Do not ask me,” cried I,
putting my hands before my eyes,
for I thought I saw the dreaded
spectre glide into the room; “he
can tell.
” I imagined that the monster
seized me; I struggled furiously
and fell down in a fit.
such joy, so strangely turned to
bitterness.
grief, for I was lifeless and
did not
recover my senses for a long,
long time.
fever which confined me for
several months.
father's advanced age and
unfitness for so long a journey,
and how wretched my sickness
would make Elizabeth, he spared
them this grief by concealing
the extent of my disorder.
kind and attentive nurse than
himself; and, firm in the hope
he felt of my recovery, he did
not
doubt that, instead of doing
harm, he performed the kindest
action that he could towards
them.
and surely nothing but the
unbounded and unremitting
attentions of my friend could
have restored me to life.
bestowed existence was for ever
before
my eyes, and I raved incessantly
concerning him.
at first believed them to be the
wanderings of my disturbed
imagination,
but the pertinacity with which I
continually recurred to the same
subject
persuaded him that my disorder
indeed owed its origin to some
uncommon and terrible event.
frequent relapses that alarmed
and grieved my friend, I
recovered.
capable of observing outward
objects
with any kind of pleasure, I
perceived that the fallen leaves
had disappeared and that the
young buds were shooting forth
from the
trees that shaded my window.
season contributed greatly to my
convalescence.
affection revive in my bosom; my
gloom
disappeared, and in a short time
I became as cheerful as before I
was attacked by the fatal
passion.
“how kind, how very good you are
to me.
spent in study, as you promised
yourself, has been consumed in
my sick room.
the disappointment of which I
have been the occasion, but you
will forgive me.
“You will repay me entirely if
you do not discompose yourself,
but get well as fast as you can;
and since you
appear in such
good spirits, I may speak to you
on one subject, may I not?
observed my change
of colour, “I will not mention
it if it agitates you; but your
father
and cousin would be very
happy if they received a letter
from you in your own
handwriting.
and are uneasy at your long
silence.
first thought would not fly
towards
those dear, dear friends whom I
love and who are so deserving of
my love?
“If this is your present temper,
my friend, you will perhaps be
glad to see a letter that has
been lying here some
days for you; it is from your
cousin, I believe.
”
very ill, and even the constant
letters
of dear kind Henry are not
sufficient to reassure me on
your account.
hold a pen; yet one word from
you, dear Victor, is necessary
to calm our apprehensions.
each post would bring this
line, and my persuasions have
restrained
my uncle from undertaking a
journey to Ingolstadt.
inconveniences and perhaps
dangers of so long a
journey, yet how often have I
regretted
not being able to perform it
myself!
Yet that is over now:  Clerval
writes that indeed you are
getting better.
this intelligence soon in your
own handwriting.
and friends who love you dearly.
he asks but to see you, but to
be assured that you are well;
and not a care will ever cloud
his benevolent countenance.
improvement of our Ernest!
to enter into foreign service,
but we cannot part with him, at
least until his elder brother
returns to us.
of a military career in a
distant country, but Ernest
never had your powers of
application.
fetter; his time is spent in the
open air, climbing the hills or
rowing on the lake.
unless we yield the point
and permit him to enter on the
profession which he has
selected.
This girl had always been the
favourite of her father, but
through a strange perversity,
her mother could not endure her,
and after the death of M.My aunt
observed this, and when Justine
was twelve years of age,
prevailed on her mother to allow
her to live at our house.country
have produced simpler and
happier manners than those which
prevail Hence there is less
distinction between the several
classes of its inhabitants; and
the lower orders, being neither
so
poor nor so despised, their
manners are more refined and
moral.
same thing as a servant in
France and England.
family, learned the duties of a
servant, a condition which, in
our
fortunate country, does not
include the idea of ignorance
and a
sacrifice of the dignity of a
human being.
favourite of yours; and I
recollect you once remarked that
if you were in an ill humour,
one glance from Justine could
dissipate it, for the
same
reason that Ariosto gives
concerning the beauty of
Angelica—she My aunt conceived a
great attachment for her, by
which she was induced to give
her an education superior to
that which she had at first
intended.
was the most grateful little
creature in
the world:  I do not mean that
she made
any professions I never heard
one pass her lips, but you could
see by her eyes that she almost
adored her protectress.
many respects inconsiderate, yet
she
paid the greatest attention to
every gesture of my aunt.
excellence and endeavoured to
imitate her phraseology and
manners, so that even now she
often reminds me of her.
was too much occupied in their
own grief to notice poor
Justine, who had attended her
during her illness with the most
anxious affection.
“One by one, her brothers and
sister died; and her mother,
with the exception
of her neglected daughter, was
left childless.
troubled; she began to think
that the deaths of her
favourites was a judgement
from heaven to chastise her
partiality.
her confessor confirmed the idea
which she had conceived.
departure for Ingolstadt,
Justine was
called home by her repentant
mother.
She wept when she quitted our
house; she was much altered
since the death of my aunt;
grief had given softness and a
winning mildness to her manners,
which had before been
remarkable for vivacity.
house of a nature to restore her
gaiety.
her unkindness, but much oftener
accused Perpetual fretting at
length threw Madame Moritz into
a decline, which at first
increased her irritability, but
she is now at peace for ever.
weather, at the beginning of
this last winter.assure you I
love her tenderly.
extremely pretty; as I mentioned
before,
her mien and her expression
continually remind me of my dear
aunt.
you, my dear cousin, of little
darling William.
tall of his age, with sweet
laughing blue eyes, dark
eyelashes, and curling hair.
appear on each cheek, which are
rosy with health.
littlewives, but Louisa Biron is
his favourite, a pretty little
girl of five years of age.
you wish to be indulged in a
little
gossip concerning the The pretty
Miss Mansfield has already
received the congratulatory
visits on her approaching
marriage with a young
Englishman, John Melbourne, Esq.
Duvillard, the rich banker, last
autumn.Manoir, has suffered
several misfortunes
But he has already recovered his
spirits, and is reported to be
on the point of marrying a
lively pretty Frenchwoman,
Madame Tavernier.Manoir; but she
is very much admired, “I have
written myself into better
spirits, dear cousin; but my
anxiety Write, dearest
Victor,—one line—one word will
be a blessing to us.kindness,
his affection, and his many
letters; we are sincerely
grateful.I entreat you, write!
” I
exclaimed, when I had read her
letter:
“I will write instantly and
relieve them from the anxiety
they must feel.” I wrote, and
this exertion greatly fatigued
me; but my convalescence had
commenced, and proceeded
regularly.
to leave my chamber.
was to introduce Clerval to the
several professors of the
university.
rough usage, ill befitting the
wounds that my mind had
sustained.
my labours, and the beginning of
my
misfortunes, I had conceived a
violent
antipathy even to the name of
natural philosophy.
health, the sight of a chemical
instrument would renew all the
agony of my nervous symptoms.
he perceived that I had acquired
a
dislike for the room which had
previously been my laboratory.
no avail when I visited the
professors. Waldman inflicted
torture when he
praised, with kindness and
warmth, the astonishing progress
I had made in the sciences.
subject; but not guessing the
real
cause, he attributed my feelings
to modesty, and changed the
subject from my improvement, to
the science itself, with a
desire, as I evidently saw, of
drawing
me out.
one by one, in my view those
instruments
which were to be afterwards used
in putting me to a slow and
cruel death.
dared not exhibit the pain I
felt.
were always quick in discerning
the sensations of others,
declined the subject, alleging,
in excuse, his total
ignorance; and the conversation
took a more general turn.
but he never attempted to draw
my secret from me; and although
I loved him with a mixture of
affection and reverence that
knew no bounds, yet I could
never persuade myself to confide
in him that event which was so
often present to my
recollection, but which I feared
the detail to another would only
impress more deeply.
Krempe was not equally docile;
and in
my condition at that time, of
almost insupportable
sensitiveness, his harsh
blunt encomiums gave me even
more pain than the benevolent
approbation of M.
” cried he; “why, M. Clerval, I
assure you he has outstript us
all.
believed in Cornelius Agrippa as
firmly as in the gospel, has now
set himself at
the head of the university; and
if he is not soon pulled down,
we shall all be out of
countenance.
face expressive of suffering,
“M. Frankenstein is modest; an
excellent quality in a young
man.
themselves, you know, M.
Clerval:  I was myself when
young; but that wears out in a
very short time.
Krempe had now commenced an
eulogy on himself, which happily
turned the conversation from a
subject that was so annoying to
me.
tastes for natural science; and
his literary pursuits differed
wholly from those which had
occupied me.
design of making himself
complete master of the oriental
languages, and thus he
should
open a field for the plan of
life he had marked out for
himself.
career, he turned his eyes
toward the East, as affording
scope for his spirit of
enterprise.
languages engaged his attention,
and I was easily induced to
enter on the same studies.
and now that I wished to fly
from reflection, and hated my
former studies, I felt great
relief in being the fellow-pupil
with my friend, and found not
only instruction but consolation
in the works of the
orientalists.
from Greece
Summer passed away in these
occupations, and my return to
Geneva was fixed for the latter
end of autumn; but being
delayed by several accidents,
winter and snow arrived, the
roads were deemed impassable,
and my journey was retarded
until the ensuing spring.
longed to see my native town and
my beloved friends.long, from an
unwillingness to leave Clerval
in a strange place, before he
had become acquainted with any
of its inhabitants.
cheerfully; and although the
spring was uncommonly late, when
it came its beauty compensated
for its dilatoriness.
commenced, and I expected the
letter daily which was to fix
the date of my
departure, when Henry proposed a
pedestrian tour in the environs
of Ingolstadt, that I might bid
a personal farewell to the
country I had
so long inhabited.
proposition:  I was fond of
exercise, and Clerval had always
been my favourite companion in
the ramble of this nature that I
had taken among the scenes of my
native country.
perambulations:  My health and
spirits had long been restored,
and they gained additional
strength from the salubrious air
I breathed, the natural
incidents of
our progress, and the
conversation of my friend.
intercourse of my
fellow-creatures, and rendered
me unsocial; but Clerval called
forth the better feelings of my
heart; he again taught me to
love the aspect of nature, and
the cheerful faces of children.
How sincerely you did love me,
and endeavour to elevate my mind
until it was on a level with
your own.narrowed me, until your
gentleness and affection warmed
and opened my senses; I became
the same happy creature who, a
few years ago, loved and beloved
by all, had no sorrow or care.
power of bestowing on me the
most delightful sensations.
filled me with ecstasy.
the flowers of spring bloomed in
the hedges, while those of
summer were already in bud.
during the preceding year had
pressed upon me, notwithstanding
my endeavours
to throw them off, with an
invincible burden.
sincerely sympathised in my
feelings:  He exerted himself to
amuse me, while he expressed the
sensations that filled his soul.
occasion were truly astonishing:
His conversation was full of
imagination;
and very often, in imitation of
the Persian and Arabic writers,
he invented tales of wonderful
fancy and passion.
poems, or drew me out into
arguments, which he supported
with great ingenuity.
afternoon:  The peasants were
dancing, and every one we met
appeared gay and happy.
along with feelings of unbridled
joy and hilarity.
—
“My dear Victor, “You have
probably
waited
impatiently for a letter to fix
the date of your return to us;
and I was at first tempted to
write only a few lines,
merely mentioning the day on
which I
What would be your surprise, my
son, when you expected a happy
and glad welcome, to behold, on
the contrary, tears and
wretchedness?
callous to our joys and griefs;
and how shall I inflict pain on
my long absent son?
news, but I know it is
impossible; even now your eye
skims over the page to seek the
words which are to convey to you
the horrible tidings.
delighted and warmed my heart,
who was so gentle, yet so gay!
will simply relate the
circumstances of the
transaction.
two brothers, went to walk in
Plainpalais.
prolonged our walk farther than
usual.
of returning; and then we
discovered
that William and Ernest, who had
gone on before, were not to be
found.
until they should return.
we had seen his brother; he
said, that
he had been playing with him,
that William had run away to
hide himself, and that he vainly
sought for him, and
afterwards waited for a long
time, but that he did not
return.
continued to search for him
until night fell, when Elizabeth
conjectured that he might have
returned to the house.
could not rest, when I thought
that my sweet boy had lost
himself, and was
exposed to all the damps and
dews of
night; Elizabeth also suffered
extreme anguish.
my lovely boy, whom the night
before I
had seen blooming and active in
health, stretched on the grass
livid and motionless; the print
of the murder's finger was on
his neck.
that was visible in my
countenance betrayed the secret
to Elizabeth.
she persisted, and entering the
room where it lay, hastily
examined the neck
of the victim, and clasping her
hands exclaimed, ‘O God!
William had teased her to let
him wear a very valuable
miniature that she possessed of
your mother.the temptation which
urged the murderer to the deed.
although our exertions to
discover him are unremitted; but
they will not restore my beloved
William!
herself unjustly as the cause of
his death; her words pierce my
heart.
be an additional motive for you,
my son, to return and be our
comforter?
to witness the cruel, miserable
death of her youngest darling!
vengeance against the assassin,
but with
feelings of peace and
gentleness, that will heal,
instead of festering, the wounds
of our minds.
but with kindness and affection
for those who love you, and not
with hatred for your enemies.
father, “Alphonse Frankenstein.
Clerval, who had watched my
countenance as I read this
letter, was surprised to observe
the despair that succeeded the
joy I at first expressed on
receiving new from my friends.
covered my face with my hands.
Henry, when he perceived me weep
with bitterness, “are you always
to be unhappy?
I motioned him to take up the
letter, while I walked up and
down the room in the extremest
agitation.
Clerval, as he read the account
of my misfortune.
friend,” said he; “your disaster
is irreparable.
come with me, Henry, to order
the horses.
During our walk, Clerval
endeavoured to say a few words
of consolation; he could only
express his heartfelt sympathy.
” said he, “dear lovely child,
he now sleeps with his angel
mother!
in his young beauty, but must
weep over his untimely loss!
friends mourn and weep, but he
is at rest.
we must reserve that for his
miserable survivors.
Clerval spoke thus as we hurried
through the streets; the words
impressed themselves on my mind
and I remembered them afterwards
in solitude.I hurried into a
cabriolet, and bade farewell to
my friend.longed to console and
sympathise with my loved and
sorrowing friends; but when I
drew near my native town, I
slackened my progress.
feelings that crowded into my
mind.
youth, but which I had not seen
for nearly six years.
taken place; but a thousand
little circumstances might have
by degrees worked other
alterations, which, although
they were done more tranquilly,
might not be the less decisive.
dreading a thousand nameless
evils that
made me tremble, although I was
unable to define them.
were placid; all around was
calm; and
the snowy mountains, “the
palaces of nature,” were not
changed.restored me, and I
continued my journey towards
Geneva.
which became narrower as I
approached my native town.
sides of Jura, and the bright
summit of Mont Blanc.
I fear, my friend, that I shall
render myself tedious by
dwelling on these
preliminary circumstances; but
they were days of comparative
happiness, and I think of them
with pleasure.
took in again beholding thy
streams, thy
mountains, and, more than all,
thy lovely lake!
fear again overcame me.
could hardly see the dark
mountains, I felt still more
gloomily.
scene of evil, and I foresaw
obscurely that I was destined to
become
one single circumstance, that in
all the misery I imagined and
dreaded, I did not
conceive the hundredth part of
the anguish I was destined to
endure.
in the environs of Geneva; the
gates of
the town were already shut; and
I was obliged to pass the night
at Secheron, a village at the
distance of half a league from
the city.
unable to rest, I resolved to
visit the spot where my poor
William had been murdered.
was obliged to cross the lake in
a boat to arrive at Plainpalais.
lightning playing on the summit
of Mont Blanc in the most
beautiful figures.
and, on landing, I ascended a
low hill, that I might observe
its progress.and I soon felt the
rain coming slowly in large
drops, but its violence quickly
increased.
although the darkness and storm
increased every minute, and the
thunder burst with a terrific
crash over my head.
and the Alps of Savoy; vivid
flashes of lightning dazzled my
eyes, illuminating the lake,
making it appear like a vast
sheet of fire; then for an
instant every thing seemed of a
pitchy darkness, until
The storm, as is often the case
in Switzerland, appeared at once
in various parts of the heavens.
north of the town, over the part
of the lake which lies between
the promontory
of Belrive and the village of
Copêt.
faint flashes; and another
darkened and sometimes disclosed
the Môle, a peaked mountain to
the east of the lake.
beautiful yet terrific, I
wandered on with a hasty step.
spirits; I clasped my hands, and
exclaimed aloud, “William, dear
angel!
dirge!” As I said these words, I
perceived in the gloom a figure
which stole from behind a clump
of trees near me; I stood
fixed, gazing intently:  I could
not be mistaken.
object, and discovered its shape
plainly
to me; its gigantic stature, and
the deformity of its aspect more
hideous than belongs to
humanity, instantly
informed me that it was the
wretch, the filthy daemon, to
whom I had given life.
imagination, than I became
convinced of its truth; my teeth
chattered, and I was
forced to lean against a tree
for support.
The mere presence of the idea
was an irresistible proof of the
fact.
but it would have been in vain,
for another flash discovered him
to me
hanging among the rocks of the
nearly perpendicular ascent of
Mont Salêve, a hill that bounds
Plainpalais on the south.
continued, and the scene was
enveloped in an impenetrable
darkness.
I had until now sought to
forget:  The whole train of my
progress toward the creation;
the appearance of the works of
my own hands at my bedside; its
departure.
the night on which he first
received life; and was this his
first crime?
depraved wretch, whose delight
was in carnage and misery; had
he not murdered my brother?
suffered during the remainder of
the night, which I spent, cold
and wet, in the open air.
the weather; my imagination was
busy in scenes of evil and
despair.
had cast among mankind, and
endowed with the will and power
to effect purposes of
horror, such as the deed which
he had
now done, nearly in the light of
my own vampire, my own spirit
let loose from the grave, and
forced to destroy all that was
dear to me.
knew of the murderer, and cause
instant
But I paused when I reflected on
the story that I had to tell.
endued with life, had met me at
midnight
among the precipices of an
inaccessible mountain.
with which I had been seized
just at the time that I dated my
creation, and which
would give an air of delirium to
a tale I well knew that if any
other had communicated such a
relation to me, I should have
looked upon it as the ravings of
insanity.animal would elude all
pursuit, even if I were so far
credited as to persuade my
relatives to commence it.
scaling the overhanging sides of
Mont Salêve?
entered my father's house.
family, and went into the
library to attend their usual
hour of rising.
dream but for one indelible
trace, and I stood in the same
place where I had last
embraced my father before my
departure for Ingolstadt.
which stood over the
mantel-piece.
at my father's desire, and
represented Caroline Beaufort in
an agony of
despair, kneeling by the coffin
of her dead father.
pale; but there was an air of
dignity and beauty, that hardly
permitted the sentiment of pity.
William; and my tears flowed
when I looked upon it.
entered:  He had heard me
arrive, and
hastened to welcome
me:  “Welcome, my dearest
Victor,” said he.
ago, and then you would have
found us all joyous and
delighted.
which nothing can alleviate; yet
your
presence will, I hope, revive
our father,
Grief on the death of mamma.
Poor Elizabeth is also quite
inconsolable.
Do not, said I, welcome me thus.
Try to be more calm that I may
not be absolutely miserable the
moment I enter
my father's house after so long
an absence.
But tell me, how does my father
support his misfortune? And how
is my poor Elizabeth?
She requires consolation.
She accused herself of having
caused the death. But since the
murderer had been discovered --
the murderer discovered? Good
God! How can that be?
Who can attempt to pursue him?
It is impossible.
One might as well try to
overtake the winds, or confine a
mountain-stream with a straw.“I
do not know what you mean,”
replied my brother, in accents
of wonder, “but to us the
discovery we have made completes
our misery.even now Elizabeth
will not be convinced,
notwithstanding all the
evidence.
Justine Moritz, who was so
amiable, and fond of all the
family, could suddenly become so
capable of so frightful, so
appalling a crime?”
that; no one believes it,
surely, Ernest?
”
circumstances came out, that
have almost forced conviction
upon
us; and her own
behaviour has been so confused,
as to add to the evidence of
facts a weight that, I fear,
leaves no hope for doubt.
”which the murder of poor
William had been discovered,
Justine had been taken ill, and
confined to her bed for several
days.
servants, happening to examine
the apparel she had worn on the
night of the
murder, had
discovered in her pocket the
picture of my mother, which had
been
judged to be the temptation of
the murderer.
of the others, who, without
saying a word to any of
the family, went to a
magistrate; and, upon their
deposition, Justine was
apprehended.poor girl confirmed
the suspicion in a great measure
by her extreme confusion of
manner.shake my faith; and I
replied earnestly,
“You are all mistaken; I know
the murderer.
At that instant my father
entered.
his countenance, but he
endeavoured to welcome me
cheerfully; and, after we had
exchanged our mournful greeting,
would have introduced some other
topic than that of our disaster,
had not Ernest
exclaimed, “Good God, papa!
murderer of poor William.“We do
also, unfortunately,” replied my
father, “for indeed I had rather
have been for ever ignorant than
have discovered so much
depravity and ungratitude in one
I valued so highly.
“My dear father, you are
mistaken; Justine is innocent.
“If she is, God forbid that she
should suffer as guilty.
sincerely hope, that she will be
acquitted.
that Justine, and indeed every
human being, was guiltless of
this murder.
circumstantial evidence could be
brought forward strong enough to
convict her.
publicly; its astounding horror
would be looked upon as madness
by the vulgar.
creator, who would believe,
unless his
senses convinced him, in the
existence of the living monument
of presumption and rash
ignorance which I had let loose
upon the world?
beheld her; it had endowed her
with loveliness surpassing the
beauty of her childish years.
vivacity, but it was allied to
an expression more full of
sensibility and intellect.
justify my poor guiltless
Justine.
have not only lost that lovely
darling boy, but this poor girl,
whom I sincerely love, is to be
torn away by even a worse fate.
not; and then I shall be happy
again, even after the sad death
of my little William.
“She is innocent, my Elizabeth,”
said I, “and that shall be
proved; fear nothing,
but let your spirits be cheered
by the assurance of her
acquittal.
and that made me wretched, for I
knew that it was impossible:
And to see
every one else prejudiced in so
deadly a manner rendered me
hopeless and despairing.” She
wept.
rely on the justice of our laws,
and the
activity with which I shall
prevent the slightest shadow of
partiality.
We passed a few sad hours until
eleven o'clock, when the trial
was to commence.being obliged to
attend as witnesses, I
accompanied them to the court.
mockery of justice I suffered
living torture.
of my curiosity and lawless
devices would cause the death of
two of my
fellow beings:  One a smiling
babe full of innocence and joy,
the other far more dreadfully
murdered, with every aggravation
of infamy that could make the
murder memorable in horror.
possessed qualities which
promised to render her life
happy; now all was to be
obliterated in an ignominious
grave, and I the cause!
confessed myself guilty of
the crime ascribed to Justine,
but I was absent when it was
committed, and such a
declaration would have been
considered as the ravings of a
madman and would not
have exculpated her who suffered
through me.
countenance, always engaging,
was rendered, by the solemnity
of her
feelings, exquisitely beautiful.
and did not tremble, although
gazed on and execrated by
thousands, for all the kindness
which
her beauty might otherwise have
excited was obliterated
in the minds of the
spectators by the imagination of
the enormity she was supposed to
have committed.
was evidently constrained; and
as her confusion had before been
adduced as a proof of her guilt,
she worked up her mind to an
appearance of courage.
her eyes round it and quickly
discovered where we were seated.
saw us, but she quickly
recovered herself, and a look of
sorrowful affection seemed to
attest her utter guiltlessness.
against her had stated
the charge, several witnesses
were called.
against her, which might have
staggered anyone who had not
such proof of her
innocence as I had.
on which the murder
had been committed and towards
morning had been perceived by a
market-woman not
far from the spot where the body
of the murdered child had been
afterwards found.
there, but she looked very
strangely and only returned a
confused and unintelligible
answer.
eight o'clock, and when one
inquired where she had passed
the night, she replied that she
had been looking for the child
and demanded earnestly if
anything had been heard
concerning him.
violent hysterics and kept her
bed for several days.
servant had found in
her pocket; and when Elizabeth,
in a faltering voice, proved
that it was the same which, an
hour before the child had been
missed, she had placed round
his neck, a murmur of horror and
indignation filled the court.
defence.
countenance had altered.
tears, but when she was desired
to plead, she collected her
powers and
spoke in an audible although
variable voice.
protestations should acquit me;
I rest my innocence on a plain
and
simple explanation of the
facts which have been adduced
against me, and I hope the
character I
have always borne will incline
my judges to a favourable
interpretation where any
circumstance appears doubtful or
suspicious.
She then related that, by the
permission of Elizabeth, she had
passed the evening of the night
on which the murder had been
committed at the house of an
aunt at Chêne, a village
situated at
about a league from On her
return, at about nine o'clock,
she met a man who asked
her if she had seen anything of
the child who was lost.
and passed several hours in
looking for
him, when the gates
of Geneva were shut, and she was
forced to remain several hours
of the night in a barn belonging
to a cottage, being unwilling to
call up the inhabitants, to whom
she was well known.
watching; towards morning she
believed that she slept for a
few minutes; some steps
disturbed her, and she awoke.
asylum, that she might again
endeavour to find my brother.
body lay, it was without her
knowledge.
when questioned by the
market-woman was not surprising,
since she had passed a sleepless
night and the fate of poor
William was yet uncertain.
“how heavily and fatally this
one circumstance weighs against
me, but I have no power of
explaining it; and when
I have expressed my utter
ignorance, I am only left to
conjecture concerning
the probabilities by which it
might have been placed in my
pocket.
on earth, and none surely would
have been so wicked as to
destroy me wantonly.
for so doing; or, if I had, why
should he have stolen the
jewel, to part with it again so
soon?
witnesses examined concerning my
character, and if their
testimony shall not overweigh my
supposed guilt, I must
Several witnesses were called
who had known her for many
years, and they spoke well of
her; but fear and
hatred of the
crime of which they supposed her
guilty rendered them timorous
and unwilling to come forward.
her excellent dispositions and
irreproachable conduct, about to
fail
the accused, when, although
violently
agitated, she desired permission
to address the court.
unhappy child who was murdered,
or rather his sister, for I was
educated by
and have lived with his parents
ever since and even long before
his birth.
me to come forward on this
occasion, but
when I see a fellow creature
about to
perish through the cowardice of
her pretended friends, I wish to
be allowed to speak, that I may
say what I know of her
character.
her, at one time for five
and at another for nearly two
years.
me the most amiable and
benevolent of human creatures.
aunt, in her last illness, with
the greatest affection and care
and afterwards attended her own
mother
during a tedious illness, in a
manner
that excited the admiration of
all who knew her, after which
she again lived in my uncle's
house, where she was beloved by
all the family.
who is now dead and acted
towards him like a most
affectionate mother.
say that, notwithstanding all
the evidence produced against
her, I believe
and rely on her perfect
innocence.
action; as to the bauble on
which the chief proof rests, if
she had earnestly desired it, I
should have willingly given it
to her, so much do I
esteem and value her.
A murmur of approbation followed
Elizabeth's simple and powerful
appeal,
but it was excited by her
generous interference, and not
in
favour of poor Justine,
on whom the public indignation
was turned with renewed
violence, charging her with the
blackest ingratitude.
spoke, but she did not answer.
brother also in his hellish
sport have betrayed the innocent
to death and ignominy?
situation, and when I perceived
that the popular voice and the
countenances of
the judges had already condemned
my unhappy victim, I rushed out
of the court in agony.
equal mine; she was sustained by
innocence, but the fangs of
remorse tore my bosom and would
not forgo their hold.
lips and throat were parched.
I was known, and the officer
guessed the
cause of my visit.
all black, and Justine was
condemned.
horror, and I have endeavoured
to bestow upon them adequate
expressions, but
words cannot convey an idea of
the
heart-sickening despair that I
then endured.
added that Justine had already
confessed her guilt.
hardly required in so glaring a
case, but I am glad of it, and,
indeed, none
of our judges like to condemn a
criminal upon circumstantial
evidence, be it ever so
decisive.
This was strange and unexpected
intelligence; what could it
mean?
world would believe me to be if
I disclosed the object of my
suspicions?
Elizabeth eagerly demanded the
result.
as you may have expected; all
judges had rather that ten
innocent should suffer than that
one guilty should escape.
This was a dire blow to poor
Elizabeth, who had relied with
firmness upon Justine's
innocence.
in human goodness?
my sister, how could she put on
those smiles of innocence only
to betray?
severity or guile, and yet she
has committed a murder.Soon
after we heard that the poor
victim had expressed a desire to
see my cousin.that he left it to
her own judgment and feelings to
decide.” The idea of this visit
was torture to We entered the
gloomy prison chamber and beheld
Justine sitting on some straw at
the farther end; her hands were
manacled, and her head rested on
her knees.
when we were left alone with
her, she threw herself at the
feet of Elizabeth, weeping
bitterly.
although I was then very
wretched, I was not so miserable
as I am now.
“And do you also believe that I
am so very, very wicked?
crush me, to condemn me as a
murderer?” Her voice was
suffocated with sobs.
“why do you kneel, if you are
innocent?
believed you guiltless,
notwithstanding every evidence,
until I heard that you had
yourself declared your guilt.
assured, dear Justine, that
nothing can shake my confidence
in you for a moment, but your
own confession.
I confessed, that I might obtain
absolution; but now that
falsehood lies heavier at my
heart than all my other sins.
confessor has besieged me; he
threatened and menaced, until I
almost began to think that I was
the monster that he said I was.
fire in my last moments if I
continued obdurate.
all looked on me as a wretch
doomed to ignominy and
perdition.
and now only am I truly
miserable.
She paused, weeping, and then
continued, “I thought with
horror, my
sweet lady, that you should
believe your Justine, whom your
blessed aunt had so highly
honoured, and whom you loved,
was a creature capable of a
crime which none but the devil
himself could have perpetrated.
where we shall all be happy; and
that consoles me, going as I am
to suffer ignominy and death.
moment distrusted you.
your innocence.
enemies by my tears and prayers.
Justine shook her head
mournfully.
you remember me and think of me
as of one unjustly condemned, I
am resigned to the fate awaiting
me.
submit in patience to the will
of heaven!
”
to the corner of the prison room
where I
could conceal the anguish that
possessed me. Despair? Who dare
talk of that?
The poor victim who on thehe
morrow was to die felt not as I
did. I gnashed my teeth and
ground them
together, uttering a groan that
came from my inmost soul.
Justine started.
She approached me and said,
"Dear sir, you are very kind of
visit me.
You do not believe they am
guilty?" I could not answer. "No
Justine.
He is more convinced of your
innocence than I was." I truly
thank him.
In these last moments, I feel
the sincerest gratitude towards
those who think of me with
kindness.
misfortune, and I feel as if I
could die in peace now that my
innocence is acknowledged by
you, dear lady, and your cousin.
Thus the poor sufferer tried to
comfort others and herself.
never-dying worm alive in my
bosom, which allowed of no hope
or consolation.
but hers also was the misery of
innocence, which, like a cloud
that passes over the fair moon,
for a while hides but cannot
tarnish its brightness.
the core of my heart; I bore a
hell within me which nothing
could extinguish.
and it was with great difficulty
that Elizabeth could tear
herself away.
die with you; I cannot live in
this world of misery.Justine
assumed an air of cheerfulness,
She embraced Elizabeth and said
in a voice of half-suppressed
emotion, “Farewell, sweet lady,
dearest Elizabeth, my beloved
and only friend; may heaven, in
its bounty, bless and preserve
you; may this be the last
failed to move the judges from
their settled conviction in the
criminality of the saintly
sufferer.and heard the harsh,
unfeeling reasoning
of these men, my purposed avowal
died away on my lips.
but not revoke the sentence
passed upon my wretched victim.
heart, I turned to contemplate
the deep and voiceless grief of
my Elizabeth.
mind than, after the feelings
have been worked up by a quick
succession of events, the dead
calmness of inaction and
certainty which follows and
deprives the soul both of hope
and fear.
but a weight of despair and
remorse
pressed on my heart which
nothing could remove.
like an evil spirit, for I had
committed
deeds of mischief beyond
description
horrible, and more, much more
was yet behind.
intentions and thirsted for the
moment when I should put them in
practice and make myself useful
to my fellow beings.
serenity of conscience which
allowed me
to look back upon the past with
self-satisfaction, and from
thence to gather promise of new
hopes, I was seized by remorse
and the sense of
guilt, which hurried me away to
a hell of intense tortures such
as no language can describe.
health, which had perhaps never
entirely
recovered from the first shock
it had sustained.
joy or complacency was torture
to me; solitude was my only
consolation—deep, dark,
deathlike solitude.
alteration perceptible in my
disposition and habits and
endeavoured by arguments
deduced from the feelings of his
serene conscience and guiltless
life to inspire me with
fortitude and awaken in me the
courage to dispel the dark cloud
which brooded over me.loved your
brother”—tears came into his
eyes as he spoke—“but is it not
a duty to the survivors that we
should refrain from augmenting
their unhappiness by an
appearance of immoderate grief?
excessive sorrow prevents
improvement or
enjoyment, or even the discharge
of
daily usefulness, without which
no man is fit for society.
This advice, although good, was
totally inapplicable to my case;
I should have been the first to
hide my grief and
console my friends if remorse
had not
mingled its bitterness, and
terror its alarm, with my other
sensations.
a look of despair and endeavour
to hide myself from his view.
our house at Belrive.
ten o'clock and the
impossibility of remaining on
the lake after that hour
had rendered our residence
within the walls of Geneva very
irksome to me.
retired for the night, I took
the boat
and passed many hours upon the
water.
was carried by the wind; and
sometimes, after rowing into the
middle of the lake, I left the
boat to pursue its own
course and gave way to my own
miserable reflections.
peace around me, and I the only
unquiet thing that wandered
restless in a scene
so beautiful and heavenly—if I
except some bat, or the frogs,
whose harsh and interrupted
croaking was heard only when
I approached the shore—often, I
say, I was tempted to plunge
into the silent lake, that the
waters might close over me and
my calamities for ever.
the heroic and suffering
Elizabeth, whom
I tenderly loved, and whose
existence was bound up in mine.
surviving brother; should I by
my base desertion leave them
exposed and unprotected to the
malice of the fiend whom I had
let loose among them?wished that
peace would revisit my mind only
that I might afford them
consolation and happiness.
evils, and I lived in daily fear
lest
the monster whom I had created
should perpetrate some new
wickedness.
not over and that he would still
commit some signal crime, which
by its enormity
should almost efface the
recollection of the past.
as anything I loved remained
behind.
teeth, my eyes became inflamed,
and I ardently wished to
extinguish that life
which I had so thoughtlessly
bestowed.
malice, my hatred and revenge
burst all bounds of moderation.
highest peak of the Andes, could
I, when
there, have precipitated him to
their base.
wreak the utmost extent of
abhorrence on his head and
avenge the deaths of William and
Justine.
the horror of the recent events.
no longer took delight in her
ordinary
occupations; all pleasure seemed
to her sacrilege toward the
dead; eternal woe and tears she
then thought
was the just tribute she should
pay to innocence so blasted and
destroyed.
who in earlier youth wandered
with me on the banks of the lake
and talked with ecstasy of our
future prospects.
sent to wean us from the earth
had
visited her, and its dimming
influence quenched her dearest
smiles.
she, “on the miserable death of
Justine Moritz, I no longer see
the world and its works as they
before appeared to me.vice and
injustice that I read in books
or heard from others as tales of
ancient days or imaginary evils;
at least they
were remote and more familiar to
reason than to the imagination;
but now misery has come home,
and men appear to me as monsters
thirsting for each other's
blood.
guilty; and if she could have
committed
the crime for which she
suffered, assuredly she would
have been the most depraved of
human creatures.
have murdered the son of her
benefactor and friend, a child
whom she had nursed
from its birth, and appeared to
love as if it had been her own!
human being, but certainly I
should have
thought such a creature unfit to
remain in the society of men.
are of the same opinion, and
that confirms me.
the truth, who can assure
themselves of certain happiness?
of a precipice, towards which
thousands
are crowding and endeavouring to
plunge me into the abyss.
and the murderer escapes; he
walks about
the world free, and perhaps
respected.
suffer on the scaffold for the
same crimes, I would not change
places with such a wretch.
I listened to this discourse
with the extremest agony.
was the true murderer.
countenance, and kindly taking
my hand, said, “My dearest
friend, you must calm yourself.
knows how deeply; but I am not
so wretched as you are.
sometimes of revenge, in your
countenance that makes me
tremble.
who centre all their hopes in
you.
each other, here in this land of
peace and beauty, your native
country, we may reap every
tranquil blessing—what can
disturb our peace?
And could not such words from Fe
her whom I fondly prized before
every other gift of fortune
suffice to chase away the fiend
that lurked in my heart?as if in
terror, lest at that very moment
the destroyer had been near to
rob me of her.nor the beauty of
earth, nor of heaven, could
redeem my soul from woe; the
very accents of love were
ineffectual.
beneficial influence could
penetrate.
limbs to some untrodden brake,
there to gaze upon the arrow
which had pierced it, and to
die, was but a type of me.
But Elizabeth and Ernest never
had.
This place had been described to
them as so wonderful and
sublime.
We departed from Geneva on this
tour
about the middle of the month of
August.
The weather was uncommonly fine,
and it might have been sorrow to
have been chased away by any
fleeting circumstance, this
excursion would certainly have
had the effect intended by my
father.
As it was, I was somewhat
interested.
We followed.
When the sun had set, we beheld
mountains overhanging us on
every side, and heard the sound
of the river raging among rocks
and the dashing of water falls
around.
The next day we pursued our
journey,
and as we ascended still higher,
the
valley appeared more magnificent
and
Ruined castles hanging on the
precipices of piny mountains,
the impetuous Arve, and cottages
every here and there peeping
forth from among the trees
formed a scene of singular
beauty.
sublime by the mighty Alps,
whose white
and shining pyramids and domes
towered above all, as belonging
to another earth, the
habitations of another race of
beings.
Pélissier, where the ravine,
which the river forms, opened
before me, and I began to ascend
the mountain that overhangs it.
of Chamounix.
sublime, but not so beautiful
and picturesque as that of
Servox, through which I had just
passed.immediate boundaries, but
I saw no more ruined castles and
fertile fields.
heard the rumbling thunder of
the falling avalanche and marked
the smoke of its passage.
Mont Blanc, raised itself from
the
Surround ing aiguilles, and its
tremendousdôme overlooked the
valley.
At other times, I brought the
animals
before my
companion.
At a distance, I
, weighted down by despair.
At 8:00 in the evening, I
arrived at Chamounix.
Ernest was delighted and in high
spirits.
The rain seemed to promise for
the next day. We returned to our
apartment, but not to sleep. At
least I did not.
I remained many hours at the
window, watching the lightning
that played above, and listening
to the rushing of
the Arve, which runs below my
I spent the following day
roaming through the valley.
Arveiron, which take their rise
in a glacier, that with slow
pace is advancing down from the
summit of the hills to barricade
the valley.
although they did not remove my
grief,
they subdued and
tranquilized it.
I returned in the evening
fatigued but less unhappy and
conversed with my
family with more cheerfulness
than had been my custom for some
time.
My father was pleased, and
Elizabeth
overjoyed.
The following morning, rain full
down
in
torrents. The feelings
overpowered me. I knew that they
would remain that day
at the end, and as I had ever
endeared myself to the rain,
moisture, and cold,
I resolved to go alone to the
summit of
It had then filled me with a
sublime ecstasy that gave wings
to the soul and allowed it to
soar from the obscure world to
light and joy.nature had indeed
always the effect of solemnising
my mind and causing me to forget
the passing cares of life.
I was well acquainted with the
path, and
the presence
of another would destroy the
solitary grandeur of the scene.
is cut into continual and short
windings, which enable you to
surmount
the perpendicularity of the
mountain.
of the winter avalanche may be
perceived, where trees lie
broken and strewed on the
ground, some entirely destroyed,
others bent, leaning upon the
jutting rocks of the mountain or
transversely upon other trees.
intersected by ravines of snow,
down
which stones
continually roll from above; one
of them is particularly
dangerous, as the slightest
sound, such as even speaking
in a loud voice, produces a
concussion of air sufficient to
draw destruction upon the head
of the speaker.
but they are sombre and add an
air of severity to the scene.
vast mists were rising from the
rivers which ran through it and
curling in thick wreaths around
the opposite mountains, whose
summits were hid in the
uniform clouds, while rain
poured from the dark sky and
added to the melancholy
impression I received from the
objects around me.
superior to those apparent in
the brute;
it only renders them more
necessary beings.
hunger, thirst, and desire, we
might be nearly free; but now we
are moved by every wind that
blows and a chance word or scene
that that word may convey to us.
pollutes the day.
weep,
Embrace fond woe, or cast our
cares away; It is the same:
For, be it joy or sorrow, The
path of its departure still is
free.morrow; Nought may endure
but mutability!the top of the
ascent.
cloud, and I descended upon the
glacier.
the waves of a troubled sea,
descending
low, and interspersed by rifts
that sink deep.
width, but I spent nearly two
hours in crossing it.
Montanvert was exactly opposite,
at the distance of a league; and
above it rose Mont Blanc, in
awful majesty.
gazing on this wonderful and
stupendous scene.
ice, wound among its dependent
mountains, whose aerial summits
hung over its recesses.
the sunlight over the clouds.
now swelled with something like
joy; I exclaimed, “Wandering
spirits, if indeed
ye wander, and do not rest in
your narrow beds, allow me this
faint
happiness, or take me, as your
companion, away from the joys of
life.
As I said this I suddenly beheld
the figure of a man, at some
distance, advancing towards me
with superhuman speed.
ice, among which I had walked
with caution; his stature, also,
as he approached, seemed to
exceed that of man.
eyes, and I felt a faintness
seize me, but I was quickly
restored by the cold gale of the
mountains.
that it was the wretch whom I
had created.
resolving to wait his approach
and then close with him in
mortal combat.
bitter anguish, combined with
disdain and malignity, while its
unearthly ugliness rendered it
almost too horrible for human
eyes.
hatred had at first deprived me
of utterance, and I recovered
only to overwhelm him with words
expressive of furious
detestation and contempt.
dare approach me?
vengeance of my arm wreaked on
your miserable head?
your miserable existence,
restore those
victims whom you have so
diabolically murdered!“I
expected this reception,” said
the daemon.
then, must I be hated, who am
miserable beyond all living
things!
me, thy creature, to whom thou
art bound by ties only
dissoluble by the
annihilation of one of us.
mine towards you and the rest of
mankind.
I will leave them and you at
peace; but if you refuse, I will
glut the maw of death, until it
be satiated with the blood of
your remaining friends.
come on, then, that I may
extinguish the spark which I so
negligently bestowed.
My rage was without bounds; I
sprang on him, impelled by all
the feelings which can arm one
being against the existence of
another.
you give vent to your hatred on
my devoted head.
accumulation of anguish, is dear
to me, and I will defend it.
powerful than thyself; my height
is superior to thine, my joints
more supple.
even mild and docile to my
natural lord and king if thou
wilt also perform thy part, the
which thou owest me.
every other and trample upon me
alone,
to whom thy justice, and even
thy clemency and affection, is
most due.
ought to be thy Adam, but I am
rather the fallen angel, whom
thou drivest from joy for no
misdeed.
alone am irrevocably excluded.
and me; we are enemies.
fight, in which one must fall.
favourable eye upon thy
creature, who implores thy
goodness and compassion?
benevolent; my soul glowed with
love and humanity; but am I not
alone, miserably alone?
can I gather from your fellow
creatures, who owe me nothing?
caves of ice, which I only do
not fear,
are a dwelling to me, and the
only one which man does not
grudge.
kinder to me than your fellow
beings.
existence, they would do as you
do, and arm themselves for my
destruction.
me, and deliver them from an
evil which
it only remains for you to make
so great, that not only you and
your family, but thousands of
others, shall
be swallowed up in the
whirlwinds of its rage.
that, abandon or commiserate me,
as you shall judge that I
deserve.
bloody as they are, to speak in
their own defence before they
are condemned.
would, with a satisfied
conscience, destroy your own
creature.
to me, and then, if you can, and
if you will, destroy the work of
your hands.
“Why do you call to my
remembrance,” I
rejoined, “circumstances of
which I shudder to reflect, that
I have been the miserable origin
and author?
which you first saw light!
whether I am just to you or not.
“Thus I relieve thee, my
creator,” he said, and placed
his hated hands before
my eyes, which I flung from me
with violence; “thus I take from
thee a sight which you abhor.
demand this from you.
and the temperature of this
place is not
fitting to your fine sensations;
come to the hut upon the
mountain.before it descends to
hide itself behind your snowy
precipices and illuminate
another world, you will have
heard my story and can decide.
ever the neighbourhood of man
and lead a harmless life, or
become the scourge of your
fellow creatures and the author
of your own speedy ruin.As he
said this he led the way across
the ice; I followed.him, but as
I proceeded, I weighed the
various arguments that he had
used and determined at least to
listen to his tale.compassion
confirmed my resolution.
murderer of my brother, and I
eagerly
sought a confirmation or denial
of this opinion.
the duties of a creator towards
his creature were, and that I
ought to render him happy before
I complained of his wickedness.
began to descend; we entered the
hut, the fiend with an air of
exultation, I
with a heavy heart and depressed
spirits.
myself by the fire which my
odious
companion had lighted, he thus
began his tale.
that I remember the original era
of my being; all the events of
that period appear confused and
indistinct.seized me, and I saw,
felt, heard, and
smelt at the
same time; and it was, indeed, a
long time before I learned to
distinguish between the
operations of my various senses.
light pressed upon my nerves, so
that I was obliged to shut my
eyes.
me, but hardly had I felt this
when, by opening my eyes, as I
now suppose, the light poured in
upon me again.I presently found
a great alteration in my
sensations.
surrounded me, impervious to my
touch or sight; but I now found
that I could wander on at
liberty, with no obstacles which
I could not either surmount or
avoid.
oppressive to me, and the heat
wearying me as I walked, I
sought a place where I could
receive shade.
and here I lay by the side of a
brook
resting from my fatigue, until I
felt tormented by hunger and
thirst.
state, and I ate some berries
which I found hanging on the
trees or lying on the ground.
and then lying down, was
overcome by sleep.
also, and half frightened, as it
were, instinctively, finding
myself so desolate.
a sensation of cold, I had
covered myself with some
clothes, but these were
insufficient to secure me from
the dews of night.
wretch; I knew, and could
distinguish,
nothing; but feeling pain invade
me on all sides, I sat down and
wept.
heavens and gave me a sensation
of pleasure.rise from among the
trees.path, and I again went out
in search of berries.trees I
found a huge cloak, with which I
covered myself, and sat down
upon the ground.
and darkness; innumerable sounds
rang in
my ears, and on all sides
various scents saluted me; the
only object that I could
distinguish was the bright moon,
and I
fixed my eyes on that with
pleasure.
passed, and the orb of night had
greatly lessened, when I began
to distinguish my sensations
from each other.
stream that supplied me with
drink and the trees that shaded
me with their foliage.
that a pleasant sound, which
often
saluted my ears, proceeded from
the throats of the little winged
animals who had often
intercepted the light from my
eyes.
accuracy, the forms that
surrounded me and to perceive
the boundaries of the radiant
roof of light which canopied me.
pleasant songs of the birds but
was unable.
sensations in my own mode, but
the uncouth and inarticulate
sounds which broke from me
frightened me into silence
again.
night, and again, with a
lessened form, showed itself,
while I still remained in the
forest.distinct, and my mind
received every day additional
ideas.
and to perceive objects in their
right
forms; I distinguished the
insect from the herb, and by
degrees, one herb from another.
none but harsh notes, whilst
those of the blackbird and
thrush were sweet and enticing.I
found a fire which had been left
by some wandering beggars, and
was overcome with delight at the
warmth I experienced from it.
live embers, but quickly drew it
out
How strange, I thought, that the
same cause should produce such
opposite effects!
and to my joy found it to be
composed of wood.
branches, but they were wet and
would not burn.
watching the operation of the
fire.
the heat dried and itself became
inflamed.
the various branches, I
discovered the cause and busied
myself in collecting a great
quantity of wood, that I might
dry it and have a plentiful
supply of fire.with it, I was in
the greatest fear lest my fire
should be extinguished.
and leaves and placed wet
branches upon it; and then,
spreading my cloak, I lay on the
ground and sank into sleep.
first care was to visit the
fire.
quickly fanned it into a flame.
fan of branches, which roused
the embers when they were nearly
extinguished.
pleasure, that the fire gave
light as well as heat and that
the discovery of
this element was useful to me in
my food, for I found some of the
offals that the travellers had
left had been roasted, and
tasted much more savoury
than the berries I gathered from
the trees.
the same manner, placing it on
the live embers.
by this operation, and the nuts
and roots much improved.
often spent the whole day
searching in vain for a few
acorns to assuage the pangs of
hunger.the place that I had
hitherto inhabited, to seek for
one where the few wants I
experienced would be more easily
satisfied.lamented the loss of
the fire which I had obtained
through accident and knew not
how to reproduce it.
consideration of this
difficulty, but I was obliged to
relinquish all attempt to supply
it, and wrapping myself up in my
cloak, I struck across the wood
towards the setting sun.
and at length discovered the
open country.
the night before, and the fields
were of
one uniform white; the
appearance was disconsolate, and
I found my feet chilled by the
cold damp substance that covered
the ground.
I longed to obtain food and
shelter; at
length I perceived a small hut,
on a rising ground, which had
doubtless been built for the
convenience of some shepherd.
examined the structure with
great curiosity.
which he was preparing his
breakfast.
perceiving me, shrieked loudly,
and quitting the hut, ran across
the fields
with a speed of which his
debilitated form hardly appeared
capable.
had ever before seen, and his
flight somewhat surprised me.
of the hut; here the snow and
rain could
not penetrate; the ground was
dry; and it presented to me then
as exquisite and divine a
retreat as Pandaemonium appeared
to the daemons of hell after
their sufferings in the lake of
fire.
shepherd's breakfast, which
consisted of bread, cheese,
milk, and wine; the latter,
however, I did not like.among
some straw and fell asleep.
by the warmth of the sun, which
shone brightly on the white
ground, I determined to
recommence my travels;
and, depositing the remains of
the peasant's breakfast in a
wallet I found, I proceeded
across the fields for several
hours, until at sunset I arrived
at a village.
stately houses engaged my
admiration by turns.
and cheese that I saw placed at
the windows of some of the
cottages, allured my appetite.
I had hardly placed my foot
within the door before the
children shrieked, and one of
the women fainted.
fled, some attacked me, until,
grievously bruised by stones and
many other kinds of missile
weapons, I escaped to the open
country and
fearfully took refuge in a low
hovel, quite bare, and making a
wretched appearance after the
palaces I had beheld in the
village.
a neat and pleasant appearance,
but after my late dearly bought
experience, I dared not enter
it.
wood, but so low that I could
with difficulty sit upright in
it.
earth, which formed the floor,
but it was dry; and although the
wind entered
it by innumerable chinks, I
found it an agreeable asylum
from the snow and rain.
happy to have found a shelter,
however miserable, from the
inclemency of the
season, and still more from the
barbarity of man.
my kennel, that I might view the
adjacent cottage and discover if
I could remain in the habitation
I had found.
cottage and surrounded on the
sides which were exposed by a
pig sty and a clear pool of
water.
crept in; but now I covered
every crevice by which I might
be perceived with stones and
wood, yet in such a manner that
I might move them on
occasion to pass out; all the
light I enjoyed came through the
sty, and that was sufficient for
me.
carpeted it with clean straw, I
retired,
for I saw the figure of a man at
a distance, and I remembered too
well my treatment the night
before to trust myself in his
power.
sustenance for that day by a
loaf of coarse bread, which I
purloined, and a
cup with which I could drink
more conveniently than from my
hand of the pure water which
flowed by my retreat.
it was kept perfectly dry, and
by its vicinity to the chimney
of the cottage it was tolerably
warm.
reside in this hovel until
something should occur which
might alter my determination.
the bleak forest, my former
residence,
the rain-dropping branches, and
dank earth.
was about to remove a plank to
procure myself a little water
when I heard a step, and looking
through a small chink, I beheld
a young creature, with a pail
on her head, passing before my
hovel.
demeanour, unlike what I have
since found cottagers and
farmhouse servants to be.
blue petticoat and a linen
jacket being her only garb; her
fair hair was plaited
but not adorned:  She looked
patient yet sad.
quarter of an hour she returned
bearing the pail, which was now
partly filled with milk.
incommoded by the burden, a
young man met her, whose
countenance expressed a deeper
despondence.
melancholy, he took the pail
from her head and bore it to the
cottage himself.
with some tools in his hand,
cross the field behind the
cottage; and the girl
was also busied, sometimes in
the house and sometimes in the
yard.
one of the windows of the
cottage had
formerly occupied a part of it,
but the panes had been filled up
with wood.
imperceptible chink through
which the eye could just
penetrate.
visible, whitewashed and clean
but very bare of furniture.
an old man, leaning his head on
his hands in a disconsolate
attitude.
arranging the cottage; but
presently she took something out
of a drawer, which
employed her hands, and she sat
down beside the old man, who,
taking up an instrument, began
to play and to produce sounds
sweeter
than the voice of the thrush or
the nightingale.
wretch who had never beheld
aught beautiful before.
countenance of the aged cottager
won my reverence, while the
gentle manners of the girl
enticed my love.
perceived drew tears from the
eyes of his amiable companion,
of which the old
man took no notice, until she
sobbed audibly; he then
pronounced a few sounds, and the
fair creature, leaving her work,
knelt at his feet.
kindness and affection that I
felt sensations of a peculiar
and overpowering nature; they
were a mixture of pain and
pleasure, such as I had
never before experienced, either
from hunger or cold, warmth or
food; and I withdrew from the
window, unable to bear these
emotions.
returned, bearing on his
shoulders a load of wood.
relieve him of his burden, and
taking some of the fuel into the
cottage,
placed it on the fire; then she
and the youth went apart into a
nook of the cottage, and he
showed her a large loaf and a
piece of cheese.
garden for some roots and
plants, which she placed in
water, and then upon the fire.
whilst the young man went into
the garden and appeared busily
employed in digging and pulling
up roots.
an hour, the young woman joined
him and they entered the cottage
together.
pensive, but on the appearance
of his companions he assumed a
more cheerful air, and they sat
down to eat.
arranging the cottage, the old
man
walked before the cottage in the
sun for a few minutes, leaning
on the arm of the youth.
contrast between these two
excellent creatures.
countenance beaming with
benevolence and love; the
younger was slight and graceful
in his figure, and his features
were moulded with the finest
symmetry, yet his eyes and
attitude expressed the utmost
sadness and despondency.
and the youth, with tools
different from
those he had used in the
morning, directed his steps
across the fields.
extreme wonder, I found that the
cottagers had a means of
prolonging light by the use of
tapers, and was delighted to
find that the setting of
the sun did not put an end to
the pleasure I experienced in
watching my human neighbours.
companion were employed in
various occupations which I did
not understand; and the old man
again took up the instrument
which produced the divine sounds
that had enchanted me in the
morning.
began, not to play, but to utter
sounds
that were monotonous, and
neither resembling the harmony
of the old man's instrument nor
the songs of the birds; I
since found that he read aloud,
but at that time I knew nothing
of the science of words or
letters.occupied for a short
time, extinguished their lights
and retired, as I conjectured,
to rest.
”
manners of these people, and I
longed to join them, but dared
not.
had suffered the night before
from the
barbarous villagers, and
resolved, whatever course of
conduct I might hereafter think
it right to pursue, that for the
present I would remain quietly
in my hovel, watching and
endeavouring to discover the
motives which influenced their
actions.
and prepared the food, and the
youth departed after the first
meal.
routine as that which preceded
it.
out of doors, and the girl in
various laborious occupations
within.
be blind, employed his leisure
hours on his instrument or in
contemplation.
respect which the younger
cottagers exhibited towards
their venerable companion.
office of affection and duty
with gentleness, and he rewarded
them by his benevolent smiles.
went apart and appeared to weep.
but I was deeply affected by it.
miserable, it was less strange
that I, an imperfect and
solitary being, should be
wretched.
every luxury; they had a fire to
warm them when chill and
delicious viands
when hungry; they were dressed
in excellent clothes; and, still
more, they enjoyed one another's
company and
speech, interchanging each day
looks of affection and kindness.
questions, but perpetual
attention and time explained to
me many appearances which were
at first enigmatic.
discovered one of the causes of
the uneasiness of this amiable
family:  It was poverty, and
they suffered that evil in a
very distressing degree.
the vegetables of their garden
and the
milk of one cow, which gave very
little during the winter, when
its masters could scarcely
procure food to support it.
pangs of hunger very poignantly,
especially the two younger
cottagers, for several times
they placed food
before the old man when they
reserved none for themselves.
night, to steal a part of their
store for my own consumption,
but when I found
that in doing this I inflicted
pain on the cottagers, I
abstained and satisfied
myself with berries, nuts, and
roots which I gathered from a
neighbouring wood.
through which I was enabled to
assist their labours.
part of each day in collecting
wood for
the family fire, and during the
night I often took his tools,
the use of which I quickly
discovered, and brought home
firing sufficient for the
consumption of several days.
this, the young woman, when she
opened the door in the morning,
appeared
greatly astonished on seeing a
great pile of wood on the
outside.
and the youth joined her, who
also expressed surprise.
not go to the forest that day,
but spent it in repairing the
cottage and cultivating the
garden.
method of communicating their
experience
and feelings to one another by
articulate sounds.
sometimes produced pleasure or
pain,
smiles or sadness, in the minds
and countenances of the hearers.
I ardently desired to become
acquainted with it.
words they uttered, not having
any apparent connection with
visible objects, I was unable to
discover any
clue by which I could unravel
the mystery of their reference.
after having remained during
676767676767 the space of
several revolutions of the moon
in my hovel, I discovered the
names that were given to some of
the most familiar objects of
discourse; I learned and applied
the words,fire, milk, bread,
andwood.
them several names, but the old
man had only one, which
wasfather.
the youthFelix, brother, orson.
when I learned the ideas
appropriated to each of these
sounds and was able to
pronounce
The gentle manners and beauty of
the cottagers greatly endeared
them to me; when they were
unhappy, I felt depressed; when
they rejoiced, I sympathised in
their joys.
I saw few human beings besides
them, and if any other happened
to enter the cottage, their
harsh manners and rude
gait only enhanced to me the
superior  accomplishments of my
friends.
The old man, I could perceive,
often endeavoured to encourage
his children, as sometimes I
found that he called them, to
cast off their melancholy.
He would talk in a cheerful
accent,
with an expression of
goodness that bestowed pleasure
even upon me.
Agatha listened with respect,
her eyes sometimes filled with
tears, which she endeavoured to
wipe away unperceived; but I
generally found that her
countenance and tone were more
cheerful after having listened
to the exhortations of her
father.
It was not thus with Felix.
He was always the saddest of the
group, and even to my
unpractised senses, he appeared
to have suffered more deeply
than his friends.
But if his countenance was more
sorrowful, his voice was more
cheerful than that of his
sister, especially when he
addressed the old man.
“I could mention innumerable
instances which, although
slight, marked the dispositions
of these amiable cottagers.
In the midst of poverty and
want, Felix carried with
pleasure to his sister the first
little white flower that peeped
out from beneath the snowy
ground.
Early in the morning, before she
had risen, he cleared away the
snow that obstructed her path to
the milk-house, drew water from
the well, and brought the wood
from the outhouse, where, to
his perpetual astonishment, he
found his store always
replenished by  an invisible
hand.
In the day, I believe, he worked
sometimes for a neighbouring
farmer,
because he often went  forth and
did not return until  dinner,
yet brought no wood with him.
At other times he worked in the
garden, but as there was little
to do in the frosty season, he
read to the old man and Agatha.
“This reading had puzzled me
extremely at first, but by
degrees I discovered that he
uttered many of the same sounds
when he read as when he talked.
I conjectured, therefore, that
he found on the paper signs for
speech which he understood, and
I ardently longed to comprehend
these also; but how was that
possible when I did not even
understand the sounds for which
they stood as signs?
I improved, however, sensibly in
this science, but not
sufficiently to follow up any
kind of conversation, although I
applied my whole mind to the
endeavour, for I easily
perceived that, although I
eagerly longed to discover
myself to the cottagers, I ought
not to make the attempt until I
had first become master of their
language, which knowledge might
enable me to make them overlook
the deformity of my figure, for
with this also the contrast
perpetually presented to my eyes
had made me acquainted.
“I had admired the perfect forms
of my cottagers—their grace,
beauty, and
delicate  complexions; but how
was I  terrified when I viewed
myself  in a transparent pool!
At first I started back, unable
to believe that it was indeed I
who was reflected in the mirror;
and when I became fully
convinced that I was in
reality  the monster that I am,
I was  filled with the bitterest
sensations of despondence and
mortification.
Alas!
I did not yet entirely know the
fatal effects of this miserable
deformity.
“As the sun became warmer and
the light of day longer, the
snow vanished, and I beheld the
bare trees and the black earth.
From this time Felix was more
employed, and the heart-moving
indications of impending famine
disappeared.
Their food, as I afterwards
found, was coarse, but it was
wholesome; and they procured a
sufficiency of it.
Several new kinds of plants
sprang up in the garden, which
they dressed; and these signs of
comfort increased daily as the
season advanced.
“The old man, leaning on his
son, walked each day at noon,
when it did not rain, as I found
it was called when the heavens
poured forth its waters.
This frequently took place, but
a high wind quickly dried the
earth, and the season became far
more pleasant than it had been.
“My mode of life in my hovel was
uniform.
During the morning I attended
the motions of the cottagers,
and when they were dispersed in
various occupations,
I slept;  the remainder of the
day was  spent in observing my
friends.
When they had retired to rest,
if there was any moon or the
night was star-light, I went
into the woods and collected my
own food and fuel for the
cottage.
When I returned, as often as it
was necessary, I cleared their
path from the snow and performed
those offices that I had seen
done by Felix.
I afterwards found that these
labours, performed by an
invisible hand, greatly
astonished them; and once or
twice I
heard them, on these
occasions, utter the words good
spirit, wonderful; but I did not
then understand the
signification of these terms.
“My thoughts now became more
active, and I longed to discover
the motives and feelings of
these lovely creatures; I was
inquisitive to know why Felix
appeared so miserable and Agatha
so sad.
I thought that it might be in my
power to restore happiness to
these deserving people.
When I slept or was absent, the
forms of the venerable blind
father, the gentle Agatha, and
the excellent Felix flitted
before me.
I looked upon them as superior
beings who would be the arbiters
of my future destiny.
I formed in my imagination a
thousand pictures of presenting
myself to them, and their
reception of me.
I imagined that they would be
disgusted, until, by my gentle
demeanour and conciliating
words, I should first win their
favour and afterwards their
love.
These thoughts exhilarated me
and led me to apply with fresh
ardour to the acquiring the art
of language.
My organs were indeed harsh, but
supple; and although my voice
was very unlike the soft music
of their tones, yet I pronounced
such words as I understood with
tolerable ease.
It was as the ass and the
lap-dog; yet surely the gentle
ass whose intentions
were  affectionate, although his
manners were rude, deserved
better treatment than blows and
execration.
"The pleasant showers and genial
warmth of spring greatly altered
the aspect of the earth.
Men who before this change
seemed to have been hid in caves
dispersed themselves and were
employed in various arts of
cultivation.
The birds sang in more cheerful
notes, and the leaves began to
bud forth on the trees.
Happy, happy earth!
Fit habitation for gods, which,
so short a time before, was
bleak, damp, and unwholesome.
My spirits were elevated by the
enchanting appearance of nature;
the past was blotted from my
memory, the present was
tranquil, and the future gilded
by bright rays of hope
and  AntsAnticipations of joy."
>> I replied in the affirmative.
Every minute
continued you have burdened your
memory
with exploded systems and
useless names Good God!
In what desert land have you
lived, where no one was kind
enough to inform you that these
fancies which you have so
greedily imbibed are a thousand
years old and as musty as they
are ancient?
I little expected, in this
enlightened and scientific age,
to find a disciple of Albertus
Magnus and Paracelsus.
My dear sir, you must begin your
studies entirely anew.
So saying, he stepped aside and
wrote down a list of several
books treating of natural
philosophy which he desired me
to procure, and dismissed me
after mentioning that in the
beginning of the following week
he intended to commence a course
of lectures upon natural
philosophy in its general
relations, and that M.
Waldman,  a fellow professor,
would  lecture upon chemistry
the  alternate days that he
omitted.
I returned home not
Disapointed.
Beg, pardon.
My senses were gratified and
refreshed by a thousand scents
of delight and a thousand sights
of beauty.
It was on one of these days,
when my cottagers periodically
rested from labour—the old man
played on his guitar, and the
children listened to him—that I
observed the countenance of
Felix was melancholy beyond
expression; he sighed
frequently, and once his
father  paused in his music, and
I  conjectured by his manner
that  he inquired the cause of
his  son's sorrow.
Felix replied in a cheerful
accent, and the old man was
recommencing his music when
someone tapped at the door.
It was a lady on horseback,
accompanied by a country-man as
a guide.
The lady was dressed in a dark
suit and covered with a thick
black veil.
Agatha asked a question, to
which the stranger only replied
by pronouncing, in a sweet
accent, the name of Felix.
Her voice was musical but unlike
that of either of my friends.
On hearing this word, Felix came
up hastily to the lady, who,
when she saw him, threw up her
veil, and I beheld a
countenance of angelic beauty
and  expression.
Her hair of a shining raven
black, and curiously braided;
her eyes were dark, but gentle,
although animated; her features
of a regular proportion, and her
complexion
wondrously fair, each cheek
tinged with a lovely pink.
Felix seemed ravished with
delight when he saw her, every
trait of sorrow vanished from
his face, and it instantly
expressed a degree of ecstatic
joy, of which I could hardly
have believed it capable; his
eyes sparkled, as his cheek
flushed with pleasure; and at
that moment I thought him as
beautiful as the stranger.
She appeared affected by
different feelings; wiping a few
tears from her lovely eyes, she
held out her hand to Felix, who
kissed it rapturously and called
her, as well as I could
distinguish, his sweet Arabian.
She did not appear to understand
him, but smiled.
He assisted her to dismount, and
dismissing her guide, conducted
her into the cottage.
Some conversation took place
between him and his father, and
the young stranger knelt at the
old man's feet and would have
kissed his hand, but he raised
her and embraced her
affectionately.
I soon perceived that although
the stranger uttered articulate
sounds and appeared to have a
language of her own, she was
neither understood by nor
herself understood the
cottagers.
They made many signs which I did
not comprehend, but I saw that
her presence
diffused gladness  through the
cottage, dispelling  their
sorrow as the sun  dissipates
the morning mists.
Felix seemed peculiarly happy
and with smiles of delight
welcomed his Arabian.
Agatha, the ever-gentle Agatha,
kissed the hands of the lovely
stranger, and pointing to her
brother, made signs
which  appeared to me to mean
that he  had been sorrowful
until she  came.
Some hours passed thus, while
they, by their countenances,
expressed joy, the cause of
which I did not comprehend.
Presently I found, by the
frequent recurrence of some
sound which the stranger
repeated after them, that she
was endeavouring to learn their
language; and the idea instantly
occurred to me that I should
make use of the same
instructions to the same end.
The stranger learned about
twenty words at the first
lesson; most of them, indeed,
were those which I had before
understood, but I profited by
the others.
As night came on, Agatha and the
Arabian retired early.
When they separated Felix kissed
the hand of the stranger and
said, ‘Good night sweet Safie.
' He sat up much longer,
conversing with his father, and
by the frequent repetition of
her name I conjectured that
their lovely guest was the
subject of their conversation.
I ardently desired to understand
them, and bent every faculty
towards that purpose, but found
it utterly impossible.
The next morning Felix went out
to his work, and after the usual
occupations of Agatha were
finished, the Arabian sat
at the feet of the old man, and
taking  his guitar, played some
airs so  entrancingly beautiful
that they at once drew tears of
sorrow and delight from my eyes.
She sang, and her voice flowed
in a rich cadence, swelling or
dying away like a nightingale of
the woods.
When she had finished, she gave
the guitar to Agatha, who at
first declined it.
She played a simple air, and her
voice accompanied it in sweet
accents, but unlike the wondrous
strain of the stranger.
The old man appeared enraptured
and said some words which Agatha
endeavoured to explain to Safie,
and by which he appeared to wish
to express that she bestowed on
him the greatest delight by her
music.
The days now passed as peaceably
as before, with the  sole
alteration that
joy had  taken place of sadness
in the  countenances of my
friends.
Safie was always gay and happy;
she and I improved rapidly in
the knowledge of language, so
that in two months I began to
comprehend most of the words
uttered by my protectors.
In the meanwhile also the black
ground was covered with herbage,
and the green banks interspersed
with innumerable flowers, sweet
to the scent and the
eyes, stars of pale radiance
among the  moonlight woods; the
sun became  warmer, the nights
clear and  balmy; and my
nocturnal rambles  were an
extreme pleasure to me,
although they were considerably
shortened by the late setting
and early rising of the sun,
for I never ventured abroad
during  daylight, fearful of
meeting  with the same treatment
I had  formerly endured in the
first  village which I entered.
>> We'll now take a short
15-minute break.  Thank you.
My days were spent in close
attention, that I might more
speedily master the language;
and I may boast that I improved
more rapidly than the Arabian,
who understood very little and
conversed in broken accents,
whilst I comprehended and could
imitate almost every word that
was spoken.
While I improved in speech, I
also learned the science of
letters as it was taught to the
stranger, and this opened before
me a wide field for wonder and
delight.
The book from which Felix
instructed Safie was
Volney'sRuins of Empires.
I should not have understood the
purport of this book had not
Felix, in reading it, given very
minute explanations.
He had chosen this work, he
said, because the declamatory
style was framed in imitation of
the Eastern authors.
Through this work I obtained a
cursory knowledge of history and
a view of the several empires at
present existing in the world;
it gave me an insight into the
manners, governments, and
religions of the different
nations of the earth.
I heard of the slothful
Asiatics, of the stupendous
genius and mental activity of
the Grecians, of the wars
and  wonderful virtue of the
early  Romans—of their
subsequent  degenerating—of the
decline of  that mighty empire,
of chivalry, Christianity, and
kings.
I heard of the discovery of the
American hemisphere and wept
with Safie over the hapless fate
of its original inhabitants.
These wonderful narrations
inspired me with strange
feelings.
Was man, indeed, at once so
powerful, so virtuous and
magnificent, yet so vicious and
base?
He appeared at one time a mere
scion of the evil principle and
at another as all that can be
conceived of noble and godlike.
To be a great and virtuous man
appeared the highest honour that
can befall a sensitive being; to
be base and vicious, as many on
record have been, appeared
the  lowest degradation, a
condition  more abject than that
of the  blind mole or harmless
worm.
For a long time I could not
conceive how one man could go
forth to murder his fellow, or
even why there were laws
and  governments; but when I
heard  details of vice and
bloodshed,  my wonder ceased and
I turned  away with disgust and
loathing.
Every conversation of the
cottagers now opened new wonders
to me.
While I listened to the
instructions which Felix
bestowed upon the Arabian, the
strange system of human society
was explained to me.
I heard of the division of
property, of immense wealth and
squalid poverty, of rank,
descent, and noble blood.
The words induced me in turn
towards myself.
I learned that the possessions
most esteemed by your fellow
creatures were high and
unsullied descent united with
riches.
A man might be respected with
only one of these advantages,
but without either he was
considered, except in very rare
instances, as a vagabond and a
slave, doomed to waste his
powers for the profits of the
chosen few!
And what was I?
Of my creation and creator I was
absolutely ignorant, but I knew
that I possessed no money, no
friends, no kind of property.
I was, besides, endued with a
figure hideously deformed and
loathsome; I was not even of the
same nature as man.
I was more agile than they and
could subsist upon coarser diet;
I bore the extremes of heat and
cold with less injury to my
frame; my stature far exceeded
theirs.
When I looked around I saw and
heard of none like me.
Was I, then, a monster, a blot
upon the earth, from which all
men fled and whom all men
disowned?
I cannot describe to you the
agony that
these reflections  inflicted
upon me; I tried to  dispel
them, but sorrow only  increased
with knowledge.
Oh, that I had for ever remained
in my native wood, nor known nor
felt beyond the sensations of
hunger, thirst, and heat!
Of what a strange nature is
knowledge!
It clings to the mind when it
has once seized on it like a
lichen on the rock.
I wished sometimes to shake off
all thought and feeling, but I
learned that there was but one
means to overcome the
sensation
Of pain and that was death -- a
state which I feared yet did not
understand.
I admired virtue and good
feelings and loved the gentle
manners and amiable qualities of
my cottagers, but I was shut out
from intercourse with them,
except through means which I
obtained by stealth, when I was
unseen and unknown, and which
rather increased than satisfied
the desire I had of
becoming one Of my fellows.
The gentle words of Agatha and
the animated smiles of the
charming Arabian were not for
me.
The mild exhortations of the old
man and the lively conversation
of the loved Felix were not for
me.
Miserable, unhappy wretch!
Other lessons were impressed
upon me even more deeply.
I heard of the difference of
sexes, and the birth and growth
of children, how the father
doted on the smiles of the
infant, and the lively sallies
of the older child, how all the
life and cares of the mother
were wrapped up in the precious
charge, how the mind of youth
expanded and gained knowledge,
of brother, sister, and all the
various relationships which bind
one human being to another in
mutual bonds.
Where were my friends relations?
No father had watched my infant
days, no mother had blessed me
with smiles and caresses; or if
they had, all my past life was
now a blot, a blind vacancy in
which I distinguished nothing.
From my earliest remembrance I
had been as I then was in height
and proportion.
I had never yet seen a being
resembling me or who claimed any
intercourse with me.
What was I?
The question again recurred, to
be answered only with groans.
I will soon explain to what
these feelings tended, but allow
me now to return to the
cottagers, whose story excited
in me such various feelings of
indignation, delight, and
wonder, but which all terminated
in additional love
and reverence For my protectors"
for so
I loved in a innocent half
painful, half deceit to call
them."
Chapter 6.
Some time elapsed before I
learned the
history of my  friends.
It was one which could not fail
to impress itself deeply on my
mind, unfolding as it did a
number of circumstances, each
interesting and wonderful to one
so utterly inexperienced as I
was.
The name of the old man was De
Lacey.
He was descended from a good
family in France, where he had
lived for many
years in  affluence, respected
by his  superiors and beloved by
his  equals.
His son was bred in the service
of his country, and Agatha had
ranked with ladies of the
highest distinction.
A few months before my arrival
they had lived in a large and
luxurious city called Paris,
surrounded by friends and
possessed of every enjoyment
which virtue, refinement of
intellect, or taste, accompanied
by a moderate fortune, could
afford.
The father of Safie had been the
cause of their ruin.
He was a Turkish merchant and
had inhabited Paris for many
years, when, for some reason
which I could not learn, he
became obnoxious to the
government.
He was seized and cast into
prison the very day that Safie
arrived from Constantinople to
join him.
He was tried and condemned to
death.
The injustice of his sentence
was very flagrant; all Paris was
indignant; and it was judged
that his religion and
wealth  rather than the crime
alleged  against him had been
the cause  of his condemnation.
Felix had been present at the
trial; his horror and
indignation were  uncontrollable
when he heard the decision of
the court.
He made, at that moment, a
solemn vow to deliver him and
then looked around for the
means.
After many fruitless attempts to
gain admittance to the prison,
he found a strongly grated
window in an unguarded part of
the building, which lighted the
dungeon of the unfortunate
Muhammadan, who, loaded with
chains, waited in despair the
execution of the barbarous
sentence.
Felix visited the grate at night
and made known to the prisoner
his intentions in his favour.
The Turk, amazed and delighted,
endeavoured to kindle the zeal
of his deliverer by promises of
reward and wealth.
Felix rejected his offers with
contempt, yet when he saw the
lovely Safie, who was allowed to
visit her father and who by her
gestures expressed her lively
gratitude, the youth could not
help owning to his own mind that
the captive possessed a treasure
which would fully reward his
toil and hazard.
The Turk quickly perceived the
impression that his daughter had
made on the heart of Felix and
endeavoured to secure him more
entirely in his interests by the
promise of her hand in marriage
so soon as he should be conveyed
to a place of safety.
Felix was too delicate to accept
this offer, yet he looked
forward to the probability of
the event as to the consummation
of his happiness.
During the ensuing days, when
the preparations were going
forward for the escape of the
merchant, the zeal of Felix was
warmed by several letters that
he received from this lovely
girl, who found means to express
her thoughts in the language of
her lover by the aid of an old
man, a servant of her father who
understood French.
She thanked him in the most
ardent
terms for his intended  Services
towards her father, and at the
same time she gently  deplored
her own fate.
I have copies of these letters,
for I found means, during my
residence in the hovel, to
procure the implements of
writing; and the letters were
often in the hands of Felix or
Agatha.
Before I depart I will give them
to you; they will prove the
truth of my tale;
but at  present, as the sun is
already  far declined, I shall
only have  time to repeat the
substance of  them to you.
Safie related that her mother
was a Christian Arab, seized and
made a slave by the Turks;
recommended by her beauty, she
had won the heart of the father
of Safie, who married her.
The young girl spoke in high and
enthusiastic terms of her
mother, who, born in freedom,
spurned the bondage to which she
was now reduced.
She instructed her daughter in
the tenets of her religion and
taught her to aspire to higher
powers of intellect and an
independence of spirit forbidden
to the female followers of
Muhammad.
This lady died, but her lessons
were indelibly impressed on the
mind of Safie, who sickened at
the prospect of again returning
to Asia and being immured within
the walls of a harem,
allowed  only to occupy herself
with  infantile amusements,
ill-suited to the temper of her
soul, now  accustomed to grand
ideas and a  noble emulation for
virtue.
The prospect of marrying a
Christian and remaining in a
country where women were allowed
to take a rank in society was
enchanting to her.
The day for the execution of the
Turk was fixed, but on the
night previous to it he quitted
his prison and before morning
was distant many leagues from
Paris.
Felix had procured passports in
the name of his father, sister,
and himself.
He had previously communicated
his plan to the former, who
aided the deceit by quitting his
house, under the pretence
of a  journey and concealed
himself,  with his daughter, in
an obscure part of Paris.
Felix conducted the fugitives
through France to Lyons and
across Mont Cenis to Leghorn,
where the merchant had decided
to wait a favourable opportunity
of passing into some part of the
Turkish dominions.
Safie resolved to remain with
her father until the moment of
his departure, before which time
the Turk renewed his promise
that she should be united to his
deliverer; and Felix remained
with them in expectation of
that event; and in the meantime
he  enjoyed the society of the
Arabian, who exhibited towards
him the simplest and tenderest
affection.
They conversed with one another
through the means of an
interpreter, and sometimes with
the interpretation of looks; and
Safie sang to him the divine
airs of her native country.
The Turk allowed this intimacy
to take place and encouraged the
hopes of the youthful lovers,
while in his heart he had formed
far other plans.
He loathed the idea that his
daughter should be united to a
Christian, but he feared the
resentment of Felix if he
should appear lukewarm, for he
knew  that he was still in the
power  of his deliverer if he
should  choose to betray
him to the  Italian state which
they  inhabited.
He revolved a thousand plans by
which he should be enabled to
prolong the deceit until it
might be no longer
necessary,  and secretly to take
his  daughter with him when he
departed.
His plans were facilitated by
the news which arrived from
Paris.
The government of France were
greatly enraged at the escape of
their victim and spared no pains
to detect and punish his
deliverer.
The plot of Felix was quickly
discovered, and De Lacey and
Agatha were thrown into prison.
The news reached Felix and
roused him from his dream of
pleasure.
His blind and aged father and
his gentle sister lay in a
noisome dungeon while he enjoyed
the free air and the society of
her whom he loved.
This idea was torture to him.
He quickly arranged with the
Turk that if the latter should
find a favourable opportunity
for escape before Felix
could  return to Italy, Safie
should  remain as a boarder at a
convent at Leghorn; and then,
quitting  the lovely Arabian, he
hastened  to Paris and delivered
himself
up to the vengeance of the law,
hoping to free De Lacey and
Agatha by this proceeding.
He did not succeed.
They remained confined for five
months before the trial took
place, the result of which
deprived them of their fortune
and condemned them to a
perpetual exile from their
native country.
They found a miserable asylum in
the cottage in Germany, where I
discovered them.
Felix soon learned that the
treacherous Turk, for whom he
and his family endured such
unheard-of oppression, on
discovering that his deliverer
was thus reduced to poverty and
ruin, became a traitor to good
feeling and honour and
had  quitted Italy with his
daughter, insultingly sending
Felix a  pittance of money to
aid him, as he said, in some
plan of future  maintenance.
Such were the events that preyed
on the heart of Felix and
rendered him, when I first saw
him, the most miserable of his
family.
He could have endured poverty,
and while this distress had been
the meed of
his virtue, he  gloried in it;
but the  ingratitude of the Turk
and the  loss of his beloved
Safie were  misfortunes more
bitter and  irreparable.
The arrival of the Arabian now
infused new life into his soul.
When the news reached Leghorn
that Felix was deprived of his
wealth and rank, the merchant
commanded his daughter to think
no more of her lover, but to
prepare to return to her native
country.
The generous nature of Safie was
outraged by this command; she
attempted to expostulate with
her father, but he
left her  angrily, reiterating
his  tyrannical mandate.
A few days later, the Turk
entered his daughter's apartment
and told her hastily that he had
reason to believe that his
residence at Leghorn had been
divulged and that he should
speedily be delivered up to the
French government; he had
consequently hired a vessel to
convey him to Constantinople,
for which city he should sail in
a few hours.
He intended to leave his
daughter under the care of a
confidential servant, to follow
at her leisure with the greater
part of his property, which had
not yet arrived at Leghorn.
When alone, Safie resolved in
her own mind the plan of conduct
that it would become her to
pursue in this emergency.
A residence in Turkey was
abhorrent to her; her religion
and her feelings were alike
averse to it.
By some papers of her father
which fell into her hands she
heard of the exile of her lover
and learnt the name of the spot
where he then resided.
She hesitated some time, but at
length she formed her
determination.
Taking with her some jewels that
belonged to her and a sum of
money, she quitted Italy with an
attendant, a native of Leghorn,
but who understood the common
language of Turkey, and departed
for Germany.
She arrived in safety at a town
about twenty leagues from the
cottage of De Lacey, when her
attendant fell dangerously ill.
Safie nursed her with the most
devoted affection, but the poor
girl died, and the Arabian was
left alone, unacquainted with
the language of the country and
utterly ignorant of the customs
of the world.
She fell, however, into good
hands.
The Italian had mentioned the
name of the spot for which they
were bound, and after her death
the woman of the house in which
they had lived took care that
Safie should arrive in safety at
the cottage of her lover.
Chapter 7.  Such was the history
of my beloved cottagers.
It impressed me deeply.
I learned, from the views of
social life which it developed,
to admire their virtues and to
deprecate the vices of mankind.
As yet I looked upon crime as a
distant evil, benevolence and
generosity were ever present
before me, inciting within
me a  desire to become an actor
in the busy scene where so many
admirable qualities were called
forth and displayed.
But in giving an account of the
progress of my intellect, I must
not omit a circumstance which
occurred in the beginning of the
month of August of the same
year.
One night during my accustomed
visit to the neighbouring wood
where I collected my own food
and brought home firing for
my  protectors, I found on the
ground a leathern portmanteau
containing several articles of
dress and some books.
I eagerly seized the prize and
returned with it to my hovel.
Fortunately the books were
written in the language, the
elements of which I had acquired
at the cottage; they
consisted
of Paradise Lost, a volume
ofPlutarch's Lives, and
theSorrows of Werter.
The possession of these
treasures gave me extreme
delight; I now continually
studied and exercised my mind
upon these histories, whilst my
friends were employed in their
ordinary occupations.
I can hardly describe to you the
effect of these books.
They produced in me an infinity
of new images and feelings, that
sometimes raised me to ecstasy,
but more frequently sunk me into
the lowest dejection.
In theSorrows of Werter, besides
the interest of its simple and
affecting story, so many
opinions are canvassed and so
many lights thrown upon what had
hitherto been to me obscure
subjects that I found in it a
never-ending source of
speculation and astonishment.
The gentle and domestic manners
it described, combined with
lofty sentiments and feelings,
which had for their object
something out of self, accorded
well with my experience among
my protectors and with the wants
which were for ever alive in my
own bosom.
But I thought Werter himself a
more divine being than I had
ever beheld or
imagined; his  character
contained no  pretension, but it
sank deep.
The disquisitions upon death and
suicide were calculated to fill
me with wonder.
I did not pretend to enter into
the merits of the case, yet I
inclined
towards the opinions of the
hero, whose extinction I  wept,
without precisely  understanding
it.
As I read, however, I applied
much personally to my own
feelings and condition.
I found myself similar yet at
the same
time strangely unlike  to the
beings concerning whom I  read
and to whose conversation I was
a listener.
I sympathised with and partly
understood them, but I was
unformed in mind; I was
dependent on none and related to
none.
The path of my departure was
free, and there was none to
lament my annihilation.
My person was hideous and my
stature gigantic.
What did this mean?
Who was I?
What was I?
Whence did I come?
What was my destination?
These questions continually
recurred, but I was unable to
solve them.
The volume ofPlutarch's  Lives
which I possessed  contained the
histories of the  first founders
of the ancient  republics.
This book had a far different
effect upon me from theSorrows
of Werter.
I learned from Werter's
imaginations
despondency and  gloom, but
Plutarch taught me  high
thoughts; he elevated me  above
the
wretched sphere of my  own
reflections, to admire and  love
the heroes of past ages.
Many things I read surpassed my
understanding and experience.
I had a very confused knowledge
of
kingdoms, wide extents of
country, mighty rivers, and
boundless seas.
But I was perfectly unacquainted
with towns and large assemblages
of men.
The cottage of my protectors had
been the only school in which I
had studied human nature, but
this book developed new and
mightier scenes of action.
I read of men concerned in
public affairs, governing or
massacring their species.
I felt the greatest ardour for
virtue
rise within me, and  abhorrence
for vice, as far as I understood
the signification of  those
terms, relative as they  were,
as I applied them, to  pleasure
and pain alone.
Induced by these feelings, I was
of course led to admire
peaceable lawgivers, Numa,
Solon, and Lycurgus,
in  preference to Romulus and
Theseus.
The patriarchal lives of my
protectors caused these
impressions to take a firm
hold  on my mind; perhaps, if my
first introduction to humanity
had  been made by a young
soldier,  burning for glory and
slaughter, I should have been
imbued with  different
sensations.
But Paradise Lost excited
different and far deeper
emotions.
I read it, as I had read the
other volumes which had fallen
into my hands, as a true
history.
It moved every feeling of wonder
and awe that the picture of an
omnipotent God warring with his
creatures was capable
of  Having.
I often referred the several
situations, as their similarity
struck me, to my own.
Like Adam I was created
apparently united by no link to
any other  being in existence;
but his  state was far different
from  mine in every other
respect.
He had come forth from the hands
of God a perfect creature, happy
and prosperous, guarded by the
especial care of his Creator; he
was allowed to converse with and
acquire knowledge from
beings of a superior nature, but
I was  wretched, helpless, and
alone.
Many times I considered Satan as
the fitter emblem of my
condition, for often, like him,
when I viewed the bliss of my
protectors, the bitter gall of
envy rose within me.
Another circumstance
strengthened and confirmed these
feelings.
Soon after my arrival in the
hovel I discovered some papers
in the pocket of the dress which
I had taken from your
laboratory.
At first I had neglected them,
but now that I was able to
decipher the characters in which
they were written, I began to
study them with diligence.
It was your journal of the four
months that preceded my
creation.
You minutely described in these
papers every step you took in
the progress of your work; this
history was mingled
with  accounts of domestic
occurrences.
You doubtless recollect these
papers.
Here they are.
Everything is related in them
which bears reference to my
accursed origin; the whole
detail of that series of
disgusting circumstances which
produced it is set in view; the
minutest description of my
odious and loathsome person is
given, in language which
painted your own horrors and
rendered  mine indelible.
I sickened as I read.
Hateful day when I received life
I
exclaimed in agony.
‘Accursed creator!
Why did you form a monster so
hideous that evenyou turned from
me in disgust?
God, in pity, made man beautiful
and alluring, after his own
image; but my form is a filthy
type of yours, more horrid even
from the very resemblance.
Satan had his companions, fellow
devils, to admire and encourage
him, but I am
solitary and
Detested" these were the
reflections of my hours of
despondency and  solitude; but
when I  contemplated the virtues
of
the  cottagers, their amiable
and  benevolent dispositions, I
persuaded myself that when they
should become acquainted with my
admiration of their virtues they
would compassionate me and
overlook my personal deformity.
Could they turn from their door
one, however monstrous, who
solicited their compassion and
friendship?
I resolved, at least, not to
despair, but in every way to fit
myself for an interview with
them which would decide my fate.
I postponed this attempt for
some months longer, for the
importance attached to its
success inspired me with a dread
lest I should fail.
Besides, I found that my
understanding improved so much
with every day's experience that
I was unwilling to commence this
undertaking until a few
more  months should have added
to my  Wisdom.   Several changes
in the meantime, took place in
the cottage.
The presence of Safie diffused
happiness among its inhabitants,
and I also found that a greater
degree of plenty reigned there.
Felix and Agatha spent more time
in amusement and conversation,
and were assisted in their
labours by servants.
They did not appear rich, but
they were contented and happy;
their feelings were serene and
peaceful, while mine became
every day more tumultuous.
Increase of knowledge only
discovered to me more clearly
what a wretched outcast I was.
I cherished hope, it is true,
but it vanished when I beheld my
person reflected in water or my
shadow in the moonshine, even as
that frail image and that
inconstant shade.
“I endeavoured to crush these
fears and to fortify myself for
the trial which in a few months
I resolved to undergo;
and  sometimes I allowed my
thoughts, unchecked by reason,
to ramble  in the fields of
Paradise, and  dared to fancy
amiable and  lovely creatures
sympathising  with my feelings
and
cheering my gloom; their angelic
countenances breathed smiles of
consolation.
But it was all a dream; no Eve
soothed my sorrows nor shared my
thoughts; I was alone.
I remembered Adam's supplication
to his Creator.
But where was mine?
He had abandoned me, and in the
bitterness of my heart I cursed
him.
Autumn passed thus.
I saw, with surprise and grief,
the leaves decay and fall, and
nature again assume the barren
and bleak appearance it had worn
when I first beheld the woods
and the lovely moon.
Yet I did not heed the bleakness
of the
weather; I was better  Yet I did
not heed the bleakness of the
weather; I was better fitted by
my conformation for the
endurance of cold than heat.the
flowers, the birds, and all the
gay apparel of summer; when
those deserted me, I turned with
more attention towards the
cottagers.
the absence of summer.
another; and their joys,
depending on each other, were
not interrupted by the
casualties that took place
around them.
became my desire to claim their
protection and kindness; my
heart yearned to be known and
loved by these amiable
creatures; to see their sweet
looks directed towards me with
affection was the utmost limit
of my ambition.
them from me with disdain and
horror.
treasures than a little food or
rest:  I required kindness and
sympathy; but I did not believe
myself utterly unworthy of it.
revolution of the seasons had
taken place since I awoke into
life.
directed towards my plan of
introducing myself into the
cottage of my protectors.
which I finally fixed was to
enter the dwelling when the
blind old man should be alone.
the unnatural hideousness of my
person was the chief object of
horror with My voice, although
harsh, had nothing terrible in
it; I thought, therefore, that
if in the absence of his
children I
could gain the good will and
mediation of the old De Lacey, I
might by his means be tolerated
by my younger protectors.
of about 20 minutes. Thank you.
“One day, when the sun shone on
the red leaves that strewed the
ground and diffused
cheerfulness, although it
denied warmth, Safie, Agatha,
and Felix departed on a long
country walk, and the old man,
at his own desire, was left
alone in the cottage.
up his guitar and played several
mournful but sweet airs, more
sweet and mournful than I had
ever heard him play before.
illuminated with pleasure, but
as he continued, thoughtfulness
and sadness
succeeded; at length, laying
aside the instrument, he sat
absorbed in reflection.
and moment of trial, which would
decide my hopes or realise my
fears.
cottage; it was an excellent
opportunity; yet, when I
proceeded to execute my plan, my
limbs failed me and I sank to
the ground.
firmness of which I was master,
removed the planks which I had
placed before my hovel to
conceal my retreat.
renewed determination I
approached the door of their
cottage.
a traveller in want of a little
rest; you would greatly oblige
me if you would
allow me to remain a few minutes
before the fire.
try in what manner I can to
relieve your wants; but,
unfortunately, my children
are from home, and as I am
blind, I am afraid I shall find
it difficult to procure food for
you.
host; I have food; it is warmth
and rest only that I need.
to me, yet I remained irresolute
in what manner to commence the
interview, when the old man
addressed me.
you are my countryman; are you
French?
family and understand that
language only.
of some friends, whom I
sincerely love, and of whose
favour I have some hopes.
creature, I look around and I
have no relation or friend upon
earth.
never seen me and know little of
me.
there, I am an outcast in the
world for ever.
unfortunate, but the hearts of
men, when unprejudiced by any
obvious self-interest, are full
of brotherly love and charity.
and if these friends are good
and amiable, do not despair.
excellent creatures in the
world; but, unfortunately, they
are prejudiced against me.
been hitherto harmless and in
some degree beneficial; but a
fatal prejudice
clouds their eyes, and where
they ought to see a feeling and
kind friend, they behold only a
detestable monster.
you are really blameless, cannot
you undeceive them?
and it is on that account that I
feel so many overwhelming
terrors.
unknown to them, been for many
months in the habits of daily
kindness towards
them; but they believe that I
wish to injure them, and it is
that prejudice which I wish to
overcome.
continued, ‘If you will
unreservedly confide to me the
particulars of your
tale, I perhaps may be of use in
undeceiving them.
countenance, but there is
something in your words which
persuades me that you are
sincere.
afford me true pleasure to be in
any way serviceable to a human
creature.
kindness; and I trust that, by
your aid, I shall not be driven
from the society
and sympathy of your fellow
creatures.
that can only drive you to
desperation, and not instigate
you to virtue.
have been condemned, although
innocent;
judge, therefore, if I do not
feel for your misfortunes.
voice of kindness directed
towards me; I
shall be for ever grateful; and
your present humanity assures me
of success with those friends
whom I am on the point of
meeting.
decision, which was to rob me of
or bestow happiness on me for
ever.
sufficient to answer him, but
the effort destroyed all my
remaining strength; I sank on
the chair and sobbed aloud.
the hand of the old man, I
cried, ‘Now is the time!
opened, and Felix, Safie, and
Agatha entered.
consternation on beholding me?
attend to her friend, rushed out
of the cottage.supernatural
force tore me from his I could
have torn him limb from limb, as
the lion rends the antelope.
bitter sickness, and I
refrained.
blow, when, overcome by pain and
anguish, I quitted the cottage,
and in the general tumult
escaped unperceived to my hovel.
”
extinguish the spark of
existence which you had so
wantonly bestowed?
possession of me; my feelings
were those of rage and revenge.
the cottage and its inhabitants
and have
glutted myself with their
shrieks and misery.
and wandered in the wood; and
now, no
longer restrained by the fear of
discovery, I gave vent to my
anguish in fearful howlings.
the toils, destroying the
objects that obstructed me and
ranging through the wood with a
stag-like swiftness.
the bare trees waved their
branches above me; now and then
the sweet voice of a bird burst
forth amidst the universal
stillness.
enjoyment; I, like the
arch-fiend, bore
a hell within me, and finding
myself unsympathised with,
wished to tear up the trees,
spread havoc and destruction
around me, and then to have sat
down and enjoyed the ruin.that
could not endure; I became
fatigued with excess of bodily
exertion and sank on the damp
grass in the sick impotence of
despair.that existed who would
pity or assist me; and should I
feel kindness towards my
enemies?everlasting war against
the species, and more than all,
against him who had
formed me and sent me forth to
this insupportable misery.
men and knew that it was
impossible to return to my
retreat during that day.
underwood, determining to devote
the ensuing hours to reflection
on my situation.
of day restored me to some
degree of tranquillity; and when
I considered what
had passed at the cottage, I
could not help believing that I
had been too hasty in my
conclusions.
had interested the father in my
behalf, and I was a fool in
having exposed my person to the
horror of his children.
Lacey to me, and by degrees to
have
discovered myself to the rest of
his family, when they should
have been prepared for my
approach.irretrievable, and
after much consideration I
resolved to return to the
cottage, seek the old man, and
by my representations win him to
my party.afternoon I sank into a
profound sleep; but the fever of
my blood did not allow me to be
visited by peaceful dreams.
was for ever acting before my
eyes; the females were flying
and the enraged Felix tearing me
from his father's feet.
was already night, I crept forth
from my
hiding-place, and went in search
of food.
directed my steps towards the
well-known path that conducted
to the cottage.
silent expectation of the
accustomed hour when the family
arose.
in the heavens, but the
cottagers did not appear.
The inside of the cottage was
dark, and I heard no motion; I
cannot describe the agony of
this suspense.
but pausing near the cottage,
they entered into conversation,
using violent
gesticulations; but I did not
understand what they said, as
they spoke the language of the
country, which differed from
that of my protectors.with
another man; I was surprised, as
I knew that he had not quitted
the cottage that morning, and
waited anxiously to discover
from his discourse the meaning
of these unusual appearances.
to him, ‘that you will be
obliged to pay three months'
rent and to lose the produce of
your garden?
advantage, and I beg therefore
that you will take some days to
consider of your determination.
Felix; ‘we can never again
inhabit your cottage.
greatest danger, owing to the
dreadful circumstance that I
have related.
He and his companion entered the
For the first time the feelings
of revenge and hatred filled my
bosom, and I did not strive to
control them, but
allowing myself to be borne away
by the stream, I bent my mind
towards injury and death.
mild voice of De Lacey, the
gentle eyes of Agatha, and the
exquisite beauty of the Arabian,
these thoughts vanished and
a gush of tears somewhat soothed
me.
had spurned and deserted me,
anger returned, a rage of anger,
and unable to
injure anything human, I turned
my fury towards inanimate
objects.
of combustibles around the
cottage, and
after having destroyed every
vestige of cultivation in the
garden, I waited with forced
impatience until the moon had
sunk to commence my operations.
arose from the woods and quickly
dispersed the clouds that had
loitered
in the heavens; the blast tore
along like a mighty avalanche
and produced a kind of insanity
in my spirits that burst all
bounds of reason and reflection.
danced with fury around the
devoted cottage, my eyes still
fixed on the
western horizon, the edge of
which the moon nearly touched.
and I waved my brand; it sank,
and with a loud scream I fired
the straw, and heath, and
bushes, which I had collected.
cottage was quickly enveloped by
the flames, which clung to it
and licked it
with their forked and destroying
tongues.
assistance could save any part
of the habitation, I quitted the
scene and sought for refuge in
the woods.
whither should I bend my steps?
my misfortunes; but to me, hated
and
despised, every country must be
equally horrible.
were my father, my creator; and
to whom could I apply with more
fitness than to him who had
given me life?
bestowed upon Safie, geography
had not been omitted; I had
learned from these the relative
situations of the different
countries of the earth.
your native town, and towards
this place I resolved to
proceed.
southwesterly direction to reach
my destination, but the sun was
my only guide.
that I was to pass through, nor
could I
ask information from a single
human being; but I did not
despair.
although towards you I felt no
sentiment but that of hatred.
passions and then cast me abroad
an
object for the scorn and horror
of mankind.
pity and redress, and from you I
determined to seek that justice
which I vainly attempted to gain
from any other being that wore
the human form.
the district where I had so long
resided.
encountering the visage of a
human being.
became heatless; rain and snow
poured around me; mighty rivers
were frozen;
the surface of the earth was
hard and chill, and bare, and I
found no shelter.
all within me was turned to gall
and bitterness.
habitation, the more deeply did
I feel
the spirit of revenge enkindled
in my heart.
me, and I possessed a map of the
country; but I often wandered
wide from my path.
respite; no incident occurred
from which my rage and misery
could not extract its
food; but a circumstance that
happened when I arrived on the
confines of Switzerland, when
the sun had recovered
its warmth and the earth again
began to look green, confirmed
in an especial manner the
bitterness and horror of my
feelings.
travelled only when I was
secured by night from the view
of man.
path lay through a deep wood, I
ventured to continue my journey
after the sun had
risen; the day, which was one of
the first of spring, cheered
even me by the loveliness of its
sunshine and the balminess of
the air.
pleasure, that had long appeared
dead, revive within me.
sensations, I allowed myself to
be borne away by them, and
forgetting my solitude and
deformity, dared to be happy.
I even raised my humid eyes with
thankfulness towards the blessed
sun, which bestowed such joy
upon me.
the wood, until I came to its
boundary,
which was skirted by a deep and
rapid river, into which many of
the trees bent
their branches, now budding with
the fresh spring.
path to pursue, when I heard the
sound
of voices, that induced me to
conceal myself under the shade
of a cypress.
came running towards the spot
where I was concealed, laughing,
as if she ran from someone in
sport.
precipitous sides of the river,
when suddenly her foot slipped,
and she fell into the rapid
stream.
extreme labour, from the force
of the current, saved her and
dragged her to shore.
every means in my power to
restore animation, when I was
suddenly interrupted by the
approach of a rustic,
who was probably the person from
whom she had playfully fled.
tearing the girl from my arms,
hastened towards the deeper
parts of the wood.
but when the man saw me draw
near, he aimed a gun, which he
carried, at my body and fired.
with increased swiftness,
escaped into
“This was then the reward of my
benevolence!
destruction, and as a recompense
I now writhed under the
miserable pain of a wound which
shattered the flesh and bone.
which I had entertained but a
few
moments before gave place to
hellish rage and gnashing of
teeth.
hatred and vengeance to all
mankind.
my pulses paused, and I fainted.
in the woods, endeavouring to
cure the wound which I had
received.
knew not whether it had remained
there
or passed through; at any rate I
had no means of extracting it.
the oppressive sense of the
injustice and ingratitude of
their infliction.
and deadly revenge, such as
would alone compensate for the
outrages and anguish I had
endured.
I continued my journey.
be alleviated by the bright sun
or gentle breezes of spring; all
joy was but a mockery which
insulted my desolate state and
made me feel more painfully that
I was not made for the enjoyment
of pleasure.
and in two months from this time
I reached the environs of
Geneva.
retired to a hiding-place among
the fields that surround it to
meditate in what manner I should
apply to you.
and far too unhappy to enjoy the
gentle breezes of evening or the
prospect of
the sun setting behind the
stupendous mountains of Jura.
me from the pain of reflection,
which was disturbed by the
approach of a beautiful child,
who came running into
the recess I had chosen, with
all the sportiveness of infancy.
seized me that this little
creature was unprejudiced and
had lived too short a
time to have imbibed a horror of
deformity.
educate him as my companion and
friend, I should not be so
desolate in this peopled earth.
boy as he passed and drew him
towards me.
his hands before his eyes and
uttered a shrill scream; I drew
his hand forcibly from his face
and said, ‘Child, what is the
meaning of this?
listen to me.
'
papa.'“‘Boy, you will never see
your father
again; you must come
with me.'“‘Hideous monster!
towards whom I have sworn
eternal revenge; you shall be my
first victim.
“The child still struggled and
loaded me with epithets which
carried despair to my heart; I
grasped his throat to silence
him, and in a moment he lay dead
at my feet.
swelled with exultation
and hellish triumph; clapping my
hands, I exclaimed, ‘I too can
create desolation; my enemy is
not invulnerable; this death
will carry despair to him, and a
thousand other miseries shall
torment and destroy him.
“As I fixed my eyes on the
child, I saw something
glittering on his breast.
softened and attracted me.
delight on her dark eyes,
fringed by deep lashes, and her
lovely lips; but presently my
rage returned; I remembered that
I was for ever deprived
of the delights that such
beautiful creatures could bestow
and that she whose resemblance I
contemplated would, in regarding
me, have changed that air of
divine benignity to one
expressive of
disgust and affright.transported
me with rage?instead of venting
my sensations in exclamations
and agony, I did not rush among
mankind and perish in the
attempt to destroy them.
feelings, I left the spot where
I had
committed the murder, and
seeking a more secluded
hiding-place, I entered a barn
which had appeared to me to be
empty.was young, not indeed so
beautiful as her whose portrait
I held, but of an agreeable
aspect and blooming in the
loveliness of youth and health.
joy-imparting smiles are
bestowed on all but me.
‘Awake, fairest, thy lover is
near—he who would give his life
but to obtain one look of
affection from thine eyes;
my beloved, awake!
'
and curse me, and denounce the
murderer?darkened eyes opened
and she beheld me.fiend within
me—not I, but she, shall suffer;
the murder I have committed
because I am for ever robbed of
all that she could give me, she
shall atone.
sanguinary laws of man, I had
learned now to work mischief.
whom I can live in the
interchange of those sympathies
necessary for my being.of you as
a right which you must not
refuse to concede.
”
anew in me the anger that had
died away
while he
narrated his peaceful life among
the cottagers, and as he said
this I could no longer suppress
the rage that burned within me.
torture shall ever extort a
consent from me.men, but you
shall never make me base in my
own eyes.
whose joint wickedness might
desolate the world.
me, but I will never consent.
“You are in the wrong,” replied
the fiend; “and instead of
threatening, I am content to
reason with you.
pieces and triumph; remember
that, and tell me why I should
pity man more than he pities me?
could precipitate me into one of
those ice-rifts and destroy my
frame, the work of your own
hands.
of kindness, and instead of
injury I would bestow every
benefit upon him with
tears of gratitude at his
acceptance.
are insurmountable barriers to
our union.
inspire love, I will cause fear,
and chiefly towards you my
arch-enemy,
because my creator, do I swear
inextinguishable hatred.
destruction, nor finish until I
desolate your heart, so that you
shall curse the hour of your
birth.
A fiendish rage animated him as
he said
this; his face was
wrinkled into contortions too
horrible for human eyes to
behold; but presently
he calmed himself and proceeded—
“I intended to reason.
you do not reflect that you are
the cause of its excess.
benevolence towards me, I should
return them a hundred and a
hundredfold; for that one
creature's sake I would make
peace with the whole kind!
moderate; I demand a creature of
another
sex, but as hideous as myself;
the gratification is small, but
it is all that I can receive,
and it shall content me.
off from all the world; but on
that account we shall be more
attached to one another.
will be harmless and free from
the misery I now feel.
gratitude towards you for one
benefit!
of some existing thing; do not
deny me my request!
possible consequences of my
consent, but I felt that there
was some justice in his
argument.
expressed proved him to be a
creature of fine sensations, and
did I not as his maker owe him
all the portion of
happiness that it was in my
power to bestow?
continued, “If you consent,
neither you
nor any other human being shall
ever see us again; I will go to
the vast wilds of South America.
destroy the lamb and the kid to
glut my appetite; acorns and
berries afford me sufficient
nourishment.
as myself and will be content
with the same fare.
the sun will shine on us as on
man and
The picture I present to you is
peaceful and human, and you must
feel that you could deny it only
in the wantonness of power and
cruelty.
now see compassion in your eyes;
let me seize the favourable
moment and persuade
you to promise what I so
ardently desire.
“You propose,” replied I, “to
fly from the habitations of man,
to dwell in those wilds where
the beasts of the field will be
your only companions.
sympathy of man, persevere in
this exile?
kindness, and you will meet with
their
detestation; your evil passions
will be renewed, and you will
then have a companion to aid you
in the task of destruction.
point, for I cannot consent.“How
inconstant are your feelings!
representations, and why do you
again harden yourself to my
complaints?
inhabit, and by you that made
me, that with the companion you
bestow, I will quit the
neighbourhood of man and dwell,
as it may chance, in the most
savage of places.
my dying moments I shall not
curse my maker.
His words had a strange effect
upon me.
a wish to console him, but when
I looked upon him, when I saw
the filthy mass
that moved and talked, my heart
sickened and my feelings were
altered to those of horror and
hatred.
thought that as I could not
sympathise with him, I had no
right to withhold
from him the small portion of
happiness which was yet in my
power to bestow.
but have you not already shown a
degree of malice that should
reasonably make me distrust you?
increase your triumph
by affording a wider scope for
your revenge?
hatred and vice must be my
portion; the love of another
will destroy the cause of my
crimes, and I shall become a
thing of whose existence
everyone will be ignorant.
forced solitude that I abhor,
and my
virtues will necessarily
arise when I live in communion
with an equal.
sensitive being and become
linked to the chain of existence
and events from which I am now
excluded.
”
had related and the various
arguments which he had employed.
which he had displayed on the
opening of his existence and the
subsequent blight of all kindly
feeling by the loathing and
scorn which his protectors had
manifested towards him.in my
calculations; a creature who
could exist in the ice-caves of
the glaciers and hide himself
from pursuit among the
ridges of inaccessible
precipices was a being
possessing faculties it would be
vain to cope with.
concluded that the justice due
both to him and my fellow
creatures demanded of me that I
should comply with his request.
“I consent to your demand, on
your solemn oath to quit Europe
for ever, and every other place
in the neighbourhood of man, as
soon as I shall deliver into
your hands a female who will
accompany you in your exile.“I
swear,” he cried, “by the sun,
and by
the blue sky of
heaven, and by the fire of love
that burns my heart, that if you
grant my prayer, while they
exist you shall never behold me
again.
labours; I shall watch their
progress with unutterable
anxiety; and fear not but that
when you are ready I shall
appear.”
fearful, perhaps, of any change
in my sentiments.
greater speed than the flight of
an eagle, and quickly lost among
the undulations of the sea of
ice.
and the sun was upon the verge
of the horizon when he departed.
descent towards the valley, as I
should soon be encompassed in
darkness; but my heart was
heavy, and my steps slow.
paths of the mountain and fixing
my feet firmly as I advanced
perplexed me,
occupied as I was by the
emotions which the occurrences
of the day had produced.
the halfway resting-place and
seated myself beside the
fountain.
clouds passed from over them;
the dark pines rose before me,
and every here and
there a broken tree lay on the
ground; it was a scene of
wonderful solemnity and stirred
strange thoughts within me.
in agony, I exclaimed, “Oh!
about to mock me; if ye really
pity me, crush sensation and
memory; let me
become as nought; but if not,
depart, depart, and leave me in
darkness.
These were wild and miserable
thoughts, but I cannot describe
to you how the eternal twinkling
of the stars weighed upon me and
how I listened to every
blast of wind as if it were a
dull ugly siroc on its way to
consume me.
village of Chamounix; I took no
rest, but returned immediately
to Geneva.
expression to my sensations—they
weighed
on me with a mountain's weight
and their excess destroyed my
agony beneath them.
house, presented myself to the
family.intense alarm, but I
answered no question, scarcely
did I speak.
ban—as if I had no right to
claim their sympathies—as if
never more might I enjoy
companionship with them.
adoration; and to save them, I
resolved to dedicate myself to
my most abhorred task.
every other circumstance of
existence
pass before me like a dream, and
that thought only had to me the
reality of life.
me and I saw animals inflecting
torture upon me?
By degrees, however, these
feelings became calmed.
I entered again into the
everyday scene of life, if not
with interest, at least
Day after day, week after week,
passed
away on my return to Geneva; and
I could not collect the courage
to recommence my work.
disappointed fiend, yet I was
unable to overcome my repugnance
to the task which was enjoined
me.
female without again devoting
several months to profound study
and laborious disquisition.
been made by an English
philosopher, the
knowledge of which was material
to my success, and I sometimes
thought of obtaining my father's
consent to visit England for
this purpose; but I clung to
every pretence of delay and
shrank from taking the first
step in an undertaking whose
immediate necessity began to
appear less absolute to me.
my health, which had hitherto
declined, was now much restored;
and my spirits,
when unchecked by the memory of
my unhappy promise, rose
proportionably.
pleasure, and he turned his
thoughts towards the best method
of eradicating the remains of my
melancholy, which every now and
then would return by fits,
and with a devouring blackness
overcast the approaching
sunshine.
in a little boat, watching the
clouds and listening to the
rippling of the waves, silent
and listless.
failed to restore me to some
degree of composure, and on my
return I met the salutations of
my friends with a readier smile
and a more cheerful heart.
these rambles that my father,
calling me
aside, thus addressed me, “I am
happy to remark, my dear son,
that you have resumed your
former pleasures and seem to be
returning to yourself.
as to the cause of this, but
yesterday an idea struck me, and
if it is well founded, I conjure
you to avow it.
only useless, but draw down
treble misery on us all.
I trembled violently at his
exordium, and my father
continued— “I confess, my son,
that I have always looked
forward
to your marriage with our dear
Elizabeth as the tie of our
domestic comfort and the stay of
my declining years.
your earliest infancy; you
studied together, and appeared,
in dispositions and tastes,
entirely suited to one another.
that what I conceived to be the
best assistants to my plan may
have entirely destroyed it.
sister, without any wish that
she might become your wife.you
may love; and considering
yourself as bound in honour to
Elizabeth, this struggle may
occasion the poignant misery
which you appear to feel.“My
dear father, reassure yourself.
Elizabeth does, my warmest
admiration and affection.
entirely bound up in the
expectation of our union.“The
expression of your sentiments of
this subject, my dear Victor,
gives me more pleasure than I
have for some time experienced.
happy, however present events
may cast a gloom over us.
have taken so strong a hold of
your mind that I wish to
dissipate.
to an immediate solemnisation of
the marriage.
events have drawn us from that
everyday
tranquillity befitting my years
and infirmities.
possessed as you are of a
competent fortune, that an early
marriage would at
all interfere with any future
plans of honour and utility that
you may have formed.
dictate happiness to you or that
a delay on your part would cause
me any serious uneasiness.answer
me, I conjure you, with
confidence and sincerity.I
listened to my father in silence
and remained for some time
incapable of offering any reply.
multitude of thoughts and
endeavoured to arrive at some
conclusion.
with my Elizabeth was one of
horror and dismay.
had not yet fulfilled and dared
not break, or if I did, what
manifold miseries might not
impend over me and my devoted
family!
deadly weight yet hanging round
my neck and bowing me to the
ground?
the monster depart with his mate
before I allowed myself to enjoy
the delight of a union from
which I expected peace.
upon me of either journeying to
England
or entering into a long
correspondence
with those philosophers of that
country whose knowledge and
discoveries were of
indispensable use to me in my
present undertaking.
desired intelligence was
dilatory and unsatisfactory;
besides, I had an insurmountable
aversion to the idea of
engaging myself in my loathsome
task in my father's house while
in habits of familiar
intercourse with those I loved.
accidents might occur, the
slightest of which would
disclose a tale to thrill all
connected with me with horror.
lose all self-command, all
capacity of hiding the harrowing
sensations that would possess me
during the progress of my
unearthly occupation.achieved,
and I might be restored to my
family in peace and happiness.to
destroy him and put an end to my
slavery for ever.but concealing
the true reasons of this
request, I clothed my desires
under a
guise which excited no
suspicion, while I urged my
desire with an earnestness that
easily induced my father to
comply.
melancholy that resembled
madness in its
intensity and effects, he was
glad to
find that I was capable
of taking pleasure in the idea
of such a journey, and he hoped
that change of scene and varied
amusement would, before my
return, have restored me
entirely to myself.my own
choice; a few months, or at most
a year, was the period
contemplated.
me, he had, in concert with
Elizabeth, This interfered with
the solitude I coveted for the
prosecution of my task;
yet at the commencement of my
journey the presence of my
friend could in no way be an
impediment, and truly I rejoiced
that thus I should be saved many
hours of lonely, maddening
reflection.
force his abhorred presence on
me to its progress?it was
understood that my union with
Elizabeth should take place
immediately on my return.
promised myself from my detested
toils—one consolation for my
unparalleled sufferings; it was
the prospect of that day when,
enfranchised from my miserable
slavery, I might claim Elizabeth
and forget the past in my union
with her.but one feeling haunted
me which filled me with fear and
agitation.
friends unconscious of the
existence of their enemy and
unprotected from his attacks,
exasperated as he might be by my
departure.
wherever I might go, and would
he not accompany me to England?
itself, but soothing inasmuch as
it supposed the safety of my
friends.But through the whole
period during which I was the
slave of my creature I allowed
myself to
be governed by the impulses of
the
moment; and my present
sensations strongly intimated
that the fiend would follow me
and exempt my family from the
danger of his machinations.
that I again quitted
my native country.and Elizabeth
therefore acquiesced, but she
was filled with disquiet at the
idea of my suffering, away from
her, the inroads of misery and
grief.
a companion in Clerval—and yet a
man is blind to a thousand
minute circumstances which call
forth a woman's sedulous
attention.a thousand conflicting
emotions rendered her mute as
she bade me a tearful, silent
farewell.was to convey me away,
hardly knowing whither I was
going, and careless of what was
passing around.
bitter anguish that I reflected
on it, to order that my chemical
instruments should be packed to
go with me.
passed through many beautiful
and majestic scenes, but my eyes
were fixed and unobserving.
travels and the work which was
to occupy me whilst they
endured.
indolence, during which I
traversed many leagues, I
arrived at Strasburgh, where
I
waited two days for Clerval.
when he saw the beauties of the
setting sun, and more happy when
he beheld it
rise and
recommence a new day.colours of
the landscape and the
appearances of the sky.
wherefore are you desponding and
sorrowful!” In truth, I was
occupied by gloomy
thoughts and
neither saw the descent of the
evening star nor the golden
sunrise reflected in the Rhine.
more amused with the journal of
Clerval, who observed the
scenery with an eye of feeling
and delight, than in I, a
miserable wretch, haunted by a
curse that shut up every avenue
to enjoyment.boat from
Strasburgh to Rotterdam, whence
we might take shipping for
London.willowy islands and saw
several beautiful towns.fifth
from our departure from
Strasburgh, arrived at Mainz.
becomes much more picturesque.
between hills, not high, but
steep, and of beautiful forms.
standing on the edges of
precipices, surrounded by black
woods, high and inaccessible.
presents a singularly variegated
landscape.
ruined castles overlooking
tremendous precipices, with the
dark Rhine rushing beneath; and
on the sudden turn of a
promontory,
flourishing vineyards with green
sloping banks and a meandering
river and populous towns occupy
the scene.
Even I, depressed in mind, and
my spirits continually agitated
by gloomy feelings, even I was
pleased.
and as I gazed on the cloudless
blue sky, I seemed to drink in a
tranquillity to which I had long
been a stranger.
to Fairy-land and
enjoyed a happiness seldom
tasted by man.
most beautiful scenes of my own
country; I have visited the
lakes of
Lucerne and Uri, where the snowy
mountains descend almost
perpendicularly to the water,
casting black and impenetrable
shades, which would cause a
gloomy and mournful appearance
were it not for the most verdant
islands that relieve the eye by
their gay appearance; I have
seen this
lake agitated by a tempest, when
the wind tore up whirlwinds of
water and
gave you an idea of what the
water-spout must be on the
great ocean; and the waves dash
with fury the base of the
mountain, where the priest and
his mistress were overwhelmed by
an avalanche and where their
dying voices are still said to
be heard amid the pauses of the
nightly wind; I have seen the
mountains of La Valais, and the
Pays de Vaud; but this country,
Victor, pleases me more than
all
those wonders.
more majestic and strange, but
there is a charm in the banks of
this divine river that I never
before saw equalled.precipice;
and that also on the island,
almost concealed amongst the
foliage of those lovely trees;
and now that group of labourers
coming from among their vines;
and that village half hid in the
recess of the mountain.
guards this place has a soul
more in harmony with man than
those who pile the glacier or
retire to the inaccessible peaks
of the mountains of our own
country.
words and to dwell on the praise
of which you are so eminently
deserving.
” His wild and enthusiastic
imagination was chastened by the
sensibility of his heart.
affections, and his friendship
was of that devoted and wondrous
nature that the worldly-minded
teach us to look for only in the
imagination.
sufficient to satisfy his eager
mind.
which others regard only with
admiration, he loved with
ardour:  — ——The sounding
cataract Haunted him like
a passion:  The
tall rock,
The mountain, and the deep and
gloomy wood, Their colours and
their forms,
were then to him
An appetite; a feeling, and a
love, That had no need of a
remoter charm, By thought
supplied, or any interest
Unborrow'd from the eye.
imaginations fanciful and
magnificent, which formed a
world, whose existence depended
on the life of its creator;—has
this mind perished?
divinely wrought, and beaming
with beauty, has decayed, but
your spirit
still visits and consoles your
unhappy friend.
ineffectual words are but a
slight tribute to the unexampled
worth of
Henry, but they soothe my heart,
overflowing with the anguish
which his remembrance creates.
plains of Holland; and we
resolved to post the remainder
of our way, for the
wind was contrary and the stream
of the river was too gentle to
aid us.
arising from beautiful scenery,
but we arrived in a few days at
Rotterdam, whence we proceeded
by sea to England.
latter days of December, that I
first saw the white cliffs of
Britain.
scene; they were flat but
fertile, and
almost every town was marked by
the remembrance of some story.
Spanish Armada, Gravesend,
Woolwich, and
Greenwich—places which I had
heard of even in my country.
Paul's towering above all, and
the Tower famed in English
history.
London was our present point of
rest; we determined to remain
several months in this wonderful
and celebrated city.
men of genius and talent who
flourished at this time, but
this was with me a secondary
object; I was
principally occupied with the
means of obtaining the
information necessary for the
completion of my promise and
quickly availed myself of the
letters of introduction that I
had
brought with me, addressed to
the most distinguished natural
philosophers.
my days of study and happiness,
it would
have afforded me inexpressible
pleasure.
existence, and I only visited
these people for the sake of the
information they might give me
on the subject in
which my interest was so
terribly profound.
I could fill my mind with the
sights of heaven and earth; the
voice of Henry soothed me, and I
could thus cheat myself into a
transitory peace.
brought back despair to my
heart.
between me and my fellow men;
this barrier was sealed with the
blood of William and Justine,
and to reflect on the events
connected with those names
filled my soul with anguish.
former self; he was inquisitive
and anxious to gain experience
and instruction.
observed was to him an
inexhaustible source of
instruction and amusement.
belief that he had in his
knowledge of its various
languages, and in the views
he had taken of its society, the
means of materially assisting
the progress of European
colonization and trade.I tried
to conceal this as much as
possible, that I might not debar
him from the pleasures natural
to one who was entering on a new
scene of life, I often refused
to accompany him, alleging
another engagement, that I might
remain alone.
materials necessary for my new
creation, and this was to me
like the torture of
single drops of water
continually falling on the head.
was an extreme anguish, and
every word that I spoke in
allusion to it caused my
lips to quiver, and my heart to
palpitate.
received a letter from a person
in Scotland who had formerly
been our visitor at Geneva.
country and asked us if those
were not
sufficient allurements to induce
us to prolong our journey as far
north as Perth, where he
resided.
invitation, and I, although I
abhorred
society, wished to view again
mountains and streams and all
the wondrous works with which
Nature adorns her chosen
dwelling-places.
beginning of October, and it was
now February.
our journey towards the north at
the expiration of another month.
follow the great road to
Edinburgh, but
to visit Windsor, Oxford,
Matlock, and the Cumberland
lakes, resolving to arrive at
the completion of this tour
about the end of July.the
materials I had collected,
resolving to finish my labours
in some obscure nook in the
northern highlands of Scotland.
and remained a few days at
Windsor, rambling in its
beautiful forest.
mountaineers; the majestic oaks,
the quantity of game, and the
herds of stately deer were all
novelties to us.
filled with the remembrance of
the events that had been
transacted there more than a
century and a half before. Had
collected his forces.after the
whole nation had forsaken his
cause to join the standard of
Parliament and liberty.his
companions, the amiable
Falkland, the insolent Goring,
his queen, and son, gave a
peculiar interest to every part
of the city which they might be
supposed to have inhabited.
dwelling here, and we delighted
to trace its footsteps.imaginary
gratification, the appearance of
the city had yet in itself
sufficient beauty to obtain our
admiration.picturesque; the
streets are almost magnificent;
and the
lovely Isis, which flows beside
it through meadows of exquisite
verdure, is spread forth into a
placid expanse of waters, which
reflects its majestic assemblage
of towers, and spires, and
domes, embosomed among aged
trees.
enjoyment was embittered both by
the memory of the past and the
anticipation of the future.
never visited my mind, and if I
was ever
overcome byennui, the sight of
what is beautiful in nature or
the study of what is excellent
and sublime in the productions
of man could always interest my
heart and communicate elasticity
to my spirits.
entered my soul; and I felt then
that I should survive to exhibit
what I shall
soon cease to be—a miserable
spectacle of wrecked humanity,
pitiable to others and
intolerable to myself.
Oxford, rambling among its
environs and endeavouring to
identify every spot which might
relate to the most animating
epoch of English history.
often prolonged by the
successive objects that
presented themselves.
Hampden and the field on which
that patriot fell.
its debasing and miserable fears
to contemplate the divine ideas
of liberty
and self-sacrifice of which
these sights were the monuments
and the remembrancers.
chains and look around me with a
free and lofty spirit, but the
iron had eaten
into my flesh, and I sank again,
trembling and hopeless, into my
miserable self.
proceeded to Matlock, which was
our next place of rest.
this village resembled, to a
greater degree, the scenery of
Switzerland; but everything is
on a lower scale, and the
green hills want the crown of
distant white Alps which always
attend on the piny mountains of
my native country.
little cabinets of natural
history, where the curiosities
are disposed in the same manner
as in the collections at Servox
and Chamounix.
pronounced by Henry, and I
hastened to quit Matlock, with
which that terrible
scene was thus associated.
northwards, we passed two months
in Cumberland and Westmorland.
lingered on the northern sides
of the mountains, the lakes, and
the dashing of
the rocky streams were all
familiar and dear sights to me.
who almost contrived to cheat me
into happiness.
proportionably greater than
mine; his mind expanded in the
company of men of talent, and he
found in his own nature
greater capacities and resources
than he could have imagined
himself to have possessed while
he associated with his
inferiors.
me; “and among these mountains I
should scarcely
But he found that a traveller's
life is one that includes much
pain amidst its enjoyments.
stretch; and when he begins to
sink into repose, he finds
himself obliged to quit
that on which he rests in
pleasure for something new,
which again engages his
attention, and which also he
forsakes for other novelties.
lakes of Cumberland and
Westmorland and
conceived an affection for some
of the inhabitants when the
period of our appointment with
our Scotch friend approached,
and we left them to travel on.
time, and I feared the effects
of the daemon's disappointment.
wreak his vengeance on my
relatives.
at every moment from which I
might otherwise have snatched
repose and peace.
impatience; if they were delayed
I was miserable and overcome by
a thousand
fears; and when they arrived and
I saw the superscription of
Elizabeth or my father, I hardly
dared to read and ascertain my
fate.
followed me and might expedite
my remissness by murdering my
companion.
would not quit Henry for a
moment, but followed him as his
shadow, to protect him from the
fancied rage of his destroyer.
crime, the consciousness of
which haunted me.
down a horrible curse upon my
head, as mortal as that of
crime.
and mind; and yet that city
might have interested the most
unfortunate being.
Oxford, for the antiquity of the
latter city was more pleasing to
him.
new town of Edinburgh, its
romantic castle and its
environs, the most delightful in
the world, Arthur's Seat, St.
Bernard's Well, and the Pentland
Hills, compensated him for the
change and filled him with
cheerfulness and admiration.
Andrew's, and along the banks of
the But I was in no mood to
laugh and talk with strangers or
enter into their feelings or
plans with the good humour
expected from a guest; and
accordingly I I may be absent a
month or two; but do not
interfere with my motions, I
entreat you; leave me to peace
and solitude for a short time;
and when I return, I hope it
will be with a lighter heart,
more congenial to your own
temper.
Henry wished to dissuade me, but
seeing me bent on this plan,
ceased to remonstrate.
“in your solitary rambles, than
with these Scotch people, whom I
do not know;
that I may again feel myself
somewhat at home, which I cannot
do in your absence.
Having parted from my friend, I
determined to visit some remote
spot of Scotland and finish my
work in solitude.
followed me and would discover
himself to me when I should have
finished, that he might receive
his companion.
northern highlands and fixed on
one of the remotest of the
Orkneys as the scene of my
labours.
being hardly more than a rock
whose high sides were
continually beaten upon by the
waves.
pasture for a few miserable
cows, and oatmeal for its
inhabitants, which consisted of
five persons, whose gaunt
and scraggy limbs gave tokens of
their miserable fare.indulged in
such luxuries, and even fresh
water, was to be procured from
the mainland, which was about
five miles distant.
three miserable huts, and one of
these was vacant when I arrived.
exhibited all the squalidness of
the most miserable penury.
were unplastered, and the door
was off its hinges.
some furniture, and took
possession, an incident which
would doubtless have occasioned
some surprise had not all the
senses of the cottagers been
benumbed by want and squalid
poverty.
unmolested, hardly thanked for
the pittance of food and clothes
which I gave, so much does
suffering blunt even the
coarsest sensations of men.
to labour; but in the evening,
when the
weather permitted, I walked on
the stony beach of the sea to
listen to the waves as they
roared and dashed at my feet.
different from this desolate and
appalling landscape.
its cottages are scattered
thickly in the plains.
gentle sky, and when troubled by
the winds, their tumult is but
as the play
of a lively infant when compared
to the roarings of the giant
ocean.
occupations when I first
arrived, but as
I proceeded in my labour, it
became every day more horrible
and irksome to me.
to enter my laboratory for
several days, and at other times
I toiled day and night in order
to complete my work.enthusiastic
frenzy had blinded me to the
horror of my employment; my mind
was intently fixed on the
consummation of my
labour, and my eyes were shut to
the horror of my proceedings.
my heart often sickened at the
work of my hands.
detestable occupation, immersed
in a solitude where nothing
could for an
instant call my attention from
the actual scene in which I was
engaged, my spirits became
unequal; I grew restless and
nervous.
the ground, fearing to raise
them lest they should encounter
the object which I so much
dreaded to behold.
fellow creatures lest when alone
he should come to claim his
companion.
labour was already considerably
advanced.
with a tremulous and eager hope,
which I dared not trust myself
to question but which was
intermixed with obscure
forebodings of evil that made my
heart sicken in my bosom.
sun had set, and the moon was
just rising from the sea; I had
not sufficient light for my
employment, and
I remained idle, in a pause of
consideration of whether I
should leave my labour for the
night or hasten its conclusion
by an unremitting attention to
it.
occurred to me which led me to
consider the effects of what I
was now doing.
the same manner and had created
a fiend
whose unparalleled barbarity had
desolated my heart and filled it
for ever with the bitterest
remorse.
of whose dispositions I was
alike ignorant; she might become
ten thousand
times more malignant than her
mate and delight, for its own
sake, in murder and
wretchedness.
of man and hide himself in
deserts, but
she had not; and she, who in all
probability was to become a
thinking and reasoning animal,
might refuse to comply
with a compact made before her
creation.
creature who already lived
loathed his own deformity, and
might he not conceive a greater
abhorrence for it when it came
before his eyes in the female
form?
him to the superior beauty of
man; she might quit him, and he
be again alone,
exasperated by the fresh
provocation of
Even if they were to leave
Europe and inhabit the deserts
of the new world,
yet one of the first results of
those sympathies for which the
daemon thirsted would be
children, and a race of devils
would be propagated upon the
earth who might make the very
existence of the species of man
a condition precarious and full
of terror.
inflict this curse upon
everlasting generations?
of the being I had created; I
had been
struck senseless by his fiendish
threats; but now, for the first
time, the wickedness of my
promise burst upon
me; I shuddered to think that
future ages might curse me as
their pest, whose selfishness
had not hesitated to buy its
own peace at the price, perhaps,
of the existence of the whole
human race.
me, when, on looking up, I saw
by the light of the moon the
daemon at the casement.
gazed on me, where I sat
fulfilling the task which he had
allotted to me.
he had loitered in forests, hid
himself
in caves, or taken refuge in
wide and desert heaths; and he
now came to mark my progress and
claim the fulfilment of my
promise.
on my promise of creating
another like to him, and
trembling with passion, tore to
pieces the thing on which I was
engaged.on whose future
existence he depended for
happiness, and with a howl of
devilish despair and revenge,
withdrew.
made a solemn vow in my own
heart never
to resume my labours; and then,
with
I was alone; none were near me
to dissipate the gloom and
relieve me from the sickening
oppression of the most terrible
reveries.
near my window gazing on the
sea; it was
almost motionless, for the winds
were hushed, and all nature
reposed under the eye of the
quiet moon.
water, and now and then the
gentle breeze wafted the sound
of voices as the fishermen
called to one another.
hardly conscious of its extreme
profundity, until my ear was
suddenly arrested by the
paddling of oars near the shore,
and a person landed close to my
house.
creaking of my door, as if some
one endeavoured to open it
softly.
presentiment of who it was and
wished to rouse one of the
peasants who dwelt in a
cottage not far from mine; but I
was overcome by the sensation of
helplessness, so often felt in
frightful dreams, when you in
vain endeavour to fly from an
impending danger, and was rooted
to the spot.
footsteps along the passage; the
door opened, and the wretch whom
I dreaded appeared.
said in a smothered voice, “You
have destroyed the work which
you began; what is it that you
intend?
Switzerland with you; I crept
along the shores of the Rhine,
among its willow
islands and over the summits of
its hills.
of England and among the deserts
of Scotland.
and cold, and hunger; do you
dare destroy my hopes?
create another like yourself,
equal in deformity and
wickedness.
“Slave, I before reasoned with
you, but
you have proved yourself
unworthy of my condescension.
yourself miserable, but I can
make you so wretched that the
light of day will be hateful to
you.
“The hour of my irresolution is
past, and the period of your
power is arrived.
act of wickedness; but they
confirm me
in a determination of not
creating you a companion in
vice.
the earth a daemon whose delight
is in
death and wretchedness?
>> We will now take another 20
minute break. Thank you.
The monster saw my determination
in my face and gnashed his teeth
in the impotence of anger.
wife for his bosom, and each
beast have his mate, and I be
alone?
were requited by detestation and
scorn.
misery, and soon the bolt will
fall which must ravish from you
your happiness for ever.
the intensity of my
wretchedness?
revenge remains—revenge,
henceforth dearer than light or
food!
tormentor, shall curse the sun
that
gazes on your misery.
snake, that I may sting with its
venom.
“Devil, cease; and do not poison
the air with these sounds of
malice.
and I am no coward to bend
beneath words.
I started forward and exclaimed,
“Villain!
sure that you are yourself safe.
I would have seized him, but he
eluded me and quitted the house
with precipitation.
which shot across the waters
with an arrowy swiftness and was
soon lost amidst the waves.
murderer of my peace and
precipitate him into the ocean.
and perturbed, while my
imagination conjured up a
thousand images to torment and
sting me.
with him in mortal strife?
he had directed his course
towards the mainland.
next victim sacrificed to his
insatiate revenge.
words—“I will be with you on
your wedding-night.” That, then,
was the period fixed for the
fulfilment of my destiny.
satisfy and extinguish his
malice.
yet when I thought of my beloved
Elizabeth, of her tears and
endless sorrow, when she should
find her lover
so barbarously snatched from
her, tears, the first I had shed
for many months, streamed from
my eyes, and I resolved not to
fall before my enemy without a
bitter struggle.
from the ocean; my feelings
became calmer, if it may be
called calmness when the
violence of rage sinks into the
depths of despair.
the last night's contention, and
walked
on the beach of the sea, which I
almost regarded as an
insuperable barrier between me
and my fellow creatures; nay, a
wish that such should prove the
fact stole across me.
that barren rock, wearily, it is
true, but uninterrupted by any
sudden shock of misery.or to see
those whom I most loved die
under the grasp of a daemon whom
I had myself created.
spectre, separated from all it
loved and miserable in the
separation.
higher, I lay down on the grass
and was overpowered by a deep
sleep.
preceding night, my nerves were
agitated, and my eyes inflamed
by watching and misery.
refreshed me; and when I awoke,
I again felt as if I belonged to
a race of human beings like
myself, and I began to
reflect upon what had passed
with greater composure; yet
still the words of the fiend
rang in my ears like a
death-knell; they appeared like
a dream,
yet distinct and oppressive as a
reality.
sat on the shore, satisfying my
appetite, which had become
ravenous,
with an oaten cake, when I saw a
fishing-boat land close to me,
and one of the men brought me a
packet; it contained letters
from Geneva, and one
from Clerval entreating me to
join him.
time fruitlessly where he was,
that letters from the friends he
had formed in London desired his
return to complete
the negotiation they had entered
into for his Indian enterprise.
departure; but as his journey to
London
might be followed, even sooner
than he now conjectured, by his
longer voyage, he entreated me
to bestow as much of my society
on him as I could spare.
solitary isle and to meet him at
Perth,
that we might proceed southwards
together.
life, and I determined to quit
my island at the expiration of
two days.task to perform, on
which I shuddered to reflect; I
must pack up my chemical
instruments, and for that
purpose I must The next morning,
at daybreak, I summoned
sufficient courage and unlocked
The remains of the half-finished
creature, whom I had destroyed,
lay scattered on the floor, and
I almost felt as if I had
mangled the living flesh of a
human being.
instruments out of the room, but
I reflected that I ought not to
leave the relics of my work to
excite the horror
and suspicion of the peasants;
and I accordingly put them into
a basket, with a great quantity
of stones, and laying
them up, determined to throw
them into the sea that very
night; and in the meantime I sat
upon the beach, employed in
cleaning and arranging my
chemical apparatus.
alteration that had taken place
in my feelings since the night
of the appearance of the daemon.
gloomy despair as a thing that,
with whatever consequences, must
be fulfilled; but I now felt as
if a film
had been taken from before my
eyes and that I for the first
time saw clearly.
for one instant occur to me; the
threat I had heard weighed on my
thoughts, but
I did not reflect that a
voluntary act of mine could
avert it.
create another like the fiend I
had first made would be an act
of the basest and most atrocious
selfishness, and I banished from
my mind every thought that could
lead to a different conclusion.
the moon rose; and I then,
putting my basket aboard a
little skiff, sailed out about
four miles from the shore.
boats were returning towards
land, but I
sailed away from them.
of a dreadful crime and avoided
with shuddering anxiety any
encounter with my fellow
creatures.
been clear, was suddenly
overspread by a thick cloud, and
I took advantage of the
moment of darkness and cast my
basket into the sea; I listened
to the gurgling sound as it sank
and then sailed away from the
spot.
pure, although chilled by the
northeast breeze that was then
rising.
such agreeable sensations that I
resolved to prolong my stay on
the
water, and fixing the rudder in
a direct position, stretched
myself at the bottom of the
boat.
obscure, and I heard only the
sound of the boat as its keel
cut through the waves; the
murmur lulled me, and in a short
time I slept soundly.
this situation, but when I awoke
I found
that the sun had already mounted
considerably.
continually threatened the
safety of my little skiff.
must have driven me far from the
coast from which I had embarked.
quickly found that if I again
made the attempt the boat would
be instantly filled with water.
slenderly acquainted with the
geography of this part of the
world that the sun was of little
benefit to me.
Atlantic and feel all the
tortures of starvation or be
swallowed up in the immeasurable
waters that roared and buffeted
around me.
felt the torment of a burning
thirst, a prelude to my other
sufferings.
covered by clouds that flew
before the wind, only to be
replaced by others; I
looked upon the sea; it was to
be my grave.
” I thought of Elizabeth, of my
father,
and of Clerval—all left behind,
on whom the monster might
satisfy his sanguinary and
merciless passions.
despairing and frightful that
even now,
when the scene is on the point
of closing before me for ever, I
shudder to reflect on it.
as the sun declined towards the
horizon,
the wind died away into a gentle
breeze and the sea became free
from breakers.
I felt sick and hardly able to
hold the rudder, when suddenly I
saw a line of high land towards
the south.
the dreadful suspense I endured
for
several hours, this sudden
certainty of life rushed like a
flood of warm joy to my heart,
and tears gushed from my eyes.
strange is that clinging love we
have of life even in the excess
of misery!
of my dress and eagerly steered
my course towards the land.
as I approached nearer I easily
perceived the traces of
cultivation.
myself suddenly transported back
to the neighbourhood of
civilised man.
land and hailed a steeple which
I at length saw issuing from
behind a small promontory.
debility, I resolved to sail
directly towards the town, as a
place where I could most easily
procure nourishment.
a small neat town and a good
harbour, which I entered, my
heart bounding with joy at my
unexpected escape.
and arranging the sails, several
people crowded towards the spot.
appearance, but instead of
offering me any assistance,
whispered together with gestures
that at any other time might As
it was, I merely remarked that
they spoke English, and I
therefore addressed them in that
language.so kind as to tell me
the name of this town and inform
me where I am?
“You will know that soon
enough,” replied a man with a
hoarse voice.
will not prove much to your
taste, but you will not be
consulted as to your quarters, I
promise you.
I was exceedingly surprised on
receiving so rude an answer from
a stranger, and I
was also disconcerted on
perceiving the
frowning and angry countenances
of his companions.
Englishmen to receive strangers
so inhospitably.
“I do not know,” said the man,
“what the custom of the English
may be, but it is the custom of
the Irish to hate villains.
While this strange dialogue
continued, I
perceived the crowd rapidly
increase.
curiosity and anger, which
annoyed and in some degree
alarmed me.
sound arose from the crowd as
they
followed and surrounded me, when
an ill-looking man approaching
tapped me on the shoulder and
said, “Come, sir, you must
follow me to Mr.? Kirwin's to
give an account of yourself.
“Ay, sir, free enough for honest
folks.
Kirwin is a magistrate, and you
are to give an account of the
death of a gentleman who was
found murdered here last night.
This answer startled me, but I
presently recovered myself.
proved; accordingly I followed
my conductor in silence and was
led to one of the best houses in
the town.
hunger, but being surrounded by
a crowd, I thought it politic to
rouse all my strength, that no
physical debility
might be construed into
apprehension or conscious guilt.
that was in a few moments to
overwhelm
me and extinguish in horror and
despair all fear of ignominy or
death.
my fortitude to recall the
memory of the frightful events
which I am about to relate, in
proper detail, to my
recollection.
of the magistrate, an old
benevolent man with calm and
mild manners.
degree of severity, and then,
turning
towards my conductors, he asked
who appeared as witnesses on
this occasion.
and, one being selected by the
magistrate, he deposed that he
had been out fishing the night
before with his
son and brother-in-law, Daniel
Nugent, when, about ten o'clock,
they observed a
strong northerly blast rising,
and they accordingly put in for
port.
had not yet risen; they did not
land at the harbour, but, as
they had been accustomed, at a
creek about two miles below.
the fishing tackle, and his
companions followed him at some
distance.
he struck his foot against
something and fell at his length
on the ground.
and by the light of their
lantern they found that he had
fallen on the body of a man, who
was to all appearance dead.
the corpse of some person who
had been drowned and was thrown
on shore by the
waves, but on examination they
found that the clothes were not
wet and even that the body was
not then cold.
cottage of an old woman near the
spot and endeavoured, but in
vain, to restore it to life.
about five and twenty years of
age.
there was no sign of any
violence except the black mark
of fingers on his neck.
not in the least interest me,
but when
the mark of the fingers was
mentioned I remembered the
murder of my brother and felt
myself extremely agitated; my
limbs
trembled, and a mist came over
my eyes, which obliged me to
lean on a chair for support.
eye and of course drew an
unfavourable augury from my
manner.
but when Daniel Nugent was
called he swore positively that
just before the fall of his
companion, he saw a boat,
with a single man in it, at a
short
distance from the shore; and as
far as he could judge by the
light of a few stars, it was the
same boat in which I had just
landed.
beach and was standing at the
door of her cottage, waiting for
the return of
the fishermen, about an hour
before she heard of the
discovery of the body, when she
saw a boat with only one man in
it
push off from that part of the
shore where the corpse was
afterwards found.
the fishermen having brought the
body into her house; it was not
cold.
and Daniel went to the town for
an apothecary, but life was
quite gone.
concerning my landing, and they
agreed that, with the strong
north wind that had arisen
during the night, it was very
probable that I had beaten about
for many hours and had been
obliged to return nearly to the
same spot from which I had
departed.
that I had brought the body from
another place, and it was likely
that as I did
not appear to know the shore, I
might have put into the harbour
ignorant of the distance of the
town of —— from the place where
I had deposited the corpse.
Kirwin, on hearing this
evidence, desired that I should
be taken into the room where the
body lay for interment,
that it might be observed what
effect the sight of it would
produce upon me.
extreme agitation I had
exhibited when the mode of the
murder had been described.
magistrate and several other
persons, to the inn.
strange coincidences that had
taken place during this eventful
night; but,
knowing that I had been
conversing with several persons
in the island I had inhabited
about the time that the body had
been found, I was perfectly
tranquil as to the consequences
of the affair.
and was led up to the coffin.
I reflect on that terrible
moment without shuddering and
agony.
magistrate and witnesses, passed
like a dream from my memory when
I saw the lifeless form of Henry
Clerval stretched before me.
myself on the body, I exclaimed,
“Have my murderous machinations
deprived you also, my dearest
Henry, of life?
victims await their destiny; but
you,
Clerval, my friend, my
benefactor—” The human frame
could no longer support the
agonies that I endured, and I
was
carried out of the room in
strong convulsions.
death; my ravings, as I
afterwards heard, were
frightful; I called myself
the murderer of William, of
Justine, and of Clerval.
assist me in the destruction of
the fiend by whom I was
tormented; and at others I felt
the fingers of the monster
already grasping my neck, and
screamed aloud with agony and
terror.
Kirwin alone understood me; but
my gestures and bitter cries
were sufficient to affright the
other witnesses.
before, why did I not sink into
forgetfulness and rest?
children, the only hopes of
their doting
parents; how many brides and
youthful lovers have been one
day in the bloom of health and
hope, and the next a prey for
worms and the decay of the tomb!
could thus resist so many
shocks, which, like the turning
of the wheel, continually
renewed the torture?
two months found myself as
awaking from a dream, in a
prison, stretched on a
wretched bed, surrounded by
gaolers, turnkeys, bolts, and
all the miserable apparatus of a
dungeon.
awoke to understanding; I had
forgotten the particulars of
what had happened and only felt
as if some great misfortune
had suddenly overwhelmed me; but
when I looked around and saw the
barred windows
and the squalidness of the room
in which I was, all flashed
across my memory and I groaned
bitterly.
was sleeping in a chair beside
me.
of the turnkeys, and her
countenance expressed all those
bad qualities which often
characterise that class.
rude, like that of persons
accustomed to
see without sympathising in
sights of misery.
indifference; she addressed me
in English, and the voice struck
me as one that I had heard
during my sufferings.
” said she.
feeble voice, “I believe I am;
but if it be all true, if indeed
I did not dream,
I am sorry that I am still alive
to feel this misery and horror.
“For that matter,” replied the
old woman, “if you mean about
the gentleman you murdered, I
believe that it were
better for you if you were dead,
for I fancy it will go hard with
you!
am sent to nurse you and get you
well; I do my duty with a safe
conscience; it were well if
everybody did the same.
I turned with loathing from the
woman who could utter so
unfeeling a speech to a person
just saved, on the very edge of
death; but I felt languid and
unable to reflect on all that
had passed.
me as a dream; I sometimes
doubted if
indeed it were all true, for it
never presented itself to my
mind with the force of reality.
became more distinct, I grew
feverish; a
darkness pressed around me; no
one was near me who soothed me
with the gentle voice of love;
no dear hand supported me.
medicines, and the old woman
prepared
them for me; but utter
carelessness was visible in the
first, and the expression of
brutality was strongly marked in
the visage of the second.
a murderer but the hangman who
would gain his fee?
Kirwin had shown me extreme
kindness.
prison to be prepared for me ;
and it
was he who had provided a
physician and a nurse.
for although he ardently desired
to
relieve the sufferings of every
human creature, he did not wish
to be present at the agonies and
miserable ravings of a murderer.
that I was not neglected, but
his visits were short and with
long intervals.
recovering, I was seated in a
chair, my eyes half open and my
cheeks livid like those in
death.
often reflected I had better
seek death
than desire to remain in a world
which to me was replete with
wretchedness.
At one time I considered whether
I should not declare myself
guilty and suffer the penalty of
the law, less innocent than poor
Justine had been.my apartment
was opened and Mr. Kirwin
entered.
compassion; he drew a chair
close to mine and addressed me
in French, “I fear that this
place is very shocking to you;
can I do anything to make you
more comfortable?
”is nothing to me; on the whole
earth there is no comfort which
I am capable
of receiving.
”
can be but of little
relief to one borne down as you
are by so strange a misfortune.
melancholy abode, for doubtless
evidence can easily be brought
to free you from the criminal
charge.
“That is my least concern; I am,
by a course of strange events,
become the most miserable of
mortals.
have been, can death be any evil
to me?
“Nothing indeed could be more
unfortunate and agonising than
the strange chances that have
lately occurred.
accident, on this shore,
renowned for
its hospitality, seized
immediately, and charged with
murder.
your eyes was the body of your
friend, murdered in so
unaccountable a manner
and placed, as it were, by some
fiend across your path.
Kirwin said this,
notwithstanding the agitation I
endured on this retrospect of my
sufferings, I also felt
considerable surprise at the
knowledge he seemed to possess
concerning me.exhibited in my
countenance, for Mr. Kirwin
hastened to say, “Immediately
upon your being taken ill, all
the papers that were on your
person were
brought me, and I examined them
that I might discover some trace
by which I could send to your
relations an account of your
misfortune and illness.
among others, one which I
discovered from its commencement
to be from your father.
nearly two months have elapsed
since the departure of my
letter.
you are unfit for agitation of
any kind.
”
times worse than the most
horrible event; tell me what new
scene of death has been acted,
and whose murder I am now to
lament?“Your family is perfectly
well,” said Mr. Kirwin with
gentleness; “and someone, a
friend, is come to visit you.I
know not by what chain of
thought the
idea presented
itself, but it instantly darted
into my mind that the murderer
had come to mock at my misery
and taunt me with the death
of Clerval, as a new incitement
for me to comply with his
hellish desires.
Kirwin regarded me with a
troubled countenance.
exclamation as a presumption of
my guilt
and said in rather a severe
tone, “I should have thought,
young man, that the presence of
your father would have been
welcome instead of inspiring
such violent repugnance.
” cried I, while every feature
and every
muscle was relaxed from anguish
to pleasure.
My change of manner surprised
and pleased the magistrate;
perhaps he thought that my
former exclamation was a
momentary return of delirium,
and now he instantly resumed his
former benevolence.
nurse, and in a moment my father
entered it.
given me greater pleasure than
the arrival of my father.
cried, “Are you then safe—and
Elizabeth—and Ernest?
My father calmed me with
assurances of their welfare and
endeavoured, by dwelling on
these subjects so interesting to
my heart, to raise my desponding
spirits; but he soon felt
that a prison cannot be the
abode of cheerfulness.
” said he, looking mournfully at
the
barred windows and wretched
appearance of the room.
fatality seems to pursue you.
unfortunate and murdered friend
was an
agitation too great to be
endured in my weak state; I shed
tears.
destiny of the most horrible
kind hangs over me, and I must
live to fulfil it,
or surely I should have died on
the coffin of Henry.
We were not allowed to converse
for any length of time, for the
precarious state
of my health rendered every
precaution
Kirwin came in and insisted that
my strength should not be
exhausted by too much exertion.
was to me like that of my good
angel, and I gradually recovered
my health.
absorbed by a gloomy and black
melancholy that nothing could
dissipate.
ever before me, ghastly and
murdered.
these reflections
threw me made my friends dread a
destiny, which is now drawing to
a close.
extinguish these throbbings and
relieve me from the mighty
weight of anguish that bears me
to the dust; and, in executing
the award of justice, I shall
also sink to rest.
distant, although the wish was
ever
present to my thoughts; and
I often sat for hours motionless
and speechless, wishing for some
mighty revolution that might
bury me and my destroyer in its
ruins.
prison, and although I was still
weak and in continual danger of
a relapse, I
was obliged to travel nearly a
hundred miles to the country
town where the court was held.
Kirwin charged himself with
every care of collecting
witnesses and arranging my
defence.
publicly as a criminal, as the
case was
not brought before the court
that decides on life and death.
its being proved that I was on
the Orkney Islands at the hour
the body of my friend was found;
and a fortnight after my removal
I was
liberated from prison.
freed from the vexations of a
criminal charge, that I was
again allowed to breathe the
fresh atmosphere and permitted
to return to my native country.
feelings, for to me the walls of
a dungeon or a palace were alike
hateful.
and although the sun shone upon
me, as upon the happy and gay of
heart, I saw
around me nothing but a dense
and frightful darkness,
penetrated by no light but the
glimmer of two eyes that glared
upon me.
of Henry, languishing in death,
the dark
orbs nearly covered by the lids
and the long black lashes that
fringed them; sometimes it was
the watery, clouded eyes of the
monster, as I first saw them in
my chamber at Ingolstadt.
soon visit, of Elizabeth and
Ernest; but these words only
drew deep groans from me.
happiness and thought with
melancholy delight of my beloved
cousin or longed,
with a devouringmaladie du pays,
to see once more the blue lake
and rapid Rhone, that had been
so dear to me in early
childhood; but my general state
of
feeling was a torpor in which a
prison was as welcome a
residence as the divinest scene
in nature; and these fits were
seldom interrupted but by
paroxysms of anguish and
despair.
put an end to the existence I
loathed,
and it required unceasing
attendance and vigilance to
restrain me from committing some
dreadful act of violence.
recollection of which finally
triumphed over my selfish
despair.
without delay to Geneva, there
to watch over the lives of those
I so fondly loved and to lie in
wait for the murderer, that if
any chance led me to
the place of his concealment, or
if he dared again to blast me by
his presence, I might, with
unfailing aim, put an end to the
existence of the monstrous image
which I had endued with the
mockery of a soul still more
monstrous.departure, fearful
that I could not sustain the
fatigues of a journey, for I was
a shattered wreck—the shadow of
a human being.
and day preyed upon my wasted
frame.
with such inquietude and
impatience, my father thought it
best to yield.
bound for Havre-de-Grace and
sailed with a fair wind from the
Irish shores.
and listening to the dashing of
the waves.
from my sight, and my pulse beat
with a feverish joy when I
reflected that I should soon see
Geneva.
light of a frightful dream; yet
the vessel in which I was, the
wind that blew me from the
detested shore of Ireland, and
the sea which surrounded me,
told me too forcibly that I was
deceived by no vision and that
Clerval, my friend and dearest
companion, had fallen a victim
to me and the monster of my
creation.
life; my quiet happiness while
residing
with my family in Geneva, the
death of my mother, and my
departure for Ingolstadt.
enthusiasm that hurried me on to
the creation of my hideous
enemy, and I called to mind the
night in which he first lived.
thought; a thousand feelings
pressed upon me, and I wept
bitterly.
I had been in the custom of
taking every night a small
quantity of laudanum, for it was
by means of this drug only that
I was enabled to gain the
rest necessary for the
preservation of life.
various misfortunes, I now
swallowed
double my usual quantity and
soon slept profoundly.
from thought and misery; my
dreams presented a thousand
objects that scared me.
kind of nightmare; I felt the
fiend's grasp in my neck and
could not free myself from it;
groans and cries rang in my
ears.
perceiving my restlessness,
awoke me; the dashing waves were
around, the cloudy sky above,
the fiend was not here:  A sense
of security, a feeling
that a truce was established
between the present hour and the
irresistible, disastrous future
imparted to me a kind of calm
forgetfulness, of which the
human mind is by its structure
peculiarly susceptible.
strength and that I must repose
before I could continue my
journey.indefatigable, but he
did not know the origin of my
sufferings and sought
erroneous methods to remedy the
incurable ill.
beings, and I felt attracted
even to the most repulsive among
them, as to creatures of an
angelic nature and celestial
mechanism.whose joy it was to
shed their blood and to revel in
their groans.and hunt me from
the world, did they know my
unhallowed acts and the crimes
which had their source in me!
my desire to avoid society and
strove by various arguments to
banish my despair.
the degradation of being obliged
to
answer a charge of
murder, and he endeavoured to
prove to me the futility of
pride.
passions, would indeed be
degraded if such a wretch as I
felt pride.
innocent as I, and she suffered
the same charge; she died for
it; and I am the cause of this—I
murdered her.
My father had often, during my
imprisonment, heard me make the
same assertion; when I thus
accused myself, he sometimes
seemed to desire an explanation,
and at others he appeared
to consider it as the offspring
of delirium, and that, during my
illness, some idea of this kind
had presented itself to my
imagination, the remembrance of
which I preserved in my
convalescence.
continual silence concerning the
wretch I had created.
supposed mad, and this in itself
would for ever have chained my
tongue.
to disclose a secret which would
fill my hearer with
consternation and make fear and
unnatural horror the inmates of
his breast.
thirst for sympathy and was
silent when I would have given
the world to have confided the
fatal secret.I could offer no
explanation of them, but their
truth in part relieved the
burden of my mysterious woe.an
expression of unbounded wonder,
“My dearest Victor, what
infatuation is this?make such an
assertion again.
“I am not mad,” I cried
energetically;
“the sun and the heavens, who
have viewed my operations, can
bear witness of my truth.
innocent victims; they died by
my machinations.
own blood, drop by drop, to have
saved their lives; but I could
not, my father,
The conclusion of this speech
convinced my father that my
ideas were deranged, and he
instantly changed the subject of
our conversation and endeavoured
to alter the course of my
thoughts.obliterate the memory
of the scenes that had taken
place in Ireland and never
alluded to them or suffered me
to speak of my misfortunes.
more calm; misery had her
dwelling in my heart, but I no
longer talked in the same
incoherent manner of my own
crimes; sufficient for me was
the consciousness of them.the
imperious voice of wretchedness,
which sometimes desired to
declare itself to the whole
world, and my manners were
calmer and more composed than
they had ever been since my
journey to the sea of ice.way to
Switzerland, I received the “My
dear Friend, “It gave me the
greatest pleasure to receive a
letter from my uncle dated at
Paris; you are no longer at a
formidable distance, and I
may hope to see you in less than
a
fortnight.
must have suffered!ill than when
you quitted Geneva.miserably,
tortured as I have been by
anxious suspense; yet I hope to
see peace in your countenance
and to find that your heart is
not totally void of comfort and
tranquillity.exist that made you
so miserable a year ago, even
perhaps augmented by time.when
so many misfortunes weigh upon
you,
but a conversation that I had
with my uncle
previous to his departure
renders some explanation
necessary before we meet.
Elizabeth have to explain?
questions are answered and all
my doubts satisfied.
possible that you may dread and
yet be pleased with this
explanation; and in a
probability of this being the
case, I dare not any longer
postpone writing what, during
your absence, I have often
wished to express to you but
have never had the courage to
begin.
had been the favourite plan of
your parents ever since our
infancy.
taught to look forward to it as
an event
that would certainly take place.
childhood, and, I believe, dear
and valued friends to one
another as we grew older.
entertain a lively affection
towards
each other without
desiring a more intimate union,
may not such also be our case?
happiness, with simple truth—Do
you not love another?
spent several years of your life
at Ingolstadt; and I confess to
you, my
friend, that when I saw you last
autumn so unhappy, flying to
solitude from the society of
every
creature, I
could not help supposing that
you might regret our connection
and
believe yourself bound in honour
to fulfil the wishes of your
parents, although they
opposed themselves to your
inclinations.
love you and that in my airy
dreams of futurity you have been
my constant friend and
companion.
desire as well as my own when I
declare to you that our marriage
would render me eternally
miserable unless it were the
dictate of your own free choice.
down as you are by the cruellest
misfortunes, you may stifle, by
the wordhonour, all hope of that
love and happiness which would
alone restore you to yourself.
affection for you, may increase
your miseries tenfold by being
an obstacle to your wishes.
playmate has too sincere a love
for you not to be made miserable
by this supposition.in this one
request, remain satisfied that
nothing on earth will have the
“Do not let this letter disturb
you; do not answer tomorrow, or
the next day, or even until you
come, if it will give you pain.
your health, and if I see but
one smile on your lips when we
meet, occasioned by this or any
other exertion of mine, I shall
need no other happiness.
revived in my memory what I had
before forgotten, the threat of
the fiend—“I will be with you on
your wedding-night!Such was my
sentence, and on that night
would the daemon employ every
art to destroy me and tear me
from the glimpse of happiness
which promised partly to console
my sufferings.
consummate his crimes by my
death.
then assuredly
take place, in which if he were
victorious I should be at peace
and his power over me be at an
end.
family have been massacred
before his eyes, his cottage
burnt, his lands laid waste, and
he is turned adrift, homeless,
penniless, and alone, but free.
my Elizabeth I possessed
a treasure, alas, balanced by
those horrors of remorse and
guilt which would pursue me
until death.
softened feelings stole into my
heart and dared to whisper
paradisiacal dreams of love and
joy; but the apple was already
eaten, and the angel's arm bared
to drive me from all hope.
death was inevitable; yet,
again, I considered whether my
marriage would hasten my fate.
few months sooner, but if my
torturer should suspect that I
postponed it, influenced by his
menaces, he would
surely find other and perhaps
more dreadful means of revenge.
wedding-night, yet he did not
consider that threat as binding
him to peace in the meantime,
for as if to show me that
he was not yet satiated with
blood, he had murdered Clerval
immediately after the
enunciation of his threats.
immediate union with my cousin
would conduce either to hers or
my father's happiness, my
adversary's designs against my
life
In this state of mind I wrote to
Elizabeth.
“little happiness remains for us
on earth; yet all that I may one
day enjoy is centred in you.
you alone do I consecrate my
life and my endeavours for
contentment.
dreadful one; when revealed to
you, it
will chill your frame with
horror, and then, far from being
surprised at my misery, you will
only wonder that I survive what
I have endured.
terror to you the day
after our marriage shall take
place, for, my sweet cousin,
there must be perfect confidence
between us.
and I know you will comply.
In about a week after the
arrival of Elizabeth's letter we
returned to Geneva.
affection, yet tears were in her
eyes as she beheld my emaciated
frame and feverish cheeks.
that heavenly vivacity that had
before charmed me; but her
gentleness and soft
looks of compassion made her a
more fit companion for one
blasted and miserable as I was.
when I thought of what had
passed, a real insanity
possessed me; sometimes I
was furious and burnt with rage,
sometimes low and despondent.
but sat motionless, bewildered
by the
multitude of miseries that
overcame me.
me from these fits; her gentle
voice would soothe me when
transported by
passion and inspire me with
human feelings when sunk in
torpor.
remonstrate and endeavour to
inspire me with resignation.
resigned, but for the guilty
there is no peace.
luxury there is otherwise
sometimes found in indulging the
excess of grief.of my immediate
marriage with Elizabeth.our
union with delight.it I will
consecrate myself, in life or
death, to the happiness of my
cousin.
“My dear Victor, do not speak
thus.
let us only cling closer to what
remains and transfer our love
for those whom we have lost to
those who yet live.
close by the ties of affection
and mutual misfortune.
despair, new and dear objects of
care
will be born to replace those of
whom we have been so cruelly
deprived.
Such were the lessons of my
father.
returned; nor can you wonder
that, omnipotent as the fiend
had yet been in his deeds of
blood, I should almost
regard him as invincible, and
that when he had pronounced the
words “I shall be with you on
your wedding-night,” I
should regard the threatened
fate as unavoidable.
of Elizabeth were balanced with
it, and
I therefore, with a contented
and even
cheerful countenance, agreed
with my father that if my cousin
would consent,
the ceremony should take place
in ten days, and thus put, as I
imagined, the seal to my fate.
might be the hellish intention
of my fiendish adversary, I
would rather have banished
myself for ever from my native
country and wandered a
friendless outcast over the
earth than have consented to
this miserable marriage.
the monster had blinded me to
his real intentions; and when I
thought that I
had prepared only my own death,
I hastened that of a far dearer
victim.drew nearer, whether from
cowardice or a prophetic
feeling, I felt my heart sink
within me.appearance of hilarity
that brought smiles and joy to
the countenance of my father,
but hardly deceived the
ever-watchful and nicer eye of
Elizabeth.
placid contentment, not
unmingled with a
little fear, which past
misfortunes had impressed, that
what now appeared certain and
tangible happiness might soon
dissipate into an airy dream and
leave no trace but deep and
everlasting regret.
congratulatory visits were
received, and all wore a smiling
appearance.
own heart the anxiety that
preyed there and entered with
seeming earnestness
into the plans of my father,
although they might only serve
as the decorations of my
tragedy.
the inheritance of Elizabeth had
been restored to her by the
Austrian government.
our union, we should proceed to
Villa Lavenza and spend our
first days of happiness beside
the beautiful lake near which it
stood.to defend my person in
case the fiend should openly
attack me.
constantly about me and was ever
on the watch to prevent
artifice, and by these
means gained a greater degree of
tranquillity.
threat appeared more as a
delusion, not
to be regarded as worthy to
disturb my peace, while the
happiness I hoped for in my
marriage wore a greater
appearance
of certainty as the day fixed
for its solemnisation drew
nearer and I heard it
continually spoken of as an
occurrence which no accident
could possibly prevent.
demeanour contributed greatly to
calm her mind.
wishes and my destiny, she was
melancholy, and a presentiment
of evil
pervaded her; and perhaps also
she thought of the dreadful
secret which I had promised to
reveal to her on the following
day.
overjoyed, and, in the bustle of
preparation, only recognised in
the melancholy of his niece the
diffidence of a bride.
large party assembled at my
father's, but it was agreed that
Elizabeth and I should commence
our journey by water,
sleeping that night at Evian and
continuing our voyage on the
following day.Those were the
last moments of my life during
which I enjoyed the feeling of
happiness.
hot, but we were sheltered from
its rays by a kind of canopy
while we enjoyed the
beauty of the scene, sometimes
on one side of the lake, where
we saw Mont Salêve, the pleasant
banks of Montalègre, and at a
distance, surmounting all, the
beautiful Mont Blanc, and the
assemblage of snowy
mountains that in vain endeavour
to emulate her; sometimes
coasting the opposite banks, we
saw the mighty Jura opposing its
dark side to the ambition that
would quit its native country,
and
an almost insurmountable barrier
to the invader who should wish
to enslave it.
what I may yet endure, you would
endeavour to let me taste the
quiet and freedom from despair
that this one day at least
permits me to enjoy.
“Be happy, my dear Victor,”
replied Elizabeth; “there is, I
hope, nothing to distress you;
and be assured that if a
lively joy is not painted in my
face, my heart is contented.
too much on the prospect that is
opened before us, but I will not
listen to such a sinister voice.
the clouds, which sometimes
obscure and sometimes rise above
the dome of Mont Look also at
the innumerable fish that are
swimming in the clear waters,
where we can distinguish every
pebble that lies at the bottom.
Thus Elizabeth endeavoured to
divert her thoughts and mine
from all reflection upon
melancholy subjects.
a few instants shone in her
eyes, but it continually gave
place to distraction and
reverie.
passed the river Drance and
observed its
path through the chasms of the
higher and the glens of the
lower hills.
and we approached the
amphitheatre of mountains which
forms its eastern boundary.
woods that surrounded it and the
range of mountain above mountain
by which it was overhung.
along with amazing rapidity,
sank at sunset to a light
breeze; the soft air
just ruffled the water and
caused a pleasant motion among
the trees as we approached the
shore, from which it wafted the
most delightful scent of flowers
and hay.landed, and as I touched
the shore I felt those cares and
fears revive which soon were to
clasp me and cling to me for
ever.
landed; we walked for a short
time on the shore, enjoying the
transitory light, and then
retired to the inn and
contemplated the lovely
scene of waters, woods, and
mountains, obscured in darkness,
yet still displaying their black
outlines.
south, now rose with great
violence in the west.
heavens and was beginning to
descend; the clouds swept across
it swifter than
the flight of the vulture and
dimmed her rays, while the lake
reflected the scene of the busy
heavens, rendered still
busier by the restless waves
that were beginning to rise.
soon as night obscured the
shapes of objects, a thousand
fears arose in my mind.
right hand grasped a pistol
which was hidden in my bosom;
every sound terrified me, but I
resolved that I would sell my
life dearly and not shrink
from the conflict until my own
life or that of my adversary was
extinguished.
some time in timid and fearful
silence, but there was something
in my glance
which communicated terror to
her, and trembling, she asked,
“What is it that agitates you,
my dear Victor?
“this night, and all will be
safe; but this night is
dreadful, very dreadful.
I passed an hour in this state
of mind, when suddenly I
reflected how fearful the combat
which I momentarily
expected would be to my wife,
and I earnestly entreated her to
retire, resolving not to join
her until I had obtained some
knowledge as to the situation of
my enemy.
walking up and down the passages
of the
house and inspecting every
corner that might afford a
retreat to my adversary.
was beginning to conjecture that
some fortunate chance had
intervened to prevent the
execution of his menaces
when suddenly I heard a shrill
and dreadful scream.
into my mind, my arms dropped,
the motion of every muscle and
fibre was suspended; I could
feel the blood trickling in my
veins and tingling in
the extremities of my limbs.
the scream was repeated, and I
rushed into the room.
of the best hope and the purest
creature on earth?
thrown across the bed, her head
hanging down and her pale and
distorted features half covered
by her hair.
figure—her bloodless arms and
relaxed form flung by the
murderer on its bridal bier.
recollection; I fell senseless
on the ground.
surrounded by the people of the
inn; their countenances
expressed a breathless terror,
but the horror of
others appeared only as a
mockery, a shadow of the
feelings that oppressed me.
lay the body of Elizabeth, my
love, my wife, so lately living,
so dear, so worthy.
which I had first beheld her,
and now,
as she lay, her head upon her
arm and a handkerchief thrown
across her face and neck, I
might have supposed her asleep.
with ardour, but the deadly
languor and coldness of the
limbs told me that what
I now held in my arms had ceased
to be the Elizabeth whom I had
loved and cherished.
was on her neck, and the breath
had ceased to issue from her
lips.
agony of despair, I happened to
look up.
darkened, and I felt a kind of
panic on seeing the pale yellow
light of the moon
The shutters had been thrown
back, and with a sensation of
horror not to be described, I
saw at the open window a figure
the most hideous and abhorred.he
seemed to jeer, as with his
fiendish finger he pointed
towards the corpse of my wife.
drawing a pistol from my bosom,
fired; but he eluded me, leaped
from his station, and running
with the swiftness of lightning,
plunged into the lake.
disappeared, and we followed the
track with boats; nets were
cast, but in vain.returned
hopeless, most of my companions
believing it to have been a form
conjured up by my fancy.search
the country, parties going in
different directions among the
woods and vines.
proceeded a short distance from
the
house, but my head
whirled round, my steps were
like those of a drunken man, I
fell at last in a state of utter
exhaustion; a film covered my
eyes, and my skin was parched
with the heat of fever.
placed on a bed, hardly
conscious of what had happened;
my eyes wandered round the room
as if to seek something that I
had lost.
as if by instinct, crawled into
the room where the corpse of my
beloved lay.
over it and joined my sad tears
to theirs; all this time no
distinct idea presented itself
to my
mind, but my thoughts rambled to
various subjects, reflecting
confusedly on my misfortunes and
their cause.
Justine, the murder of Clerval,
and lastly of my wife; even at
that moment I
knew not that my only remaining
friends were safe from the
malignity of the
fiend; my father even now might
be
writhing under his grasp, and
Ernest might be dead at his
feet.
I started up and resolved to
return to Geneva with all
possible speed.and I must return
by the lake; but the wind was
unfavourable, and the rain fell
in torrents.might reasonably
hope to arrive by night.
myself, for I had always
experienced relief from mental
torment in bodily exercise.
and the excess of agitation that
I
endured rendered me incapable of
any exertion.
leaning my head upon my hands,
gave way to every gloomy idea
that arose.
which were familiar to me in my
happier time and which I had
contemplated but the day before
in the company of her who was
now but a shadow and a
recollection.
saw the fish play
in the waters as they had done a
few hours before; they had then
been observed by Elizabeth.
as a great and sudden change.
lower, but nothing could appear
to me as it had done the day
before.
every hope of future happiness;
no creature had ever been so
miserable as I was; so frightful
an event is single in the
history of man.
incidents that followed this
last overwhelming event?
reached theiracme, and what I
must now relate can but be
tedious to you.
friends were snatched away; I
was left desolate.
must tell, in a few words, what
remains of my hideous narration.
former sunk under the tidings
that I bore.
for they had lost their charm
and their delight—his Elizabeth,
his more than
daughter, whom he doted on with
all that affection which a man
feels, who in the decline of
life,
having few affections, clings
more earnestly to those that
remain.
brought misery on his grey hairs
and doomed him to waste in
wretchedness!
that were accumulated around
him; the springs of existence
suddenly gave way;
he was unable to rise from his
bed, and in a few days he died
in my arms.
chains and darkness were the
only objects that pressed upon
me.
wandered in flowery meadows and
pleasant vales with the friends
of my youth, but I awoke and
found myself in a dungeon.
gained a clear conception of my
miseries
and situation and was then
released from my prison.
many months, as I understood, a
solitary cell had been my
habitation.
gift to me, had I not, as I
awakened to reason, at the same
time awakened to revenge.
pressed upon me, I began to
reflect on
their cause—the monster whom I
had created, the miserable
daemon whom I had sent abroad
into the world for my
destruction.
when I thought of him, and
desired and ardently prayed that
I might have him within my grasp
to wreak a great and signal
revenge on his cursed head.
useless wishes; I began to
reflect on
the best means of securing him;
and for this purpose, about a
month after my release, I
repaired to a criminal judge
in the town and told him that I
had an accusation to make, that
I knew the destroyer of my
family, and that I required him
to exert his whole authority for
the apprehension of the
murderer.
or exertions on my part shall be
spared to discover the villain.
“I thank you,” replied I;
“listen, therefore, to the
deposition that I have to make.
should fear you would not credit
it were
there not something in truth
which, however wonderful, forces
conviction.
mistaken for a dream, and I have
no motive for falsehood.
” My
manner as I thus addressed him
was impressive but calm; I had
formed in my own heart a
resolution to pursue my
destroyer to death, and this
purpose quieted my agony and for
an interval reconciled me to
life.
with firmness and precision,
marking the dates with accuracy
and never deviating
The magistrate appeared at first
perfectly incredulous, but as I
continued he became more
attentive and interested; I saw
him sometimes shudder with
horror; at others a lively
surprise, unmingled with
disbelief, was When I had
concluded my narration, I said,
“This is the being whom I accuse
and for whose seizure and
punishment I call upon you to
exert your whole power.
and I believe and hope that your
feelings as a man will not
revolt from the execution of
those functions on this
occasion.This address caused a
considerable change in the
physiognomy of my own auditor.
kind of belief that is given to
a tale of spirits and
supernatural events; but
when he
was called upon to act
officially in consequence, the
whole tide of his incredulity
returned.
willingly afford you every
aid in your pursuit, but the
creature of whom you speak
appears to have powers which
would put all my exertions to
defiance.
can traverse the sea of ice and
inhabit caves and dens where no
man would venture to intrude?the
commission of his crimes, and no
one
can conjecture to what place he
has wandered or what region he
may now inhabit.”
spot which I inhabit, and if he
has indeed taken refuge in the
Alps, he may be hunted like the
chamois and destroyed as a beast
of prey.not credit my narrative
and do not intend to pursue my
enemy with the punishment which
is his desert.
As I spoke, rage sparkled in my
eyes; the magistrate was
intimidated.
my power to seize the monster,
be
assured that he shall suffer
punishment proportionate to his
crimes.
yourself described to be his
properties,
that this will prove
impracticable; and thus, while
every proper measure is pursued,
you should make up your mind to
disappointment.
”
can say will be of little avail.
while I allow it to be a vice, I
confess
that it is the
devouring and only passion of my
soul.
that the murderer, whom I have
turned loose upon society, still
exists.
have but one resource, and I
devote myself, either in my life
or death, to his destruction.I
trembled with excess of
agitation as I said this; there
was a frenzy in my manner, and
something, I doubt not, of that
haughty fierceness which the
martyrs of old are said to have
possessed.
was occupied by far other ideas
than
those of devotion and heroism,
this
elevation of mind had much the
appearance of madness.
does a child and reverted
to my tale as the effects of
delirium.
I broke from the house angry and
disturbed and retired to
meditate on some other mode of
action.
all voluntary thought was
swallowed up and lost.
alone endowed me with
strength and composure; it
moulded my feelings and allowed
me to be calculating and calm at
periods when otherwise delirium
or death would have been my
portion.
Geneva for ever; my country,
which, when I was happy and
beloved, was dear to me, now, in
my adversity, became hateful.
together with a few jewels which
had belonged to my mother, and
departed.
to cease but with life.
of the earth and have endured
all the hardships which
travellers in deserts and
barbarous countries are wont to
meet.
die and leave my adversary in
being.was to gain some clue by
which I might trace the steps of
my fiendish enemy.wandered many
hours round the confines of the
town, uncertain what path I
should pursue.
the entrance of the cemetery
where William, Elizabeth, and my
father reposed.
of the trees, which were gently
agitated by the wind; the night
was nearly dark,
and the scene would have been
solemn and affecting even to an
uninterested observer.
flit around and to cast a
shadow, which was felt but not
seen, around the head of the
mourner.
first excited quickly gave way
to rage and despair.
murderer also lived, and to
destroy him I must drag out my
weary existence.
earth and with quivering lips
exclaimed, “By the sacred earth
on which I kneel,
by the shades that wander near
me, by the deep and eternal
grief that I feel, I swear; and
by thee, O Night, and the
spirits that preside over thee,
to pursue the daemon who caused
this
misery, until he or I shall
perish in mortal conflict.
life; to execute this dear
revenge will I again behold the
sun and tread the green herbage
of earth, which otherwise should
vanish from my eyes for ever.
and on you, wandering ministers
of vengeance, to aid and conduct
me in my work.
drink deep of agony; let him
feel the despair that now
torments me.
I had begun my adjuration with
solemnity and an awe which
almost assured me that
the shades of my murdered
friends heard and approved my
devotion, but the furies
possessed me as I concluded, and
rage choked my utterance.
night by a loud and fiendish
laugh.
the mountains re-echoed it, and
I felt as if all hell surrounded
me with mockery and laughter.
been possessed by frenzy and
have destroyed my miserable
existence but that my vow was
heard and that I was reserved
for vengeance.well-known and
abhorred voice, apparently close
to my ear, addressed me
in an audible whisper, “I am
satisfied, miserable wretch!
I darted towards the spot from
which the sound proceeded, but
the devil eluded my grasp.
arose and shone full upon his
ghastly and distorted shape as
he fled with more
than mortalI pursued him, and
for many months this has been my
task.
windings of the Rhone, but
vainly.
a strange chance, I saw the
fiend enter by night and hide
himself in a vessel bound for
the Black Sea.
he escaped, I know not how.
although he still evaded me, I
have ever followed in his track.
by this horrid apparition,
informed me of his path;
sometimes he himself, who
feared that if I lost all trace
of him I should despair and die,
left some mark to guide me.
saw the print of his huge step
on the white plain.
care is new and agony unknown,
how can you understand what I
have felt and still feel?
pains which I was destined to
endure; I was cursed by some
devil and carried about with me
my eternal hell; yet still
a spirit of good followed and
directed my steps and when I
most murmured would
suddenly extricate me from
seemingly insurmountable
difficulties.
hunger, sank under the
exhaustion, a repast was
prepared for me in the desert
that restored and inspirited me.
the peasants of the country ate,
but I
will not doubt that it was set
there by the spirits that I had
invoked to aid me.
cloudless, and I was parched by
thirst, a slight cloud would
bedim the sky, shed
the few drops that revived me,
and vanish.
of the rivers; but the daemon
generally
avoided these, as it was here
that the population of the
country chiefly collected.
seldom seen, and I generally
subsisted on the wild animals
that crossed my path.
friendship of the villagers by
distributing it; or I brought
with me some food that I had
killed, which, after taking a
small part, I always
presented to those who had
provided me with fire and
utensils for cooking.
hateful to me, and it was during
sleep alone that I could taste
joy.
repose, and my dreams lulled me
even to rapture.
provided these moments, or
rather hours, of happiness that
I might retain strength to
fulfil my pilgrimage.sunk under
my hardships.
inspirited by the hope of night,
for in sleep I saw my friends,
my wife, and my
beloved country; again I saw the
benevolent countenance of my
father, heard the silver tones
of my Elizabeth's voice, and
beheld Clerval enjoying health
and youth.
march, I persuaded myself that I
was dreaming until night should
come and that I should then
enjoy reality in the arms of my
dearest friends.
sometimes they haunted even my
waking hours, and persuade
myself that they still lived!
within me, died in my heart, and
I pursued my path towards the
destruction
of the daemon more as a task
enjoined by heaven, as the
mechanical impulse of some power
of which I was unconscious, than
as the ardent desire of my soul.
writing on the barks of the
trees or cut in stone that
guided me and instigated my
fury.
words were legible in one of
these inscriptions—“you live,
and my power is complete.
of the north, where you will
feel the
misery of cold and frost, to
which I am impassive.
follow not too tardily, a dead
hare; eat and be refreshed.
wrestle for our lives, but many
hard and miserable hours must
you endure until that period
shall arrive.
devote thee, miserable fiend, to
torture and death.
or I perish; and then with what
ecstasy shall I join my
Elizabeth and my
departed friends, who even now
prepare for me the reward of my
tedious toil and horrible
pilgrimage!
northward, the snows thickened
and the cold increased in a
degree almost too severe to
support.
hovels, and only a few of the
most hardy ventured forth to
seize the animals whom
starvation had forced from their
hiding-places to seek for prey.
no fish could be procured; and
thus I
was cut off from my chief
article of maintenance.
the difficulty of my labours.
furs and provide food, for we
shall soon
enter upon a journey where your
sufferings will satisfy my
everlasting hatred.
My courage and perseverance were
invigorated by these scoffing
words; I resolved not to fail in
my purpose, and
calling on Heaven to support me,
I continued with unabated
fervour to traverse immense
deserts, until the ocean
appeared at a distance and
formed the utmost boundary of
the horizon.
distinguished from land by its
superior wildness and
ruggedness.
beheld the Mediterranean from
the hills of Asia, and hailed
with rapture the boundary of
their toils.
with a full heart thanked my
guiding spirit for conducting me
in safety to the place where I
hoped, notwithstanding
my adversary's gibe, to meet and
grapple with him.
procured a sledge and dogs and
thus traversed the snows with
inconceivable speed.
the same advantages, but I found
that, as before I had daily lost
ground in the
pursuit, I now gained on him, so
much so that when I first saw
the ocean he was but one day's
journey in advance, and I
hoped to intercept him before he
should reach the beach.
on, and in two days arrived at a
wretched hamlet on the seashore.
concerning the fiend and gained
accurate information.
arrived the night before, armed
with a gun and many pistols,
putting to flight
the inhabitants of a solitary
cottage through fear of his
terrific appearance.
winter food, and placing it in a
sledge, to draw which he had
seized on a
numerous drove of trained dogs,
he had harnessed them, and the
same night, to the joy of the
horror-struck villagers,
had pursued his journey across
the sea in a direction that led
to no land; and they conjectured
that he must speedily
be destroyed by the breaking of
the ice or frozen by the eternal
frosts.
a temporary access of despair.
a destructive and almost endless
journey
across the mountainous ices of
the ocean, amidst cold that few
of the inhabitants could long
endure and which I, the native
of a genial and sunny climate,
could not hope to survive.
live and be triumphant, my rage
and vengeance returned, and like
a mighty tide, overwhelmed every
other feeling.
spirits of the dead hovered
round and instigated me to toil
and revenge, I prepared for my
journey.
fashioned for the inequalities
of the
Frozen Ocean, and purchasing a
plentiful stock of provisions, I
departed from land.
passed since then, but I have
endured misery which nothing but
the eternal sentiment of a just
retribution burning within my
heart could have enabled me to
support.
often barred up my passage, and
I often heard the thunder of the
ground sea, which threatened my
destruction.
paths of the sea secure.
had consumed, I should guess
that I had passed three weeks in
this journey; and
the continual protraction of
hope, returning back upon the
heart, often wrung bitter drops
of despondency and grief from my
eyes.
prey, and I should soon have
sunk beneath this misery.
conveyed me had with incredible
toil
gained the summit of a sloping
ice mountain, and one, sinking
under his fatigue, died, I
viewed the expanse before me
with anguish, when suddenly my
eye caught a dark speck upon the
dusky plain.
could be and uttered a wild cry
of ecstasy when I distinguished
a sledge
and the distorted proportions of
a well-known form within.
hastily wiped away, that they
might not intercept the view I
had of the daemon; but still my
sight was dimmed by the
burning drops, until, giving way
to the emotions that oppressed
me, I wept aloud.
disencumbered the dogs of their
dead companion, gave them a
plentiful portion
of food, and after an hour's
rest, which was absolutely
necessary, and yet which was
bitterly irksome to me, I
continued my route.
again lose sight of it except at
the moments when for a short
time some
ice-rock concealed it with its
intervening crags.
when, after nearly two days'
journey, I beheld my enemy at no
more than a mile distant, my
heart bounded within me.
grasp of my foe, my hopes were
suddenly extinguished, and I
lost all trace of
him more utterly than I had ever
done before.
its progress, as the waters
rolled and
swelled beneath me, became every
moment more ominous and
terrific.
with the mighty shock of an
earthquake, it split and cracked
with a tremendous
and overwhelming sound.
minutes a tumultuous sea rolled
between me and my enemy, and I
was left drifting
on a scattered piece of ice that
was continually lessening and
thus preparing for me a hideous
death.
passed; several of my dogs died,
and I myself was about to sink
under the accumulation of
distress when I saw your
vessel riding at anchor and
holding forth to me hopes of
succour and life.
came so far north and was
astounded at the sight.
to construct oars, and by these
means was enabled, with infinite
fatigue, to move my ice raft in
the direction of your ship.
southwards, still to trust
myself to the mercy of the seas
rather than abandon my purpose.
boat with which I could pursue
my enemy.
exhausted, and I should soon
have sunk
under my multiplied hardships
into a death which I still
dread, for my task is
unfulfilled.
conducting me to the daemon,
allow me the rest I so much
desire; or must I die, and he
yet live?
shall not escape, that you will
seek him and satisfy my
vengeance in his death.
undertake my pilgrimage, to
endure the hardships that I have
undergone?
appear, if the ministers of
vengeance should conduct him to
you, swear that he
shall not live—swear that he
shall not triumph over my
accumulated woes and He is
eloquent and persuasive, and
once his words had even power
over my heart; but trust him
not.
full of treachery and fiend-like
malice.
William, Justine, Clerval,
Elizabeth, my
father, and of the wretched
Victor, and thrust your sword
into his heart.
story, Margaret; and do you not
feel
your blood congeal
with horror, like that which
even now curdles mine?could not
continue his tale; at others,
his voice broken, yet piercing,
uttered with difficulty the
words so replete with anguish.
lighted up with indignation, now
subdued to downcast sorrow and
quenched in infinite
wretchedness.
and tones and related the most
horrible incidents with a
tranquil voice, suppressing
every mark of agitation; then,
like a volcano bursting forth,
his face would suddenly change
to an
expression of the wildest rage
as he shrieked out imprecations
on his persecutor.
appearance of the simplest
truth, yet I own to you that the
letters of Felix and
Safie, which he showed me, and
the apparition of the monster
seen from our ship, brought to
me a greater conviction
of the truth of his narrative
than his asseverations, however
earnest and connected.
Frankenstein the particulars of
his creature's formation, but on
this point he was impenetrable.
Would you also create for
yourself and the world a
demoniacal enemy?
Frankenstein discovered that I
made notes concerning his
history; he asked to see them
and then himself corrected
and augmented them in many
places, but principally in
giving the life and spirit to
the conversations he held with
his enemy.
narration,” said he, “I would
not that a mutilated one should
go down to posterity.
Thus has a week passed away,
while I have listened to the
strangest tale that ever
imagination formed.
soul have been drunk up by the
interest for my guest which this
tale and his own elevated and
gentle manners have created.
one so infinitely miserable, so
destitute of every hope of
consolation, to live?
be when he composes his
shattered spirit to peace and
death.
offspring of solitude and
delirium; he believes that when
in dreams he holds converse with
his friends and derives
from that communion consolation
for his miseries or excitements
to his vengeance, that they are
not the creations of his fancy,
but the beings themselves who
visit him from the regions of a
remote world.
reveries that render them to me
almost as imposing and
interesting as truth.
confined to his own history and
misfortunes.
displays unbounded knowledge and
a quick and piercing
apprehension.
touching; nor can I hear him,
when he relates a pathetic
incident or endeavours to move
the passions of pity or love,
without tears.
been in the days of his
prosperity, when he is thus
noble and godlike in ruin!
myself destined for some great
enterprise.
possessed a coolness of judgment
that fitted me for illustrious
achievements.
nature supported me when others
would
have been oppressed, for I
deemed it criminal to throw away
in useless grief those talents
that might be useful to my
fellow creatures.
completed, no less a one than
the creation of a sensitive and
rational animal, I could not
rank myself with the herd of
common projectors.
the commencement of my career,
now serves only to plunge me
lower in the dust.
nothing, and like the archangel
who aspired to omnipotence, I am
chained in an eternal hell.of
analysis and application were
intense; by the union of these
qualities I conceived the idea
and executed the creation of a
man.
passion my reveries while the
work was incomplete.
exulting in my powers, now
burning with the idea of their
effects.
hopes and a lofty ambition; but
how am I sunk!
once was, you would not
recognise me in this state of
degradation.
high destiny seemed to bear me
on, until I fell, never, never
again to rise.
Must I then lose this admirable
being?
sought one who would sympathise
with and love me.
found such a one, but I fear I
have gained him only to know his
value and lose him.
your kind intentions towards so
miserable a wretch; but when you
speak of new ties and fresh
affections, think
you that any can replace those
who are gone?
any woman another Elizabeth?
strongly moved by any superior
excellence, the companions of
our childhood always possess a
certain power
over our minds which hardly any
later friend can obtain.
which, however they may be
afterwards modified, are never
eradicated; and they
can judge of our actions with
more certain conclusions as to
the integrity of our motives.
indeed such symptoms have been
shown early, suspect the other
of fraud or false dealing, when
another friend,
however strongly he may be
attached, may, in spite of
himself, be contemplated with
suspicion.
through habit and association,
but from their own merits; and
wherever I am, the
soothing voice of my Elizabeth
and the conversation of Clerval
will be ever whispered in my
ear.
such a solitude can persuade me
to preserve my life.
undertaking or design, fraught
with extensive utility to my
fellow creatures, then could I
live to fulfil it.
pursue and destroy the being to
whom I gave existence; then my
lot on earth will be fulfilled
and I may die.
My beloved Sister, September 2d.
and ignorant whether I am ever
doomed to see again dear England
and the dearer friends that
inhabit it.
which admit of no escape and
threaten every moment to crush
my vessel.
to be my companions look towards
me for aid, but I have none to
bestow.
in our situation, yet my courage
and hopes do not desert me.
lives of all these men are
endangered through me.
and you will anxiously await my
return.visitings of despair and
yet be tortured by hope.
My beloved sister, the sickening
failing of your heart-felt
expectations is, in prospect,
more terrible to me than my own
death.
children; you may be happy.
talks as if life were a
possession which he valued.
accidents have happened to other
navigators who have attempted
this sea, and in spite of
myself, he fills me with
cheerful auguries.
eloquence; when he speaks, they
no longer despair; he rouses
their energies, and while they
hear his voice
they believe these vast
mountains of ice are mole-hills
which will vanish before the
resolutions of man.
of expectation delayed fills
them with fear, and I almost
dread a mutiny caused by this
despair.
uncommon interest that, although
it is highly probable that these
papers may never reach you, yet
I cannot forbear recording it.
ice, still in imminent danger of
being crushed in their conflict.
unfortunate comrades have
already found a grave amidst
this scene of desolation.
health; a feverish fire still
glimmers in his eyes, but he is
exhausted, and when suddenly
roused to any exertion, he
speedily sinks again into
apparent lifelessness.I
entertained of a mutiny.
the wan countenance of my
friend—his eyes half closed and
his limbs hanging listlessly—I
Fe Fe Fe Fe Fe Fe was roused by
half a dozen of the sailors, He
told me that he and his
companions had been chosen by
the other sailors to come in
deputation to me to make me a
requisition which, in justice, I
could not refuse.probably never
escape, but they feared that if,
as was possible, the ice should
dissipate and a free passage be
Fe opened, I should be rash
enough to continue my voyage and
lead them into fresh dangers,
after they might happily have
surmounted this.
engage with a solemn promise
that if the
vessel should be freed I would
instantly direct my course
southwards.
conceived the idea of returning
if set free.
possibility, refuse this demand?
Frankenstein, who had at first
been silent, and indeed appeared
hardly to
have force enough to attend, now
roused himself; his eyes
sparkled, and his cheeks flushed
with momentary vigour.
placid as a southern sea, but
because it was full of dangers
and terror, because
at every new incident your
fortitude was to be called forth
and your courage
exhibited, because danger and
death surrounded it, and these
you were to brave and overcome.
was it an honourable
undertaking.benefactors of your
species, your names adored as
belonging to brave men who
encountered death for honour and
the benefit of mankind.
imagination of danger, or, if
you will, the first mighty and
terrific trial of your courage,
you shrink away and are
content to be handed down as men
who had not strength enough to
endure cold and peril; and so,
poor souls, they were chilly and
returned to their warm
firesides.
preparation; ye need not have
come thus far and dragged your
captain to the shame of a defeat
merely to prove yourselves
cowards.
your hearts may be; it is
mutable and cannot withstand you
if you say that it
Do not return to your families
with the stigma of disgrace
marked on your brows.
conquered and who know not what
it is to turn their backs on the
foe.He spoke this with a voice
so modulated to the different
feelings expressed in
his speech, with an eye so full
of lofty design and heroism,
that can you wonder that these
men were moved?
consider of what had been said,
that I would not lead them
farther north if they
strenuously desired the
contrary, but that I hoped that,
with reflection, their courage
would return.How all this will
terminate, I know not, but I had
rather die than return
shamefully, my purpose
unfulfilled.
men, unsupported by ideas of
glory and honour, can never
willingly continue to endure
their present hardships.
return if we are not destroyed.
and indecision; I come back
ignorant and disappointed.
possess to bear this injustice
with patience.
glory; I have lost my friend.
bitter circumstances to you, my
dear sister; and while I am
wafted towards England and
towards you, I will not despond.
and roarings like thunder were
heard at a distance as the
islands split and cracked in
every direction.
as we could only remain passive,
my
chief attention was occupied by
my unfortunate guest whose
illness increased in such a
degree that he was entirely
confined to his bed.
driven with force towards the
north; a breeze sprang from the
west, and on the 11th the
passage towards the south became
perfectly free.
their return to their native
country was apparently assured,
a shout of tumultuous joy broke
from them, loud and
long-continued.
asked the cause of the tumult.
will soon return to England.
“Do so, if you will; but I will
not.is assigned to me by Heaven,
and I dare not.assist my
vengeance will endow me with
sufficient strength.” Saying
this, he endeavoured to spring
from the bed, but the exertion
was too great for him; he fell
back and fainted.
I often thought that life was
entirely extinct.
breathed with difficulty and was
unable to speak.
draught and ordered us to leave
him undisturbed.
friend had certainly not many
hours to live.
could only grieve and be
patient.
eyes were closed, and I thought
he slept; but presently he
called to me in a feeble voice,
and bidding me come near, said,
“Alas!
feel that I shall soon die, and
he, my
enemy and persecutor, may still
be in being.
moments of my existence I feel
that burning hatred and ardent
desire of revenge I once
expressed; but I feel
myself justified in desiring the
death of my adversary.
occupied in examining my past
conduct; nor do I find it
blamable.
created a rational creature and
was bound towards him to assure,
as far as
was in my power, his happiness
and well-being.
another still paramount to that.
species had greater claims to my
attention because they included
a
greater proportion of happiness
or misery.
did right in refusing, to create
a companion for the first
creature.
selfishness in evil; he
destroyed my friends; he devoted
to destruction beings who
possessed exquisite sensations,
happiness, and wisdom; nor
do I know where this thirst for
vengeance may end.
other wretched, he ought to die.
motives, I asked you to
undertake my unfinished work,
and I renew this request now,
when I am only induced by reason
and virtue.
country and friends to fulfil
this task;
and now that you are returning
to England, you will have little
chance of meeting with him.
and the well balancing of what
you may
esteem your duties, I leave to
you; my judgment and ideas are
already disturbed by the near
approach of death.
think right, for I may still be
misled by passion.
instrument of mischief disturbs
me; in other respects, this
hour, when I momentarily expect
my release, is the
only happy one which I have
enjoyed for several years.
before me, and I hasten to their
arms.
avoid ambition, even if it
be only the apparently innocent
one of distinguishing yourself
in science and discoveries.
these hopes, yet another may
succeed.
His voice became fainter as he
spoke, and at length, exhausted
by his effort, he sank into
silence.
attempted again to speak but was
unable; he pressed my hand
feebly, and his eyes closed for
ever, while the irradiation of a
gentle smile passed away from
his lips.
the untimely extinction of this
glorious spirit?
understand the depth of my
sorrow?
be inadequate and feeble.
by a cloud of disappointment.
may there find consolation.
fairly, and the watch on deck
scarcely stir.
voice, but hoarser; it comes
from the cabin where the remains
of Frankenstein still lie.
power to detail it; yet the tale
which I have recorded would be
incomplete without this final
and wonderful catastrophe.
remains of my ill-fated and
admirable friend.
find words to describe—gigantic
in stature, yet uncouth and
distorted in its proportions.
was concealed by long locks of
ragged hair; but one vast hand
was extended, in colour and
apparent texture like that of a
mummy.
he ceased to utter exclamations
of grief
and horror and sprung towards
the window.
as his face, of such loathsome
yet appalling hideousness.
endeavoured to recollect what
were my
duties with regard to this
destroyer.
and again turning towards the
lifeless form of his creator, he
seemed to forget
my presence, and every feature
and gesture seemed instigated by
the wildest rage of some
uncontrollable passion.
” he exclaimed.
consummated; the miserable
series of my being is wound to
its close!
destroying all thou lovedst.
His voice seemed suffocated, and
my first impulses, which had
suggested to me the duty of
obeying the dying request
of my friend in destroying his
enemy, were now suspended by a
mixture of curiosity and
compassion.
dared not again raise my eyes to
his face, there was something so
scaring and
unearthly in his ugliness.
address him in a pause of the
tempest of his passion.If you
had listened to the voice of
conscience and heeded the stings
of remorse before you had urged
your
diabolical vengeance to this
extremity, Frankenstein would
yet have lived.
” said the daemon.
corpse, “he suffered not in the
consummation of the deed.
anguish that was mine during the
lingering detail of its
execution.
while my heart was poisoned with
remorse.
susceptible of love and
sympathy, and when wrenched by
misery to vice and hatred, it
did not endure the violence
of the change without torture
such as you cannot even imagine.
to Switzerland, heart-broken and
overcome.
to horror; I abhorred myself.
author at once of my existence
and of its unspeakable torments,
dared to hope
for happiness, that while he
accumulated wretchedness and
despair upon me he sought his
own enjoyment in feelings and
passions from the indulgence of
which I was for ever barred,
then impotent envy and bitter
indignation filled me with an
insatiable thirst for vengeance.
that it should be accomplished.
a deadly torture, but I was the
slave, not the master, of an
impulse which I detested yet
could not disobey.
anguish, to riot in the excess
of my despair.
adapt my nature to an element
which I had willingly chosen.
became an insatiable passion.
I was at first touched by the
expressions of his misery; yet,
when I called to mind what
Frankenstein had
said of his powers of eloquence
and persuasion, and when I again
cast my eyes on the lifeless
form of my friend, indignation
was rekindled within me.
over the desolation that you
have made.
buildings, and when they are
consumed, you sit among the
ruins and lament the fall.
would he be the object, again
would he
become the prey, of your
accursed vengeance.
lament only because the victim
of your malignity is withdrawn
from your power.
“Oh, it is not thus—not thus,”
interrupted the being.
conveyed to you by what appears
to be the purport of my actions.
of virtue, the feelings of
happiness and affection with
which my whole being overflowed,
that I wished to be
participated.shadow, and that
happiness and affection are
turned into bitter and loathing
despair, in what should I seek
for sympathy?
sufferings shall endure; when I
die, I
am well satisfied that
abhorrence and opprobrium should
load my memory.
of virtue, of fame, and of
enjoyment.
beings who, pardoning my outward
form, would love me for the
excellent qualities which I was
capable of unfolding.
misery, can be found comparable
to mine.of my sins, I cannot
believe that I am the same
creature whose thoughts were
once filled with sublime and
transcendent visions of the
beauty and the majesty of
goodness.
friends and associates in his
desolation; I am alone.
friend, seem to have a knowledge
of my crimes and his
misfortunes.
them he could not sum up the
hours and months of misery which
I endured wasting in impotent
passions.
not satisfy my own desires.
craving; still I desired love
and fellowship, and I was still
spurned.
when all humankind sinned
against me?
his friend from his door with
contumely?
sought to destroy the saviour of
his child?
an abortion, to be spurned at,
and kicked, and trampled on.
helpless; I have strangled the
innocent as they slept and
grasped to death his throat who
never injured me or any other
living thing.
specimen of all that is worthy
of love and admiration among
men, to misery; I
have pursued him even to that
irremediable ruin.
equal that with which I regard
myself.
deed; I think on the heart in
which the
imagination of it was conceived
and long for the moment when
these hands will meet my eyes,
when that imagination will haunt
my thoughts no more.
needed to consummate the series
of my
being and accomplish that which
must be done, but it requires my
own.
raft which brought me thither
and shall seek the most northern
extremity of the globe; I shall
collect my funeral pile and
consume to ashes this miserable
frame, that its remains may
afford no light to any curious
and unhallowed wretch who would
create such another as I have
been.
which now consume me or be the
prey of feelings unsatisfied,
yet unquenched.
and when I shall be no more, the
very remembrance of us both will
speedily vanish.
or feel the winds play on my
cheeks.
away; and in this condition must
I find my happiness.
this world affords first opened
upon me, when I felt the
cheering warmth of summer and
heard the rustling of the
leaves and the warbling of the
birds, and these were all to me,
I should have wept to die; now
it is my only consolation.
bitterest remorse, where can I
find rest but in death?
humankind whom these eyes will
ever behold.
cherished a desire of revenge
against me, it would be better
satiated in my life than in my
destruction.
extinction, that I might not
cause
greater wretchedness; and if
yet, in some mode unknown to me,
thou hadst not ceased to think
and feel, thou wouldst not
desire against me a
vengeance greater than that
which I feel.
still superior to thine, for the
bitter sting of remorse will not
cease to rankle in my wounds
until death shall close them for
ever.
solemn enthusiasm, “I shall die,
and what I now feel be no longer
felt.
triumphantly and exult in the
agony of the torturing flames.
My spirit will sleep in peace,
or if it thinks, it will not
surely think thus.
”
said this, upon the ice raft
which lay close to the vessel.
lost in darkness and distance.
>> On behalf of the library of
congress, I would like to thank
all of our wonderful readers
today. You did a fantastic job.
Thank you to the Franken reads
organization for bringing the
project to us. Thank you to the
national endowment for the
humanities, and thank you to
everyone around the world who
viewed us today. Good night.
>> I would like to thank Neil,
president of the Keith Shelley
association of America. Thank
you so much for your help.
Appreciate it.